[Music]
for
that
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
welcome to Di day everyone can I get a
round of
applause this is going to be the most
exciting venue today so please stick
around and invite all of your friends um
a big welcome a year ago vitalic butan
shared his philosophy on defensive
decentralized and differential
acceleration the whole idea was
believing in a a future that is vastly
brighter than what we have
today where we are using technology and
bringing in human values and safety
through
acceleration today we'll explore a
series of lightning talks we'll have a
few panels we'll have some deeper dive
sessions and there will be a lot that is
thrown at you we'll go through seven
different core themes within the area of
d back and i' would love to start by
introducing vitalic beerin himself to
the stage the founder of ethereum and
the core thinker behind the diak
philosophy welcome
[Applause]
vitalic okay thank you guys um so I
guess um I will get straight into the
one slide that I have today uh so last
year I wrote this uh post that
introduced this concept of D and in
general was basically responding to a
lot of the discussion that was happening
at the time around Techo optimism the
need to be more optimistic about
technology and to appreciate the very
positive impact that technology actually
has had over the past 10 Millennia and
also the extremely positive potential
that it has over the next century and at
the same time take seriously some of the
risks and also really focus on uh like
which Technologies are going to do the
best possible job of uh giving us the
kind of future that we want while at the
same time minimizing and even actively
fighting against the risks and uh one of
the arguments that I made is basically
that there is this uh important
phenomenon which is the offense defense
balance right basically is it easier to
attack or is it easier to defend and if
you have an environment where it's easy
to attack then you almost inevitably
have this kind of dark hsian choice
between a very powerful Sovereign and a
very destructive state of Anarchy and it
just inherently creates all kinds of
very bad political effects on top of uh
creating constant ongoing risk of
suffering right and at the same time
this is all happening under this
backdrop of this discussion about is AI
itself and particularly super
intelligent AI this a very big and
massive risk if it is should should we
try to slow it down but then if we do
slow it down then slowing it down
forever basically just creates a world
that becomes more and more unstable and
so what is the actually resilient and
actually long-term stable future that we
could be aiming for and uh
I think this uh uh to me is uh a near
and Midterm uh part of the answer right
so in the post that I made last year I
uh talked split up defensive technology
into four categories so the first split
was uh the split between the world of
atoms and the world of bits um so you
know very famous distinction might as
well just know grab it and use it and
within the world of Adams uh split it up
it's
macro and micro and uh so macro defense
basically think about physical
resilience um and we'll have some very
interesting talks uh later today
including um you know topics on how to
massively reduce casualties as if some
kind of extremely terrible disaster
happens to humanity um micro defense
basically means biod defense so anti
pandemics and uh all both myself and a
huge number of other really Fascinating
People will talking about how we can
make the uh our
environments vastly more resilient
against actually existing and even
potential pandemics all without
requiring significant changes in
individual Behavior so you might be
pleased to know that this room is
actually already passively um Airborne
uh disease resistant uh so um for
example over here you have this like a
little fun little box and the box is hea
filter we have like a bunch of these all
around the room and so basically this uh
room be like becomes vastly more safe
against Co against any kind of future
Airborne virus that that comes up
without requiring anyone to actually
notice and the this is one example of
the kinds of uh open and uh widely
widely accessible easily Deployable and
freedom preserving technologies that
weaken deploy that can give Humanity or
an orders of magnitude boost in its
resistance against these kinds of
threats these are things that we are not
doing today and these are things that
with a surprisingly low amount of
investment we could actually do a much
better job at uh so then on the other
side we have the world of bits and the
world of bits I uh I this is a a
distinction that is I believe unique to
me but I talk about the distinction
between cyber defense and info defense
cyber defense is defense against threats
where all reasonable people agree who
the attacker is right so if a defi
protocol gets hacked then obviously the
defi smart contract doesn't agree that
it got hacked because if it did it
wouldn't have it wouldn't have sent any
money out but all reasonable people
looking at the situation will agree that
like well yes there is a hacker or at
the very least someone who used a very
uh unintended mechanism to get uh coins
out to get get coins out of that system
and so we can talk about cryptography we
can talk about formal verification
blockchains zero knowledge proofs you
know what I call the Egyptian god
protocols FHA and aisc and also another
important thing Hardware security and
actually deploying all of those
Technologies and actually even applying
them at the level of operating systems
and making sure that things are much
safer than they would be today and then
info defense so this is uh where
reasonable people can actually agree on
who the attacker is so you know one
man's misinformation is another man's
unjustly suppressed valid point and we
need you know technology to actually
help filter through this information and
help people identify what kinds of
content are more likely to be actually
positive and and what kinds of content
are more likely to be misinformative
misleading things that even they
themselves if they better understood it
would not want to see and but and do so
in a way that does not involve
empowering a centralized Elite that
decides on behalf of everyone else what
is what is good and true and what is bad
and false now that is all vision of
Defense I think one thing that is uh
also important to talk about here is I
added a third dimension in the year
since then right and I call this the
survive thrive Dimension and here we
talk about not just the Technologies to
protect against the bad stuff but also
actually enabling the positive future
right so in the bio side we have
longevity who here is excited about
longevity um so now longevity and then
beside longevity we also have BCI and
BCI is kind of conveniently beside
longevity and open decentralized compute
right so on the left is making sure our
compute is safe and or at the top making
sure our compute is safe at the bottom
is making sure a compute is amazing and
compute and biology together we get uh
we get BCI acceleration and uh I think
one of the really important points that
we're going to make is that there's
actually a lot of ties between these
different spaces it's all one very big
integrated field a lot of the viral
persistence research that's being done
in the context of long covid right now
actually has a lot of tie-ins that are
very applicable to aging right so uh
there's recent new theories that Viral
persistence like actually is a a thing
that's a very big contributor to
Alzheimer's and then BCI better Medical
Technology could contribute it
contributes to fighting diseases it can
contribute to living um longer under
know quote normal conditions and it's
also a uh a BCI accelerator um now
physical abundance uh so you know we
want the uh the big solar Punk cities we
want housing to be uh to be affordable
we want you know housing to follow Mo's
law instead of following e rooms a law
for those who know what those are and uh
and and then you know we wants to go to
space we want everything about our
physical environments to not just be
resilient but also be affordable and
amazing and finally collaboration
technology so even in situations where
people are not attacking each other
where you just you actually do have
reasonable people and communities that
have high trust between each other but
they do want to be able to more quickly
and more effectively agree on things and
come to New consensuses if we want
decentralized collectives to like
actually able to act like life players
and uh make uh bold choices and keep
adapting themselves to rapidly changing
circumstances without that collapsing
into a dictatorship then much more
powerful collaboration technology so
this includes all of the stuff we've
been doing around public goods funding
it includes uh quadratic voting other
forms of voting futarchy all kinds
of all kinds of different governance
ideas right so B basically I think there
there are natural tie-ins at all sides
of this uh between technologies that can
create an environment where everything
is much more safe and much more
resilient by default and an environment
where we have open distributed and
widely available progress for everyone
and so this is what all of the speeches
uh that we're going to see today are
going to be about and uh I'm very
excited to be with you and listen to
them thank you
and so now I'll uh introduce our next
speaker Eli
[Applause]
[Music]
Dorado all
right sides all right there we
go
uh everybody I'm thrilled to be here I
am Eli Dorado I'm a chief Economist at
uh the uh abundance Institute uh and
it's a real pleasure to to be here to
talk about uh diac I'm approaching this
uh through my training as a sort of
political Economist and uh kind of give
going to give a high level overview of
how I see uh this
space uh I want to start by talking
about our instincts for both control and
freedom um we all have these instincts
and in the last few years um with uh AI
Innovation we've seen this kind of like
control narrative or this kind of
control uh uh Instinct be uh on display
like we need an enforced pause uh on AI
development we need to shut down data
centers we need a kill switch uh we need
regulation we need to restrict model
releases or we need to impose banss on
open- Source uh AI models or export
controls
and uh and sort of the counter reaction
to that is like no we need freedom of
speech uh are we really going to
regulate matrix multiplication and this
is a slippery slope to totalitarianism
and then I think that there's an
interesting uh conclusion at the end
that therefore I'm going to not believe
the premise right I'm not going to
believe that there is any risk here and
I think that this uh conclusion is is
very natural uh it's really bad
epistemic hygiene but it's common and we
need to acknowledge it right and you see
this um in completely different contexts
with things like climate right like
people will say like oh I just don't
believe in it because they don't want to
like like accept the the sort of control
oriented uh uh beliefs of of of the
other side um so just because freedom is
good doesn't mean that the problem
raised by the anti-freedom ites is fake
right
so diac approaches both like AI safety
and
biosafety from the perspective that they
are genuine public
goods but
crucially just because we acknowledge
the existence of safety as a public good
doesn't mean that we think the right
approach is to generate it through top-
down coercive means right we're going to
take both freedom and public goods
seriously and I think that's the ethos
behind diac and about a lot of ethereum
uh in
general so that brings us to the next
part of the talk uh the private
provision of public
goods
so uh what is a public good in In
classical economic terms a public good
is one that is neither excludable nor
rivalis so like the canonical example is
the lighthouse right a lighthouse on a
coastline provides guidance for all the
ships uh whether or not they pay right
so so the a lighthouse is not an
excludable good and at the same time one
ship relying on the lighthouse for
guidance does not diminish the ability
of any other ship to uh to rely on the
lighthouse for guidance so the
lighthouse is non-rival RIS so game
theoretically here we have a free rider
problem and we should not expect the
lighthouse to be produced by the market
right you must rely on governments to
produce lighthouses so one of the great
economists of the 20th century uh Ronald
Coos got interested uh in this example
and he decided to actually collect data
on ligh houses in Britain and uh
astonishingly he found that every single
one of them was privately constructed so
we have a free rider problem it's not
supposed to happen uh but every single
lighthouse in in the in Britain was
privately constructed so how can this be
what Co found is that lighthouses were
vertically integrated with ports so
uh the port operator would build a
lighthouse so that people could come to
their port and then they would recoup
the costs through Port port fees and
what this example shows is that creative
structuring uh can turn a public good
problem into a private in private good
provision um another closely related
idea is a common pool resource right
with the classic example being
irrigation systems so um ation systems
are arguably one of the things that led
to the creation of states in the first
place so Carl uh whle in his book
Oriental despotism right advances the
concept of a hydraulic Empire right a
powerful State uh as in Egypt or
Mesopotamia or China that's built around
irrigation right and and maintenance of
this common pool resource is a public
good and it's worth it to accept some
coercion if it means you get the
benefits of of irrigation um
so just like with the lighthouse there's
a Twist um so later Scholars
particularly uh Elanor Ostrom uh figured
out that many complex irrigation systems
uh like in the Philippines or in this
one in Valencia Spain uh were
cooperatively maintained there was
without an autocrat without you know
this one goes back a thousand years uh
and and so she won a Nobel Prize for
figuring out uh the conditions under
which uh such cooperation is possible
um another example of non-coercive
public good provision is standard
setting uh so standards are a public
good but because the value of the
standard goes up when other people use
it there's an incentive to cooperate in
in standard production uh standard
development so um one of the explicit
powers reserved for the government in
the US Constitution is to develop
standards but it turns out that private
uh standard setting happens all the time
uh this is an example from ietf but
we're here at Devcon and uh ethereum
itself uh involves a lot of
cooperatively produced uh
standards um I'm not going to do a long
spiel on on each of these modalities but
there's a lot of different ways in which
um public good production can be
incentivized without relying on sort of
centralized top- down government
coercion um we've talked about like the
first three already but you can think of
a lot of like open-source software uh
development as scratching an
um sometimes people do things to
accumulate Prestige uh sometimes people
give money to to causes they believe in
uh my organization the abundance
Institute is a 501c3 nonprofit our
budget is fun entirely funded by donors
who get very little public recognition
usually usually they don't want it and
they give just because they believe in
the mission um Norms like politeness or
not engaging in petty theft are are also
a source of U of public goods and and of
course of course uh you know mechanism
design is an important one for ethereum
right we can think of consensus as a
public good and the consensus protocol
as a as a mechanism that incentivizes
coming to
consensus so public goods like AI safety
and bios safety uh can be provided non-
coercively without government
involvement and it happens all the time
uh and it's possible that by some
accountings most public goods are in
fact privately produced
um and so now I want to show the flip
side uh when public goods and
particularly safety is provided
coercively top down by the state the
results are often pretty bad um so let's
look first at nuclear
energy uh in the 1950s and 60s we
experienced cost reductions as we uh as
we deployed more uh more nuclear plants
so this is common in industry it's
called The Learning rate and then in the
19 70s the trend reversed um and costs
started to to explode right so initially
it began in the early 1970s with
environmental regulation and then it
accelerated in response to the Three
Mile Island incident in 1979 which by
the way like nobody was harmed by that
incident at all
um uh another domain uh which uh
metallic referenced uh is in which
safety regulation has had enormous costs
as pharmaceutical development so um and
and by the way this is uh adjusted for
inflation just like the last chart was
also um so these higher costs of
bringing drugs to Market represent
thousands of missing drugs right we're
missing thousands of drugs and people
die because of the lack of of drugs um
but these people are not identifi
identifiable uh victims and my friend
and former Professor uh Alex tabarok
calls it the invisible graveyard of
people people dying because of lack of
of uh drugs brought to
Market um aside from nuclear and far
Pharmaceuticals the other major industry
that is regulated via like pre-market
approval is Aviation so everyone thought
like after World War II that there was
going to be a a growing uh personal
aviation industry that like anybody
people coming back from World War II
like new how to fly they could buy uh
Surplus military airplanes and and you
know we would all just have essentially
flying cars that just personal aircraft
that would take us wherever we wanted to
go um and it you know could have
happened but we had uh in increased
regulation at at a couple different
points along the way here in the mid
1960s and early 80s and this strangled
the industry um
unfortunately uh FAA has recognized that
they've gone too too far with personal
aircraft regulation they're beginning to
actually loosen the rules and it
something that's super interesting is
that they actually think that loosening
the rules for a category called light
sport aircraft will onet increase safety
through both uh through both Innovation
uh so the more you innovate the the
safer the aircraft get but also through
increasing the changing the composition
of of the fleet and and sort of
increasing the use of manufactured
airplanes this is a way that
uh deregulation can lead to um to
actually higher levels of safety and
it's interesting to see a major uh
Federal
regulator um recognize
that um so there's a lot of reasons a
lot of a lot of different examples in
which coercive safety regulation doesn't
actually make us safer so um we talked
about nuclear but let's compare it to
Coal so so we have um nuclear is is
highly regulated highly safe and
meanwhile we have coal plants still
operating and um contributing to to
thousands and thousands of deaths I I
estimate in the US we have about 16,000
deaths a year from coal emissions which
is like 5
911s uh every year and everyone's
apparently okay with that and but but
not with not with uh bringing uh making
lowering the bar for nuclear plants um
you know
uh experimental drugs uh can be
certainly can be unsafe but um a lot of
times drugs are substitutes for other
medical procedures and if you have to
have a a surgery or a hospital State
those are risky also and we don't we
don't balance the risks uh in those in
those kinds of um we don't make that
comparison in our regulatory system um
one thing that strikes me as really
interesting is uh in Europe you can buy
a contact lens from a vending machine uh
but in the US you have to you have to uh
you have to go it's not safe to do that
so you have to go to a an optometrist
and get a prescription first before
you're allowed to do that and so it's
thin thinly veiled
protectionism um there's research that
shows uh by an economist named Parker
Rogers that shows that deregulated and
downregulated medical devices are
actually safer than than the sort of
more regulated device types he looks at
cases where device types are uh are
where the regulation changes on the
device types and he finds out that the
the less regulated types increase entry
into the market they increase
competition and they um and and
ultimately they turn out to be both
safer and
cheaper and uh and I already mentioned
like the over regulation of manufactured
aircraft means that people select for
experimental aircraft a lot of times
amateur homebuilt
uh
aircraft so the background here uh among
all and all this
uh all this Carnival of uh of of of
stagnant uh negative effects from safety
regulation is uh what's called the Great
stagnation um this is a period in the US
and much of the West know uh known as
the great stagnation and if we hadn't
experienced it beginning around
1973 uh the US would be about twice as
Rich today uh as as it um as it is so
it's a major major economic
event and a lot of my work focuses on
ending the great stagnation by enabling
innovation in sort of these four sectors
Health housing energy Transportation
which together make up about half of the
economy in the US and I think of
stagnation as the result of sort of
three separate pathologies but like one
of them is the way that we do uh safety
regulation in the west I think the other
is is sort of more generalized vitrac
and then protectionism but uh today
we're talking about safety and um
and so so yeah so safety the way we this
sort of top- down model of safety is is
a major cause I
think so
it's worth thinking about an alternative
to that and that alternative I I believe
is to
build
um I think that the responsibility is on
us to show that there is another way if
we don't have a good answer for how to
deal with real or perceived risks in a
decentralized and non-coercive way
people will continue to agitate for the
coercive way right and
uh you know I'm showing these modalities
again for the different ways that we can
uh we can sort of privately or non-
coercively or non-top down uh provide
public goods and we can think about how
we can apply each of these to different
aspects of the of the public goods
problem right so um you know maybe there
are safety resources that can be created
um that can be done just via firms uh
that can internalize things maybe
there's um
there are maybe there's a risk that AI
will uh be able to use sophisticated
fishing attacks that need to be
addressed and we can do that through uh
better protocols new standards uh
authentication uh Comm authenticated
communication standards um maybe uh air
filtration systems as as valalik
mentioned can protect against uh
biological attacks but also provide
ancillary benefits in the form of
reduced Stillness so that they don't
require like mandates or or uh you know
top down
regulation so I think another aspect of
the of the solution of the build
solution is to focus on uh concrete and
near-term problems I think a lot of
attention is focused on the most
fanciful scenarios but a lot of the
near-term solutions also have a bearing
on those risks and so working on things
that are concrete and yield tangible
benefits now can uh you know if we ever
if those other more extreme scenarios
ever materialize we can be uh more
prepared for them than than we otherwise
would be by focusing on the
um on some stuff that's more near-term
concrete
tangible and finally um I think a lot of
times people think about you know what
can go wrong with uh with with uh
um with new technologies a Ai and biotch
in particular right and I would think
that this needs to be balanced by what
can go right and I don't mean that in a
trait way that shuts down um thinking
about risks but as um as a counterweight
to the Panic that sometimes people feel
and as a motivation
uh to to build the future and to build
an exciting future that uh that we all
want to
see and so that's uh what I have for
this morning and thank you all very
much thank you so much
Eli so one slide
above we're not going straight we've got
longevity and neurot Technic
so this is not quite the right
slide we're going to one before this one
on longevity and neurotech uh very
excited to welcome Juan Benet to the
stage he'll be talking to us about the
next Frontier in humanity as neurotech
and then we'll follow with a series of
shorter lightning talks that we'll go
through so Juan excited to invite you up
to the stage thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
okay perfect right hey everybody uh very
excited to be here I'm going to move
really fast uh I'm going to talk about
Humanity's next Frontier which I believe
to be uh neurotech uh I'm going to cover
these three things in seven minutes uh
so please pay attention to the slides
not to me because your visual cortex can
absorb way more information um that way
so I'm going to leverage a lot of
imagery uh to communicate a lot I'm
going to talk about three things
neurotech to continue Evolution
neurotech as defensive acceleration and
the rough road map for neurotech
neurotech can be a a solution to
mitigating and curing many diseas
diseases and disorders of various sorts
both neurological things and many other
kind of um nerve damage type issues it
can also lead to better self-regulation
of our minds of our bodies and of our
moods and um of our decisions so we by
having the ability to upgrade our brains
we'll be able to do everything we do uh
hopefully better uh we can also do
things like restoring Mobility restoring
senses like sight and senses like
hearing uh this was the realm of sci-fi
in the 20th century it is happening
today and many people are already the
beneficiaries of these kinds of
Technologies you will see this ramping
up over the next 5 to 10 years now after
repair uh we can start enhancing our
senses um it's just an accidental fact
of evolution U that we have the
particular senses that we have or the
particular capabilities that we have now
that we have uh certain Technologies we
can now start enhancing our capabilities
and being able to see um a wider
Spectrum being able to hear wider
spectrum and so on we can also start
using these systems to enhance our
thought we can level up how we ourselves
um think we can also improve the
connectivity between ourselves so think
of uh the ability to actually have
something like telepathy this is this
was science fiction in the 20th century
it will become science fact in the 21st
century uh the Corpus colossum is the
way that the two loes of your brain
communicate to each other they have I
think hundreds of millions of
connections something on the order of
that or hundreds of millions of neurons
going through maybe the connections
there's many UD higher um but that's
that's how you maintain a sense of self
uh you can imagine that um type of
connectivity being able to extend to
other humans and eventually to the rest
of humanity you could actually get um
telepathy to scale uh you also have
better connectivity to computers this
means uh you can think of augmenting
your um your current neocortex which is
itself a brain on top of other brains
right like our evolution in the brain is
a a series of stacked brains that we
evolved over uh hundreds of millions of
years uh and you can think of now adding
um a next layer uh which people commonly
call the the exocortex of being able to
now have other devices um associated
with your your brain then that could
lead to connectivity with the internet
more broadly being able to do things
like recall the information that's in
the internet being able to learn
extremely quickly being able to actuate
um other uh computers in the internet
and so on but the most important thing
and why uh we're here today in terms of
DC day is connectivity to Ai and I'm
going to make the case of this this is
absolutely critical from a um Humanity
survival uh level
scale uh look the diff the future is
extremely different than the past uh
normally Humanity doesn't like to think
about this um we like our normal
day-to-day experience and we believe
this like wonderful fiction that the
world was just always like this and
always will be uh this is just not the
case all of the evidence that we have
about our past shows that um the entire
universe was extremely different
billions of years ago um the planet was
very different uh billions and millions
of years ago and our own species evolved
um through various different paths and
various different time frames even
ourselves after achieving this level of
biological scale uh changed a dramatic
amount over the last um tens to hundreds
of thousands of years ago or even
millions of years ago so who you are
today who uh humanity is today is
radically different than the humanity of
a thousand years ago 10,000 years ago
100 thousand years ago so this is a
totally different um uh evolving
landscape and so we now need to look
ahead into 100 a thousand 10,000 years
into the future and think about where
we're
headed so this is the hard part this is
what I consider to be the most important
graph uh for Humanity today it's a plot
of the Computing scale uh over time uh
and the horizontal lines are different
um guesses as to what you would take
computationally to be able to simulate a
whole brain we're entering what I call
the fund Zone where we're finally um for
many models we should be able to um do
actually model a human brain sometime in
the in the next 10 to 20 years with that
level of computational capacity um if
you're much more conservative than that
and think uh there's maybe many other uh
lower level uh Atomic or or other or
Quantum effects um it might take another
20 years but this is roughly roughly the
timeline this also suggests if you can
do this with the to the human brain
which is you know um neurons are quite
big we're talking about Micron scale if
you can do this in neurons you can
certainly do it in artificial neuron
Nets which are orders the magnitude
smaller and faster meaning there say an
advantage for digital systems um that
just operate dramatically faster and at
smaller scale meaning that if you can do
this to to a human brain in this time
scale you can certainly create an AGI um
much sooner than that order some
magnitude uh sooner in terms of
computing complexity so that means many
years uh before we've seen AI seep into
things we've seen the field accelerate
um and now this is the main uh problem
space uh we've seen capabilities um
human capabilities fall to AI uh there's
like this great graph from our world in
data that shows how um we can build
models and go very quickly from
completely abys performance to
superhuman capability in a matter of a
year or a few years um and so you know
whenever you hear somebody say oh a AIS
will never do that just pull up this
graph and just start pondering at what
point in time uh will that actually
cease to be the case so just do not
believe disbelieve um the the question
of oh AIS are just never going to be
able to do what humans can do just
remember that you know we do things that
that dinosaurs couldn't do um so just
have some humility as a species um the
top right uh graph is maybe one of the
most optimistic Landscapes um a lot of
the people deep in the AI field uh think
that that's roughly what's going to
happen in 2027 2028 we'll start getting
a recursive self-improvement and then
will go from AGI to ASI that's very um
aggressive that I hold a large
probability distribution there but I
think it may take longer it may take
quite a lot longer so we have some
window of time uh to upgrade ourselves
uh to make matters more complicated we
now have a whole bunch of Robotics
appearing so these models even though
you know they might not be as smart as
us are going to be able to actuate uh
bodies um like ours and bodies that are
uh just different than ours in a bunch
of regards so we have both humanid
humanoids coming in the pipeline and
then other things like drones and
whatnot so we're really um headed for a
very very difficult Choice um I like
that story of comparing homor rectus to
Homo sapiens the neand andin homoerectus
was a hominid from um millions of years
ago uh one to million years ago that
expanded Out of Africa the same way that
we did and basically colonized a lot of
the world uh but went extinct um
millions of years later uh hundreds of
thousands of years ago Homo sapiens
neanthal and denisovans each had their
own um uh expansion Out of Africa then
eventually ended up merging and upgraded
into the species that we have today so
um most of us carry some amount of neth
and DNA um and we have this combined
species with the bulk of it being Homo
sapiens so this is the the trade-off
that we have we can go the way of
homerus or we can start merging um and
improving ourselves and so really I
think of it this way we have this
digital Evolution pathway that we're
building and either we're going to make
a another digital species that will
replace us um if we uh insist on
remaining uh entirely biological and and
refuse to enhance ourselves or we can
take the path of um bootstrapping with
neurotech and evolving uh ourselves in
our future uh now I'll touch super
briefly on the road map there's bcis and
you'll see this um you starting to see
this develop um this will enhance over
the next um 5 to 10 years whole bra
emulation is the next Frontier after
that uh I really think these two things
are extremely critical to survive uh
this is roughly the the road map that I
expect in hbr emulation this might be
too late by many accounts um and so if
you want to dramatically decrease uh AI
risk um I suggest you join me in
accelerating the home R emulation road
map and and also the you know BCI road
map we could be doing something kind of
like this potentially even tighter um
and so that's both possible and um
and I think imperative uh we need
breakthroughs in all kinds of tools and
Technologies um and we really need a a
um an R&D environment similar to the one
that we just saw for AI development or
for many other Technologies uh this is
roughly the capital scale that we're
talking about um which means you can
usually um Orient it in terms of um you
know philanthropy and Angel Investors
initially then VC then tech companies
because the the scaling the tens of
billions of scale is just so expensive
that just VC cannot afford this so
either you start generating a cash flow
to grow or you have to tap the tech
companies themselves um so I think if
you um want to defensively accelerate uh
I strongly encourage you to support uh
neurotech either by working directly in
it by funding it um and by uh spreading
the word uh I think a government isn't
going to do it uh for a lot of reasons
and I do think that we need a range of
field building to happen um huge plug
for for a lot of organizations that have
been doing this um and especially um I
think today we think that prizes and
fast grants can greatly accelerate the
field you'll hear from other folks in
neurotech about um a lot of this stuff
in more detail um but specifically a way
that the crypto Community can
dramatically help here um is by
supporting uh the field as a whole
through prices and grants all right
thank you very much thanks thank you
Juan that was amazing really learning
about the next Frontier in
neurotech for those who'd like we would
love to make sure that all speakers go
outside the room so that people can ask
questions please we do encourage asking
questions so if you're excited to learn
more from Juan please join him outside
ask him all the questions you have next
up we're going to learn a bit about
neurons to networks mam is going to join
us on the stage she's from foresight
Institute and we'll share more about
whole brain emulation thank you so
much cool thank you maybe we should get
some oxygen to the brain who wants to
stand up for a couple of seconds Stand
Up and Shake it out just a little bit
cuz you've had had three talks so far
okay
cool right so kod my name is Neeve I am
from foresight Institute I'm chief of
innovation there uh and I care a lot
about whole brain emulation so we are a
nonprofit in San Francisco we're a
501c3 uh and we were co-founded by Eric
Drexler uh who's the Godfather of
nanotechnology and Christine peton who
coined the term open source uh we're 40
years old we're currently an allw woman
team uh and we're looking to accelerate
whole brain emulation so we have five
key Focus areas nanotech neurotech
biotech space Tech and computation with
an overarching track called existential
hope in which we hope to build out
flourishing Futures as chief of
innovation and strategy I oversee the
fellowships the prizes and the grants
and I also build Out Future programs two
of which we will be discussing here
today one is a lowii HB brain emulation
Mouse brain prize which we'll be
launching next year as well as our whole
brain emulation fast grants and grand
prize uh because we are looking to
accelerate this field dramatically uh so
what is whole brain emulation you've
heard about it from Juan but essentially
it's the uploading of the brain onto the
platform why do we want to do this
because with the you know short
timelines we think that this is a really
great way that we might be able to
coordinate and cooperate uh rather than
just yeah evolving essentially uh with
AIS which is what we want to do uh we
also know that neurotech is super cool
uh and that it's going to help us with
modern day science uh and Medicine
cognitive enhancement space Tech who
doesn't want to jump in a spaceship
right now and travel 2 million light
years away I do I think it's kind of sad
that I'm limited to my own physical
being right now uh and I think also that
uh whole brain emulation is possibly
going to help us uh with better
understanding Consciousness uh obviously
just like whole brain emulation has
never been done before the human has
never been mapped before Consciousness
itself has also never really been
defined uh properly so we've got a lot
to cover and this is why it really is
the New Frontier uh so I joined
foresight two years ago one of the first
projects that I really built out was our
first HB brain emulation Workshop this
here was a pretty big deal uh because it
was the very first in the world and what
we did is we brought together the
original authors of uh the road map and
asked them alongside AI alignment
researchers and Neuroscience I like why
is this stagnated the report was written
20 years ago what's happened uh is this
still relevant and what bottlenecks do
we need to overcome the biggest thing
for them was money uh and it was also
because money is really hard to get when
there's a lot of stigma involved with
whole brain emulation it's kind of seen
as a little bit weird a little bit icky
even though as we've just listed there's
a lot of benefits to actually exploring
this and so that's what I can do and
that's what I how I can help them as you
can see here uh it's it's blowing up at
foresight our community is like three
times bigger than it has been and just
keeps growing we actually had to reject
a bunch of people which is pretty sad to
do from a workshop we are already giving
out with our AI safety grants um money
to help people that are working um in
our neurotech for AI so a safer AI with
neurotech these are some of our grantees
I don't know if you haven't read yet but
Mark posted on Les wrong it's very very
good so please take the time to read it
and this is calin's first whole brain
emulation wet lab uh for Mouse brains
pretty big deal because it's the very
first in Europe and we help fund that
with that so we are doing all that we
can to progress things and we're
building out as we go uh why is our
community worth somewhat supporting
because they're pretty cool and they're
pretty good at what they do and they're
all radical moonshots uh so we've now
had two Nobel Prize winners come out of
our Fineman prizes uh as you can see
we've got sir Fraser stod out here he
submitted an essay the ex same essay N9
years later W went on to win a Nobel
Prize and then this year we also had
Nick Baker uh win a Nobel Prize with the
same work that he submitted 20 years
earlier so a little bit more of a long
game there but we're with him all the
way uh and as you might see Jean Hub
who's a pretty big deal in longevity the
amaranth Foundation named his work uh
one of the cornerstones and it's about
essentially replacement therapies for
aging brain tissue uh so we're all on
the Casp there uh great fellows uh
including some of our core Community I
see Michael andrig in the audience he's
working on hi-fi approaches to Mouse
brains at the moment he's very good at
Hardware so you know chat to him if
you're interested please do uh I've got
some incredible fellows this guy here
Akash is working in India using
wearables uh to better understand scent
which is pretty unmapped at the moment
uh but also these bcis are directly uh
capturing EEG data uh and training AI so
that we have better diagnostic tooling
uh for cancer uh which is pretty cool uh
sna Norman is uh working on ultrasound
for bcis with his technology and this is
his frro not only has he mapped uh the
human brain as best as it has been yet
with ultrasound he's also managed to
turn uh ultrasound which is normally
like the size of a fridge uh into a
teeny tiny chip which is this size and
two weeks ago I stood in my living room
with this chip and found my own heart
valve beating on my own TV screen with
it which is pretty huge I mean this is
kind of what happens when you start
exploring things because you start
seeing how Innovation can just like fly
and that's pretty great for Humanity uh
so there are a lot of enabling
Technologies already pushing toward
whole brain emulation if you haven't
seen yet we've just mapped the uh fruit
fly brain for the first time that's
138,000 neurons which is a pretty big
deal uh you should watch the video on
science if you haven't already so that's
why we think it's possible we are
launching next year a mouse brain lowy
emulation prize uh that would be a
million dollars a that incentivizes
researchers to start working in this
field uh it also just yeah it just helps
progress things all together we think uh
the timeline for this to be one is 2 to
three years but actually uh simply
through you know like positive
competition uh this might be one sooner
than that which would be even greater
because when we're looking at shortening
uh timelines we need to do all that we
can to find progress and so that's
what's happening there uh we are hoping
to launch a whole brain emulation fast
grants and grand prize so similar to
metaculus Grants and the co fast grants
we know that we can stimulate an
industry this way we can help people
with their pre R&D proof so that they
can then go to the VCS with the proof
and actually get the money to build it
out but we need a little bit help first
and so that's where we're hoping to lean
in and be able to actually create space
for this uh and obviously like $20
million is like the minimum uh that
we're working with right now uh if we
can grow that further then we can
obviously like help more people and
accelerate this even further so that's
like a big deal for us also a $20
million prize uh for whole brain
emulation of a human brain is definitely
going to get people up in Adam uh so
that's what we think so come chat to me
because I know that we're pretty short
on time sorry if I went a little bit
long uh if you'd like to know more about
what we're doing and also want to get
involved with whole brain emulation
there are a lot of rest but we do want
to do it the right way and we think we
have the community and the means to to
be that uh yeah thank
you thank you n again if you wouldd like
to go outside and have anyone ask
questions please do next up we have our
first remote speaker of the day uh Milan
chich He is building a startup in neurot
right now so can't be with us today but
I would love to bring Millan onto the
screen and we'll be ready to
[Music]
go thanks so much Janine uh see can I be
heard
yes I heard a yes okay
excellent awesome well I'm very sad I
couldn't be there uh in person the
pictures have been absolutely amazing
that I've been seeing uh but it's a an
absolute pleasure to be here virtually
my name as as Janine said is milanovich
I'm the co-founder of integral startup
based in South San Francisco building
deep brain implants to treat severe
neurological and psychiatric disease but
I'm not here today on behalf of my
company but rather as an advocate for
the entire space of neurotechnology
development um I'm often asked to talk
about why I think neurotechnology is so
important but you all are very lucky
that you have already heard Juan and
have Patrick later in this session who
are making that case uh much more
compellingly then I'm sure that I would
so I will just reiterate that I think
neurotechnology is uh indeed a critical
technology to ensure Humanity's
successful transition to an AI world but
moreover even in a world where AI didn't
exist I would contend that
neurotechnology is definitionally the
most transformative sector of
technological progress for enhancing The
Human Experience and improving human
wellbeing in as much as the definitions
of experience and wellbeing are that
they are produced by brains um instead
though I was asked to talk about uh
opportunities and challenges so let's
let's get into that and we'll see if my
AV Works did that did that slide
change G I think that's a yes all right
so um those aren't familiar let me just
give a a far too brief and absolutely
non-exhaustive um context for the state
of the field of neurotechnology as of
2024 so um a neurot technology is any
tool that directly exogenous so not
thinking but somehow externally observes
or manipulates the state of biological
nervous systems and in particular the
human brain is often the one we care
about although animal communication is
is obviously an exciting prospect uh the
definition that I just gave there
encompasses a huge range of Technologies
and also goals that we might want to
achieve with them with respect to the
many goals uh Juan already went over
some of this and to be clear I'm not
intending anyone to be able to read the
list on the left I made it comically
small to make a point uh which is one of
the uh actually kind of biggest
opportunities and or challenges in the
space which is uh unlike a field like
longevity or climate technology where at
least at a high level I think there's
some clarity and and agreement on what
the the goal of the field is neurot
technology is a little bit more like um
the early days of the internet or
speaking outside my expertise compared
to those listening for sure but uh what
I imagine the early days of of the
ethereum ecosystem were like which is um
everyone was really excited about
building you know this platform this
this fundamental technology but it
wasn't you know clear at the outset what
all the killer use cases would be or
even what would be possible um or even
what would be desirable uh neur
technology is a little bit like that
it's something of a marketing problem
for the field um we can we can talk
about a lot of exciting use cases but uh
it doesn't um pull the imagination to
any one Vision so that's both an
opportunity and a challenge depending on
on how you look at things uh on the
right hand side you know there are a
number of existing and emerging
technologies that uh we can use for
obser Ing and manipulating the brain
I'll just highlight some important ones
and and really not going into too much
detail here at all there there's not
time but you know electricity is one
tool that we can use we can place
electrodes in the brain to record the
spiking of neurons or record large scale
electri activity recording the spiking
of neurons is what companies like
neuralink do with their brain computer
interfaces we can also emit small
amounts of current into deep regions of
the brain to change things like mood or
treat Parkinson's disease that's what
the devices that my company works on do
uh we can you know know Place
non-invasive electrodes on the scalp and
record EEG signal so electricity is you
know one important uh lever one one
aspect of physics that's a critical tool
electromagnetic interactions Beyond
electrical current of course also
important whether we're talking about
fmri scans or infrared spectroscopy that
can be used to detect uh blood um either
oxygenation or blood flow changes in the
brain and give a signal of what kind of
activity is occurring at the neural
level but at a at a larger spatial
extent those are really important tools
as well biological um developments
developments in synthatic biology and
biologics are critical tools for for
neurotechnology whether that's Gene
therapies cell therapies immune
therapies antibodies um we can do
genomics transcriptomics proteomics
connectomics all things that we couldn't
do before and that's all enabled by um
well maybe joh genomics but other than
that they're all enabled and enhanced
certainly by um the advance of of
biological uh type tools and
Therapeutics um chemical uh
interventions of course by far the
world's most wide used neurot
Technologies we're all familiar with
coffee and and psychedelics um
ultrasound a few people are probably
familiar with ultrasound but it's a very
exciting emerging technology if uh you
know among people in this audience if if
you need one takeaway from this talk to
look cool at the neurot technology party
just uh go read a little bit about
ultrasound trans cranial focused
ultrasound for um stimulating the brain
and uh functional ultrasound imaging
someone already in a previous talk
mentioned Forest focused research
organization that's working on that
technology among many academic groups
doing great work there and that's a
functional ultrasound imaging is useful
technology for um observing the state of
the brain a really exciting um emerging
modality that's it's going to unlock a
lot I think um there's also peripheral
simulation so that's using uh signals
going in and out of of the body's own
nervous system so flashing lights in the
eyes or uh playing sounds in the ears
has recently been shown to be um very
promising results I should say you know
they're not not uh cases and fully
closed on it yet promising results that
it can slow the progression of
Alzheimer's there's a company called
Cognito you can look up regarding that
and I'm not actually sure if it's
happening now or if it's going to happen
soon but meta reality Labs will be
showing off their um bracelet uh EMG
system uh for uh controlling I think I
think the r gear but another example of
using the peripheral nervous system the
you know afferent and efferent Pathways
from your brain to um as a form of
neurotechnology and then the last one
which is really a catchall and a little
unfair because it's it's kind of the
most exciting area but is combinations
of all the above so there are many
neurotechnologies and many the most
exciting ones which are all
uh implemented by com combining those
modalities that I listed so uh
optogenetics for example is an example
where we use biological interventions to
make neurons sensitive to a specific
frequency of light to which they're not
normally sensitive and then we can use
lasers to stimulate their activity um
there's also exciting work using
ultrasound to burst tiny bubbles in the
the bloodstream those bubbles containing
chemicals and so that's a way of
combining chemical intervention and an
ultrasound intervention and lets you
release uh drug molecules in a very
specific spatial location in the brain
so you can play the combinatorial
explosion game and get a bunch of really
exciting Technologies um that way uh
which is um where a lot of the most
exciting work is is happening uh can I
change the slide I can't um but this
also is a good chance to highlight maybe
the central challenge uh in
neurotechnology which is in general it
is really hard to know what technology
will enable what use cases this is a
consequence of having a very
impoverished understanding compared to
what we would like of how the brain
works in the science fiction limit you
know we would just be able to control
every neuron uh in a second time
resolution all the time but practically
speaking that's impossible trade-offs
have to be made and so uh there will
always be trade-offs around signal
quality latency with the external
computer system or sensors cost power
spatial Precision risks of side effects
you know whether there's a surgery
involved or not um implanting many tiny
electrodes for example here is you know
one thing we do know uh you know is is a
way we can um you know decode motor
intent for example and similarly we all
know that if we drink you know coffee we
can change our energy level but most of
the mapping between the the two sides
here the Technologies and the goals is
is really unknown so that's both an
opportunity and a challenge it's a
challenge to um build technologies that
both help us understand the brain as
well as provide beneficial effects um
and it's also a huge opportunity there's
a ton to explore and and so much to be
discovered um let's see I guess moving
swiftly on here so what are some of the
you know larger scale opportunities and
challenges beyond the technical in the
space right now the big trends affecting
the space one I would say is there's a
there's a huge cultural and Regulatory
change uh in the world especially when
it comes to psychedelics and molecules
like MDMA um there's greatly expanded
funding there's greatly expanded
interest in neurot technology overall um
and I think in particular the um
reevaluation of the the prohibitionist
era against drugs in in the 20th century
is um reopening the door to Independent
research and experiment ation um
ultrasound in particular which I
mentioned before uh is its noninvasive
nature makes it ripe for you know more
independent researchers lower cost
experimentation um and you know when it
comes to developing you know kind of
mapping the the technology and the use
case side as in the previous slide um
there's the volume of experiments the
number of people trying new things is is
really a big unlock in the same way that
you know we really hard to make progress
on um on software projects if you know
we're also working off of Main frames
and and no one you know could access
them if you wanted in a university right
everyone having laptops is a huge unlock
so I'm not advocating that anyone do
anything unsafe with ultrasound by any
means but it's a kind of technology
which has the potential you know if it's
if it's validated a little more um to uh
really lead to an explosion in
independent research I think we're only
a few thorough blog posts or YouTube
channels away from a whole independent
psychon Renaissance enabled by
ultrasound and that's really exciting
but again there's a challenge as with
any technology which is more potency is
also more potential harm and so um I
think we need to be really careful about
uh how as a neur Technology field of how
we go forward so we avoid what happened
with psychedelics in the in the 20th
century um in addition I think uh AI
obviously is going to play a huge role
not only just helping us do literature
search and uh engineering challenges
like chip design would be a massive
unlock for for many of us working in
neurotechnology but um one thing I want
to highlight is it can often be hard to
know if a neur technology is having the
desired effect and uh you know
benchmarks that are built for AI are
actually useful for um a benchmarking
human progress as well so there's
there's a nice Tailwind that we get on
the nech field for assessing human
capability
um there's also uh you know just uh the
fact that a challenge really um is about
an opportunity is that it's really hard
to beat existing neurot Technologies
it's hard to be better than coffee it's
hard to be better than a keyboard as a
BCI so that's a challenge we have to
build really good technology and get
creative about the use case but it's
also um an opportunity um and lastly I
want to mention this that's why I won't
linger but the cost and and risk of
developing Technologies it's quite
staggering and there's a bunch of um new
interest and new funding models of
science new ways of of doing research
that I think are going to be necessary
if we want to fund the kind of unusual
uh hyper interdisplinary work that is
required to ship most neurotechnologies
and and I'm hoping there's some um you
know ways that the the Dak and community
and the deathcon community can
contribute to new ways of doing science
uh and I would love to hear about what
those are um so with that I'll just yeah
encourage uh everyone as as wanted uh to
to try and get involved neurotechnology
is a delightfully interdisciplinary
field there are useful things to do for
everyone there of course is engineering
there's electrical engineering
biological engineering medical device
engineering mechanical engineering
software engineering um you everything
uh up and down technology stack um even
geoengineering there believe it or not
there are actually useful papers on
ultrasound written by geoengineers so
truly whatever your skill set uh we have
a we have a role for you um of course
scientific expertise design skills
education just you know explaining as I
kind of said before the lack of a one
clear claran obvious goal for neurot
technology means that explaining it to
the world is isett important so you know
artist designers Educators it's all
critical you know my compan is hiring
all my friends companies are hiring we
all need talent and it's a a hard space
to um to to make as exciting as other
ones these days but I think it's it's
utterly important so please get in touch
with me my email is easy to find you
know I get lots of emails asking how we
can get involved and I do try to respond
to all of them so please reach out um to
me or anybody else and uh if you're
interested in the space we would love to
help find you an on-ramp to working with
us I think that's my time thank you so
much Mill really appreciate it as he
said there's a lot of ways to get
involved in neurotech next up we have
another remote speaker and then we'll go
back to inperson speakers we've got
Patrick who will be speaking about neuro
Ai and AI safety thank
you thank
you my name is Patrick Mino and I'm a
computational neuroscientist of uh
Vision originally
uh I was also a data scientist and I've
worked on brain computer interfaces and
Industry and I'm currently working at
the amaran foundation on a brand new
ambitious project uh to make AI safety a
reality so the amaran foundation was
founded by James Fel who's one of the
pillars of the ethereum community and it
funds ambitious research in longevity
and Neuroscience and uh is not working
in AI safety so of course AI has really
changed the way that we act with uh with
text we've also seen tremendous advances
in the applications of AI and biology of
course Alpha fold recently won uh the
Nobel Prize uh for
physiology uh and we've seen
applications also on entertainment uh
including these uh dogs which uh which
are puppies playing in the snow which
are figments of sora's
imagination uh but of course there's
much to worry about when it comes to AI
because it does pose a potential
existential TR so powerful AI uh could
pose a risk of Extinction and so we saw
in this recent petition that everyone
from the fathers of deep learning to AI
safety researchers to CEOs of AI
companies as well as members of the Dak
and eak communities uh really congregate
around this idea uh that we should
really mitigate that risk and towards
that end uh we really want to create uh
safer technologies that can replace uh
this technology that is potentially very
powerful but is also um understood uh to
pose significant safety risks now why
would we have a path towards safer AI by
learning from Neuroscience well current
AI systems are really trained on
Behavior so if you look at an llm that's
trained on the hard work of hundreds of
thousands of people that have poured in
um their work true text and we learned
to imitate that but that doesn't contain
all of the nuances the processes that
were're able to create that text we
could instead uh learn information
directly from the brain and learn to
imitate the activity of the brain in
order to create potentially safer AI
systems so let's break this down a
little bit um we know that there are
existing neurot Technologies uh which
have enabled large scale uh neuroscience
uh things like neuropixels um the
neuralink implant device functional
ultrasound is coming on board uh things
like diffuse Optical tomography uh new
advances in in
conomics and these might allow brain
imitation learning now we know that
humans know how to explore safely
they're robust whether it's
adversarially or out of distribution
they cooperate sometimes they know how
to reason about other humans our world
is is built for humans and those
capacities are really a function of the
inductive biases which are embedded in
our brains so if we could back this out
uh we could uh potentially better
constraint AI systems than we would uh
be able to using Behavior alone so in
order to build a path towards brain
imitation learning uh I like to think
about three distinct system sensory
motor and cognitive so on the sensory
side it's been known for a long time
that the representations inside of
convolutional neural Nets which are
trained for image recognition are
remarkably similar to those that we find
in visual cortex in particular in the
ventral visual stream however they do
diverge in important ways in particular
when it comes to out of distribution
inputs and adversarial inputs so we
funded work at UH Stanford University
which is called the Enigma project to
really build digital twins of the visual
cortex so animals are trained to watch
movies for settle hours and uh using a
lot of this data it's possible to stitch
together a model that captures the
relationship between the input that's
coming on the retina and the
representations which are computed by
the neurons in that brain and therefore
distill a more adversar robust out of
distribution robust uh digital twin uh
that can be used in Lo of the current
image recognition systems that we use
when it comes to motor cortex uh we've
seen tremendous advances in virtualizing
bodies uh so people use Technologies
like uh X-rays and microct and com focal
Imaging uh to create basically parts
list of uh of animals and then to
painstaking work reconstructing their
skeletons uh as well as the their
tendons uh eventually allowing them to
virtualize them in environments like
moku so between that and the advances
that we've have seen in robotics it has
become much more possible uh to create a
link between the kinds of cognitive
representations that we see in the brain
uh and eventually the output of the body
and its interaction with the
environment so finally on the cognitive
side uh there are hundreds of thousands
of hours of available data from across
all kinds of brain modalities on arives
like uh Dandy Hub as well as open neuro
which brings about this possibility that
was floated recently uh by Andre kathi
which is what you would really want to
build an AGI is the inner thought
monologue of your brain if you had a
billion hours of that AGI would be here
roughly speaking and that AGI would have
learned uh the same kinds of properties
which are so crucial for the brain that
allows them to be safe and therefore
would form a safer kind of
AI now if we want to uh have an idea of
what this world will look like look no
further than fly Neuroscience so over
the past few years uh people have been
able to freeze the brains of flies to
chop them up in thin slices scanning
them segmenting them reconstructing the
tracks inside of their brains virtualize
their bodies and track the entire visual
input from uh the first synapse uh down
into the central parts of the brain to
really understand what's going on inside
of the fly's brain and that's what we
think because when we think of a virtual
fly but imagine if we had that for
virtual humans that would have the Dual
property of really advancing
Neuroscience as well as really um
creating a new kind of
AGI now it's not going to be an upload
like you would see in The Matrix or in
sanun pero but would rather be an
amalgam of the activity of many
different systems which are wired up uh
together but would nevertheless be a
crucial artifact to build a safer path
towards AGI
so to build this we need lots of brain
data a zoo of virtual bodies and
environments to leverage the existing
data uh as well as bringing uh extra
data from closed archives and to
accelerate cost cting data acquisition
Technologies including conomics and
wireless
electrophysiology so we have a road map
that's coming up in uh about two weeks U
that's called Nur AI for AI safety it's
100 pages of deep technical deep dive uh
into this field if you want to hear
about its release uh please uh follow me
on X uh for for news on that I'd like to
thank my co-authors Nicolo anelli and
Joan Pang as well as our founder James
Fel for the opportunity to work on this
thank you very
much thank you so much Patrick that was
wonderful now I'm going to introduce
Mackenzie Dion to the stage who is the
founder of triplet Imaging she's going
to give us more of an
into neurotic and the exciting things
that are happening in the field welcome
Mackenzie to the
[Applause]
[Music]
stage cool um I okay um I'm going to be
giving just a high level overview of
neurotech so kind of some heris discs
for thinking about neurotechnologies for
people outside of the field key results
and then some of the opinions I have on
it um a bit of context on my background
I joined Nur link after finishing school
um I left pretty quickly to help start a
brain cryopreservation company called
cradle um where I worked on Neuroscience
related projects there and um over the
summer I started a new company called
triplet Imaging that discovered a new
type of optical effect um to image and
manipulate matter at a microscopic scale
Rel uh replacing 200k lasers with $5
lasers um and we're applying this across
biology and
Neuroscience um so I just want to give
some high level heuristics for people
who are interested in neurotech but
don't really know what to think about it
so you know there's invasive versus
non-invasive um which requires some type
of medical procedure you know like
through the skull or under the skin
medical versus consumer so I think the
key thing to consider with medical is
that this requires some type of FDA
approval which can you know add upwards
of like hundred million dollar to
bringing the technology to patients um
also add multiple years of clinical
trials and then neurom modulation versus
Imaging which is fairly obvious but
driving neural activity versus recording
and interpreting it um and while these
are separate tracks of Technology
development I think it's worth noting
that um neuroimaging technology is
required to do neuromodulation
effectively in order to localize where
in the brain you want to stimulate um
but I would say developing working
neuroimaging technology is um fairly
easier and more tractable than neurom
modulation um for a couple reasons but I
think kind of the the highle ones are um
neuroimaging you simply just need um
knowledge of like correlation of neural
activity to some to some stimulus or a
report from a patient um where
neuromodulation you need to sort of
understand like causality in the brain
um neuromodulation also generally
requires higher resolution targeting
than um neuroimaging for sort of
interpreting the the meaning of of
neural data um and previous speakers
have touched on this but available
available modalities are sort of you
know all the the all the fundamental
like physical forces um and then kind of
at the end it's worth noting that
introducing genetic engineering into
neurotech development will sort of
change what's possible in this field um
making neurons sensitive to light or
sensitive to high frequency sound
ultrasound um really kind of like
unlocks new applications and and right
now that's mainly in the research phases
but I think there probably are some very
early stage efforts um to bring that
into clinical
applications um and I think there's like
a lot of especially in technologist
circles a lot of lore and excitement
about the the future of neurotech but
you know as someone working in the field
today I would say you know 99% of
neurotechnology is being developed for
medical purposes and I think the people
within these companies see themselves as
working on uh you know a medical device
for someone with you know significant
you know physical or cognitive
disability and so I just wanted to touch
on some of some of the kind of key
results which I think previous speakers
have referenced as well but um up at the
top right was a man who was actually
fully paralyzed um
and he's being able to walk again due to
a spinal cord um prosthetic as well as a
brain computer interface um kind of in
restoring physical capabilities there's
also been restoration of speech from
thought to text um computer use so
cursor control which um if you saw the
nurlink demo I think that's a good
example of that um trimers from
Parkinson's and even some efforts to
actually restore Vision to blind people
so I think the available Technologies
today are more like very vague you know
uh distinguishing between different
objects but nurlink and then also uh Nur
Link's former president are both kind of
going after this but they're taking
different technological approaches and
on the um psychiatric and cognitive side
there's been invasive and non-invasive
really promising results for treatment
resistant depression um using uh
transcranial magnetic stimulation um as
well as invasive electrical stimulation
and um this bottom right photo is from a
lab at Stanford doing something called
the saint protocol which I think reduced
uh treatment resistant depression uh by
like 95 to 98% something like that um
yeah and then I I think it's like worth
noting that I I mentioned this already
but I would say even I my bet would be
like even within nurlink like the vast
majority of employees like see
themselves as as working as medical
device companies I don't think there's
actually been a clear Bridge from the
way we we talk about neur here and how
and you know the people actually on the
ground developing it um
um I think this is a really poignant
example of of medical results um this
man has ALS and he has a cortical
implant in the region responsible for
speech production and um he's saying
here he's communicating with his family
in this video actually this is from
Sergey sisy's Lab at UC Davis um I have
been waiting for this um and I think
what's really cool is there's been you
know several iterations of this
technology but actually the introduction
of language models in facilitating um
decoding I think helped expand the the
vocabulary to 125k words and it actually
performs better than all um Speech to
Text uh types of Technologies like Siri
for example I think it's like 98%
accurate um and then I just want to say
like really high level I think for
futurist communities a big part of the
the kind of contemplation of neurotech
is you know will this help humans um
become more resilient as AI accelerates
dramatically um and sort of kind of
contemplating like yeah is this is this
kind of compatible with like the the DC
perspective um and just to sort of
ground it in like what's happening today
for um how AI is facilitating neurotech
development um as mentioned it's
improving decoding pretty dramatically
so this is frari data um the top two
images are um image the actual images
that subjects were looking at and the
bottom two were um reconstructions from
their neural neural data and um that
those were greatly facilitated by the
incorporation of a diffusion model into
facilitating decoding um but I would say
there's basically like no interesting
progress in how um integration of AI can
better facilitate neuros stimulation and
I think like kind of the gold standard
for a really interesting demo would be
like Could you um transfer
representations in a model into a
biological brain um I know of like some
very early stage efforts to get this
going but like I I haven't really seen
anything for it um and then just to to
wrap up um I I didn't talk about
consumer neurotech at all so you know
neural neurotech developed for the
general public without uh a medical use
and I would say because I actually don't
think there's like anything interesting
there yet um I would expect the first um
generally use consumer neurot technology
to be non-invasive neuroimaging for
computer use but there's actually like
very few um if you kind of look at the
the bandwidth and the latency that you
need for kind of high bandwidth Clos
Loop computer interaction that actually
does better than our existing tools um I
think there's only a couple technical
paths forward and I'm kind of hopeful or
would expect there'll be like some
breakthroughs in this in the next maybe
fiveish years familiar with some people
working on it but I really think for it
to be integrated into broader Society it
does actually need to outperform
existing tools um and then I'll just
close and say that uh you know I'm
working in like a very very technical
field right now but I'm always kind of
wondering like how um I'm interested in
developing Technologies to you know
enhance human empathy human
self-expression and and um communication
between people and um I'm trying to kind
of understand how neurotech can fit into
or enhance that if at all um and I think
you know this merge with AI narrative
will definitely strengthen and there's
you know a lot of interesting aspects to
that but I'm I'm really interested in
sort of understanding and deepening yeah
the kind of first- person Human
Experience but um yeah and I I have like
a a very long like kind of technical
explanation of the different heris that
I mentioned that I can kind of share
online later at some some point but yeah
thank you thank you
McKenzie that was awesome next up we
will have Nathan Chang talking about the
acceleration Mo road map for longevity
take it
[Music]
away hi my name is Nathan Chang and I'll
be talking about the longevity
acceleration road map a technical plan
to solve aging
this road map is a foundational project
at the lbf and it's intended to help
guide uh newcomers to longevity space I
can only do a speedrun now but if you're
interested in the full thing check out
the link below okay so the lbf is a
nonprofit that I co-founded to mobilize
the world's top talent to work on
solving
aging but why work on Aging uh well
simply because life is good and death is
bad and if you ask what is the thing
that causes the most death uh it's aging
so so by far aging causes the most death
75% of deaths worldwide are caused by
aging and this comes in the form of age
related diseases like heart disease
cancers Alzheimer's Etc and this is an
emergency uh all 8 billion humans are on
a exponential trajectory towards
physical and cognitive decline and
ultimately
death but if we can solve aging we can
Envision a future where people can live
for as long as they want in Peak health
and
function but if you want to see this
future uh like personally uh we need to
do something about aging today so where
is the plan to solve aging well when we
first started we couldn't find any clear
plan to solve aging uh so we had to make
one on our own and in our plan we wanted
to uh have three key features so one uh
we wanted to exclusively focus on Direct
research and Technology paths that could
solve aging completely and uh two um we
wanted to uh focus on specific well
defined key technical objectives and
um we wanted it to be actionable so um
have a good overview of projects in the
space so that people could easily uh
join or start them or or fund them okay
so we got a lot of input from uh
scientists researchers and entrepreneurs
in the field and uh we identified three
main strategies that could posibly uh
solve aging so one is biostasis this
means uh pausing biological time uh and
this is typically with uh
cryopreservation at low temperature or
chemical fixation uh two
replacement so replacing old Parts with
young um and most promising full body uh
transplants plus gradual brain
replacement and three Advanced
bioengineering so understanding and
modeling biology and aging um and also
developing genetic and cellular uh
engineering
tools okay so one mental model to kind
of understand these three technology
paths is a 2 by two Matrix so in one
axis you're trying to solve aging uh or
or by time and the other axis you're
either trying to um understand aging or
uh bypass aging like the complexity of
Aging altogether and just as a side note
um some of these Technologies can also
be thought of General defensive
biomedical Technologies so um for for
example in like uh replacement um could
be useful for things Beyond aging so if
you got in a car accident uh replacement
could be life saving okay so let's take
a look at biostat this um so the
strategy here is to pause biological
time until the future where uh medical
Technologies can solve aging um but uh
you know there's a number of key
objectives in this rad map I can't go
over all of them so I'll just highlight
one of them so um rapid even rewarming
so this is needed to uh prevent ice
formation and and the Damage associated
with that but also to um prevent uh
thermal fracturing so when you're uh
trying to bring a body or or brain from
low temperature back to to room
temperature so there's a number of
different projects in in startups in the
space but there uh still needs to be a
lot of work to be done okay let's talk
about replacement so um this strategy is
really divided into two parts so there's
uh replacing the body with a clone body
and a knockout of the brain but then two
for the brain uh you gradually replace
the brain um with young neural tissue
graphs bit by bit kind of like in the
style of the ship
ofus now in the body um this really uh
has only become Within Reach uh since
201 18 when Chinese scientists
demonstrated the first successful
cloning of primates and uh it's
plausible that this could be extended to
humans okay but uh you can create a
clone body but you you don't want to
create a brain at the same time a person
so you'll need to construct a a a
genetic construct to ensure that that
the capacity uh to have Consciousness uh
never forms in the cloned embryo and
there's actually already a natural proof
of concept uh for this it's the birth
defect called Hydra and inphy uh where
cerebral hemispheres never form and uh
these bodies actually never have
Consciousness but uh can develop to full
maturity and last uh to put it together
you have have to do some sort of uh head
transplant and uh these have been done
experimentally in the past uh in mice
dogs and monkeys um with survival in
some cases lasting days to to months but
still needs to be improved okay so um
let's move on to the brain uh as said
before you can gradually replace the
brain with uh engineered neural neural
tissue graphs made from a patient's own
uh ipsc stem cells and um
neuroplasticity of the brain allows
migration of brain functions away from
damaged areas or or um if done uh slowly
and just recently the US rph program uh
hired the leading researcher in brain
replacement Jean habber to lead a $100
million Moon shot program in this
strategy there's um a number of uh key
technical objectives in our V1 road map
uh most of the hard stuff is in the
brain but also in spinal uh cord
reconnection and there's a number of
startups working in this field but uh
most are still in
stealth okay uh we also asked
researchers to estimate the time and
cost to um get a reasonable attempt on
this on this road map and uh they came
up with a a figure of$ 3.6 billion doar
in in about 10 years hey last
bioengineering
um so this is the uh longest and most
uncertain Road it will require the
convergence of four um uh four different
prong so one large scale data collection
um something like a protein Data Bank
but but much larger scale um two um
computational modeling uh which could
include AI models and then three uh
design of genetic or cellular
interventions and for uh delivery of
genetic uh interventions or or cell
cells okay next steps so clearly there's
a lot of work to be done in uh to solve
aging but uh unfortunately there's very
few people or resources trying to um uh
devoted to trying to solve aging um so
if you feel an intense desire to defeat
aging uh definitely join the lbf we're
the biggest Community focused
exclusively on building for indefinite
lifespan extension um we run uh highly
selective intensive Workshop Retreats
our next one is in March in Berkeley
California and um but uh fighting aging
is not just for biotechs and scientists
um we need everyone to get uh Society
aligned on allocating Apollo program
level resources to fighting aging and so
if this resonates with you I'd encourage
you to also join the vitalism community
where we're building a social political
movement uh to make fighting aging and
death hum's number one priority um and
uh our community is organizing the
biggest longevity event in the world
it's going to be um a two-month uh
pop-up longevity City in Berkeley
California in April and May next year
right in uh right next to Silicon
Valley okay so don't wait join us fight
aging and uh if you're interested in any
of these projects check out my uh
profile
thanks thank you
Nathan and that wraps up our longevity
and neurot Tech section next up we're
moving on to decentralized Identity so
take a look at what we've got today a
really exciting group of individuals
will be speaking
and firstly I would love to Welcome
ramco to the stage to talk about
decentralized identity um and biometric
proof of personhood thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you thank
you so proof of human um we've now
talked a lot about how can we make
humans live as long as physically
possible but blockchain chains and
therefore decentralized Finance at the
moment doesn't even know what a human
being is and unlocking this will unlock
a lot of new things just like
decentralized Finance does so proof of
human also known as proof of personhood
it's basically a way to limit account
generation to a few ideally just one
human
being if you add zero knowledge proofs
in the mix you get something that is
substantially more powerful then you get
a way of signing messages as a unique
but Anonymous human this allows you to
for example organize voting mechanisms
where every human can quadratically or
single vote um without revealing their
past voting behavior but with the
guarantee that no one exceeds their
voting limit and you can create social
media platforms where you know that a
person represents a single person there
are no bot farms and so on so what is it
not it is not a capture proof of
personhood by default doesn't give you a
human in the loop guarantee and I would
argue this is a benefit this means that
humans can still use automation to
automate their accounts they can have
their their accounts run by AIS if they
want
to it does however give you civil
resistance spam protection and and a
good form of um rate limiting and why do
we need this well AI which is now very
clear um will make it impossible to
distinguish humans from non-humans based
on just observed Behavior especially in
the digital domain there is also a good
argument to be made that AI will create
fairly massive disruptions in the global
economy and we need to have a way to
address that the way to address that is
to financial Primitives that have at
their core a concept of a human
individual there's a lot of those
Insurance loans pensions Ubi and so on
right now none of these can be
implemented because this score primitive
of a human being is missing on
blockchains so if we add the individ
as a programmable primitive we unlock
all of this another good case is to be
made for enhancing
decentralization if you have individual
humans you essentially have individual
conscious decision makers this is a very
strong form of decentralization that you
can add to any
system why would you not want proof of
personhood a unique human can be just a
proxy for a more precise thing that
you're trying to achieve here um for
example you might not necessarily want
to have a social media platform that is
only limited to human beings maybe you
do want an AGI to be able to add an
account to create an account and join
the
discussion it's kind of the argument
that the internet should be neutral to
whether you're human or a bot or
whatever and the other argument you can
make is that if you really want to be
maximal on privacy you wouldn't even
want to reveal the number of humans that
are in your system which also precludes
these kinds of
solutions that being said there are many
very genuine and very useful use cases
um so let's look at how do we solve this
it's essentially an oracle problem
humans are a physical phenomena so we
need to do some sort of compromise of
our platonic ideal of the cryptographic
world in order to introduce this concept
into to the system and there are three
main approaches the first category is
Authority based where you use some
existing proxy for a unique uh human
being like a passport a credit card a
phone number a mobile phone or some
social media account and use an oracle
to bring this onchain then there are
graph-based methods where
you essentially pick a subset a small
subset of human beings and then go
through some process to verify that
they're indeed distinct this could be
just simple social vouching where you
say that hey I am distinct from my
friends and my friends are distinct from
each other so I'm just going to sign off
on that fact you can have approaches
that are video based I think there's one
where you upload a video online and then
other people can review all of those
videos and make sure that there are
indeed all different human beings I
think this approach will fail with the
current start state of AI and then there
is actually a really cute approach um
where you invite a number of people from
the system to simultaneously solve
captas
and and since a human can only solve one
capture at a time and Bots cannot solve
them this also guarantees you that they
are distinct then a third category is
much more direct um it is directly
testing the property that a unique human
body is associated with this account
through the use of
Biometrics the challenges with this
approach is um biometric are actually
not that strong faces are not as unique
as you think they would be um they're
not unique among identical twins but
even the current state of art cannot
distinguish between more than let's say
a million users um same problem with
fingerprints irises however have an
enormous amount of entrop entropy in
them and we believe at least that with
the technology that we have we can
distinguish billions of people uh this
way so what is the high level strategy
of implementing this so have your
modality um which is either like a
passport uh a biometric you name it you
need some sort of trusted sensor to
capture this uh which could be the
secure Enclave on your passport or this
can be a hardware device that captur a
biometric then the way we do it is we
create secret shares using zero
knowledge proofs so all of this happens
between you and the device uh none of
this information gets revealed this
modality stays in the private domain and
the secret shares get sent to a
multi-party compute setup that then in
the secret domain verifies that these
are distinct from all those who have
registered before so now we've achieved
a modality based
uniqueness without revealing this
modality beyond the uh beyond the owner
then we add an additional layer of
protection on top of the cisum where
instead of now blessing let's say an
ethereum account with being a unique
human we use zero knowledge proofs to
hand out Anonymous credentials which
allow you to sign something as a unique
Anonymous
user um we have implemented this with
three
modalities we offer biometric using a
device called the orb that you'll
probably see around here somewhere
um we offer a passport base and we also
have a device base um that's the lowest
TI that's basically you have a unique
mobile
phone as I said a very important
principle to us is that the modality is
kept private to the user
exclusively and we offer uniqueness with
strong anonymity by
default um I'm Remco I'm leading the R&D
at the world Foundation thank you all
and let's have an interesting discussion
on proof of person
[Applause]
rco and next up we have Martin who's
going to be talking about resilient
money with
[Applause]
circles yeah all right so I will
um give the graph-based uh approach um
to to Identity but actually uh circles
um didn't um yeah didn't start as a as a
identity uh project with a goal to
create an identity standard but instead
it started or it is a project about
money uh and about creating a fair and
resilient form of money and essentially
it creates this identity graph based
identity as yeah almost a byproduct um
so therefore I will quickly do the money
part and then uh connected to the um
decentralized identity part and here
kind of just this uh quote
uh from yeah Professor Lear kind of just
thinking about what money actually is
and realizing it is um a social
construct and therefore uh it is a
choice and it's not a god-given thing uh
and it is absolutely something that well
we can modify and we can essentially
modify it any way we want and we can
have other um
choices so let's quickly do this
exercise and just pretend uh we want to
design money right now um
and reasons for that I mean uh in the
crypto world it's I think it's not
unheard of that the dollar or existing
currencies might fail so just from a
resilience perspective it might be good
uh to have an alternative but but just
again let's let's just pretend okay we
are on an island now we are 100 people
uh we somehow stranded there we don't
have money and kind of we we think well
would be a good idea to have money how
would we uh do it so so the very first
approach could be to say okay let's just
give everyone um a thousand
units um but then uh after a couple of
days a group of other people come uh
comes they also get a th000 unit but
then they spent that and the next day or
the day after that group uh left so they
kind of just got the money spend it all
H and left so was that really a good um
approach so maybe
idea to Let's uh let's distribute the
money instead um over time um
meaning per person you get one unit uh
one unit of money um over time so let's
quickly look at that uh so here we see
the um the uh uh money growing um
growing linearly
um and now let's let's say after after
some years we are on this island money
grows linearly the storm hits uh and
unfortunately 80% of the people die so
therefore uh kind of now you have much
more money per person um in the system
and it goes on and goes on and the money
per person in the system grows and grows
so then uh in consequence um the amount
that is newly issued per person
essentially um uh goes towards zero and
then after some time new people arrive
and they are offered to join the system
but they there are already millions of
of of of units of money uh in the system
um and now we offer them to join our
system and say yeah you also get one
unit uh per hour but essentially in
relation to the existing money it's it's
it's essentially nothing
so the conclusion might be old money
must somehow uh disappear over time and
that's how we come up with with the
third uh idea to say okay there is
constant issuance but there's also
constant reduction what we call um
demage and there you get not going into
details but essentially you get a
constant or you always stabilize the
ratio between new Supply and old Supply
that will always converge towards 7%
in this approach and this is kind of
just the balance if you look at one
individual so it goes constant to those
or it approaches those 120,000 roughly
um and here theoretically if after 80
years they die or stop issuing then that
would disappear that money so conclusion
uh supply of circles is converges to
120,000 okay and one one last thing and
then we finally go to the identity part
uh so one one way to look at it is also
to say there's kind of a tax on money um
and if you hold this magic number of 20
100 20,000 then your marginal tax rate
is exactly zero because the new issuance
exactly equals out the 7% demarrage if
you have less than that you have
negative tax so you kind of get more
from the system than you pay into and if
your wealth approaches Infinity then at
least the the tax on money uh uh
converges against those uh 7% because
the new issuance doesn't matter the
issuance per person doesn't matter just
the um the 7% now finally the identity
part um who can create money in this
system um and uh yeah who who can be let
in and in circles the radical answer is
everyone and that also means fake
accounts so you can create uh fake
accounts and or basically just anyone
can create immediately an account that
can issue circles but they are distinct
l so of course you could not say they
issue they I mean if if they could all
issue the same circuit then of course
that currency would be completely
destroyed because just anyone could
create bunch of fake accounts and so
everyone creates their
own distinct version of
circles and now um we form this web of
trust so here person a has 300 a circles
and kind of they are issuing circles at
this rate of one per hour circles person
B issues B circles and now they can
trust each other and trusting each other
means they are willing to exchange their
circles um one to one uh meaning B is is
accepting a circles and is willing to
exchange either accept them or exchange
them against any other Circle they hold
in this case um also B circles so here
let's say a wants to do a a transfer to
C and the important part is C doesn't
need to know a or trust a but as long as
there's a pass between the two then a
can send 100 a circles to B and B
because they are willing to um yeah
exchange a circles for B circles can
forward uh 100 B circles and that's very
important that they forward B circles uh
to C so C is uh person C is just
receiving B circles so circles from a
person they Trust so whether a exists or
not is not relevant to C because from
their perspective they just got paid
circles from a person they trust so
whether a is a is a fake account or not
is is is not um um affecting C and we
will see those those those things uh
even in a larger graph summary three
real three rules of circles it's all
what circles defines issuance one per
hour 7% demage and this um trust system
that I just described now um circles is
a system that was launched in October uh
um 2020 and here is how it looked like
after uh a couple of hours so this is
how the trust graph formed after some
hours that was after um a day and that
was that's how the trust graph looked
after um uh a couple of
weeks so we have that amazing trust
graph already with um over 100,000 um
well hopefully mostly people um and here
just just a real world example so then
circles went into a period of of of
trying to to make that form of money
work here is a a basket on a on a
farmers market that sold for 450 um
circles and here is an actual
transaction of on the left side me um
transacting to that um yeah Power direct
U this is Farmers Market and because
they didn't know me they didn't trust me
but they trusted those uh entities and
there is essentially this trust pass so
that that's how how a trust pass or
concretely a circle transaction looked
um in in in in
practice so now
um yeah essentially circles creates as a
byproduct uh a digital identity system
and we would argue that it does that
well because because it's not the
primary objective or more so speaking so
we are creating this um web of trust but
in previous approaches let's say pgp um
trusting someone didn't necessarily had
an economic meaning in circles it does
have an economic meaning because it says
yeah I'm I'm willing to exchange um I'm
willing to uh accept the circles from
that person that that person's issues
and I'm willing to exchange it against
any Circle I hold and if I do that too
Loosely so let's say a random telegram
uh Channel someone says yeah can you
please trust me and I if I then do that
essentially what it will what will
happen is that I will lose all my
circles because sooner or later Bots
will come and and um and um yeah
generate circles if I trust them then I
end up with their circles that no one
else uh in the network um uh wants so
essentially I end up with unpend circles
which is equivalent to I I lose all my
circles so long story short um Trust has
economic meaning in circles
um but yeah of course the important part
is uh circles doesn't create an absolute
identity it always creates a relative
identity so relative to that group that
initial set you can say those accounts
are likely human uh are likely human but
my take would be that I think there are
very very few uh use cases for absolute
identity and in absolutely most cases
you want relative identity but probably
we can discuss that also more on the
panel later last part uh we are um
upgrading circles slightly to circles uh
2.0 and adding another layer what we
call groups and from an identity
perspective that would probably be
attestations uh here just one more so
circles is or there is this tradeoff
between resilience and efficiency and I
think circuit in its core version goes
maximal resilience so you have all those
different currencies and the idea is
okay if just we three Trust each other
and we we are just connected kind of the
rest of the world cannot harm us and
regardless what the rest of the world
does we are not affected that's maximum
resilient but not very efficient to have
all those uh so we are introducing
groups which allows you to pick any um
any uh sweet spot you want on this
resiliency um efficiency trade-off so
groups essentially just allow you to say
okay you give some attestations to some
of those personal circles and kind of
bch them to together and create a
fungible um circles uh um for that group
so you can have here on the lowest layer
those individual circles and then you
can try to say okay let let's do some
city city Circ or some some Regional
circles you can go higher Europe and you
could go all the way up here and that
could be let's say even worldcoin or
World ID so where you try to have this
this this largest group which would be
most um which would be most efficient to
just have one group but I would argue
also least
resilient uh so yeah just here uh if you
if you trusted by a group you can turn
your personal circles into a kind of
Vault contract and issue the equivalent
amount um of group circles and you can
even do that so here person B is not
trusted but they
hold Circles of person a uh and as long
as a is member of this group they can
still use that to Mint um that group
currency uh here just um yeah we will uh
expect to have all kind of groups so
just to mention a few things that are
here so we could have a group based on
Zupas and World IDE on poops on local
groups manual groups um those those kind
of things so last thing uh here looking
at uh where is circles so again showed
you some pictures from the October 2020
launch then we did a bunch of
experiments a small scale trying to make
circles work and Ballo and barley um but
recently yeah a couple of weeks ago we
released circles 2.0 at least the
develop release and for early um yeah
2020 we are uh sorry 20 next year uh we
are planning the on Jan ckp so welcome
lha to the
[Applause]
stage hi
everyone I'm on this kind of ZK
permissionless
identities if you're trying to use your
identity on
chain it doesn't matter now you tap it
you scan it you push your fingerprint to
it you kind of rely on a service or a
company that acts as a kind of an attas
to your
identity this
dependency is kind of problematic
because like forget like this kind of
risk of like collusion or like a certain
company going mad trying to take over
the world the problem that we already
see is that such systems don't scale
especially under the regulatory pressure
so if somebody wants to just impose a
ban on the system they know exactly
which Hardware operator to go after and
we've seen it already in multiple cases
across the world
to kind of solve this
challenge we had to go to the
fundamentals of building the
permissionless
systems and during the research we found
out that mostly these dependencies apart
from like being this kind of a business
issuer business on its own is based on
the so-called kind of
trilemma so in a fully decentralized
environment such as like
blockchains you couldn't have two
properties such as uniqueness and
privacy at the same time because if you
want to generate a
nullifier and to make it verifiable you
need to push it on chain you're losing
the Privacy if you enable the client
side blinding of it then the user is
able to generate as many nullifiers and
unique numbers as possible
and that means that you won't have a
uniqueness for certain cases so our
solution to solve that was to kind of
zoom out and create a shared ZK registry
on chain and on an example of like
biometric passports that we already
already have and the fact is that like
passports contain the chip and all the
information and signature to verify
certain attrib about ourselves so with
the passport we can enable the client
side issuance using your
phone then forming a list of uniqueness
hashes directly on chain but as a
concept introduces kind of a shared
permissionless registry of unique
identifiers the more apps you
have it's super hard to deduce for
exactly what activity
those identities have been
used so more passports more identities
more stuff you put within this registry
the Privacy strengthens so even if
somebody has a copy like a government
has a copy of your passport somebody
gets on hold of it all they can
understand is that you registered in
this vast disc centralized
permissionless registry but never
understand you came there to get your
meme coins or like vote against the
regimes we actually battle tested this
permissionless registry with Russian
elections where just Russian citizens
could tap their passports and vote
against the
regimes the next day after the app was
released Kremlin just like had no idea
where to Target and what to take down so
all they did they filed a complaint to
an Apple Store
that a certain app was violating like
the counterfeiting National
IDs which is kind of yeah so
the advantage of such systems is that as
they're not nor Hardware nor the client
side software
dependent the next day the new apps
would pop up and people would continue
to
vote and that's basically
the true power of
decentralization so even when building
this this identity systems we should
focus on this new way of full
decentralization and empowering
users because that's the systems that
scale those Registries could have
passports as a single instance and they
could extend to much wi things like you
can build different commitment TRS ZK
reputation systems or just like put even
the sanctions or like some kind of band
list and make it like publicly
verifiable and the cool part about is
like that anyone can do it and use it so
as the next
step this idea of permissionless onchain
Registries we want to propose it as an
ERC and are happy to like get the
community Community feedback engagement
from all these people working in the
identities but the existing
implementation of registry that is lived
and used by different countries
different applications we will be
bringing on ethereum as a rollup because
I believe this is the biggest alignment
from a vision perspective because at a
near
future
everyone just like using your phone
should run a node and secure it a
network and the very same phone
simultaneously should be managing your
entire
identity thank
[Applause]
you thank you so much lasasha and next
up I am going to bring a number of the
speakers that we just had as we're going
to have a panel Pua is going to be
moderating for us so please welcome Pua
to the stage rco lasasha Martin please
join us thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you hello
hello
great so we just had a nice overview of
the three protocols um and what I want
to do in this uh small amount of time we
have is just challenge each one I think
there's something to learn uh you know
from each approach here and see if we
can come to some greater synthesis so
I'll start with Remco so Remco I
actually wrote a critique of proof of
personhood it's called compressed to
zero the silent strings of proof of
personhood and what I did is I looked at
a parallel protocol to worldcoin a
different authentication mechanism but
they had succeeded in uh verify in
Unique Individuals uh through cognitive
tests um and they had avoided the
problem of account trading which
worldcoin has had to Grapple with
because each account has money and then
of course there's an incentive to um you
know sell accounts early on and so
that's something you're grappling with
they had solved that with this novel
mechanism called sublinear identity
staking which I'm happy to talk to you
about later and but they were still left
with this information game theoretic
problem around puppeteering which is
that when you have an account and it has
monetary value it has a Ubi stream
coming towards it which is one of the
goals of worldcoin um you create
incentives for other people to try to
control those accounts and extract from
them and so in the kind of pithy way to
put it is when you try to differentiate
humans from Bots and use Ubi incentives
you actually create an unintended
consequence of humans trying to control
other humans as if they were Bots right
and so the control problem becomes an
information problem and it's an
information game theoretic ones so I I
want to know how you uh think about this
challenge because there are two goals
that are very explicit with worldcoin
one is both Ubi and a kind of rails for
Democratic governance and even maybe
even uh AI alignment but if if
ultimately you know pursuing both of
those goals ends up in coalitions and
oligopolies and basically politics right
um and one person one vote break breaks
down very quickly in the Coalition it's
like how do you so um we're if not
nearly a 100 countries right now you
kind of see everything that people can
throw at you and while the vast majority
of people is honest there are some very
dishonest actors out there and you have
the um Byzantine generals problem of you
need to make your resist system
resistance
against malicious actors um
I think this is not is not a capture
so there is this idea that you can
delegate an account this is not
something I think we should prevent but
it is something that you need to give
the user the tools to properly manage
which means that it needs to be explicit
it needs to be consensual it needs to be
revocable and so on so I think the
emphasis is on developing those tools
empowering the user to control their
world ID in the way that they want to
control it
um blockchains as a whole are not
particularly good at the moment at these
kinds of things because a lot of
decisions you make on chain are oneway
streets but there are a number of things
we are already doing here um like
allowing you to recover your account by
going back to an orb one thing we've
rolled out that is very powerful is
using the phone's front camera to do
additional interactive face
authentications to make sure that the
wallet hasn't been stolen it's still in
the possession of the original human
that signed up and so
on right maybe I can comment there
directly so I made in this presentation
my claim that I think this absolute
identity there are actually not that
many kind of just to give the extreme
example why why I'm making this claim is
let's say somehow North Korea does get
hold of one of those orbs and and
can um
uh can yeah properly authenticate they
all their 25 million or I'm not exactly
sure how many people they have probably
no one knows but 25 million people so
let's just say in worldcoin now you go
from 8 million fully verified to now uh
32 but 25 of them are just are are are
people from North Korea where it's not
even clear whether they um whether they
have control somehow centrally organized
that someone ultimately has full control
of the those those keys now you have 32
million properly verified actual humans
the question is what application for
what application would that Set uh be
useful so my claim is in absolutely most
applications and probably actually this
gas subsidy that you're doing is one of
the few where I think it is uh useful
but uh but in absolutely most
applications I would say you need more
context than just uh Being Human or I
mean if you want to go even more extreme
we can think of this Matrix movie where
they literally I mean in The Matrix
movie where they literally farming
humans or it kind of have those Farms of
humans that basically just sit there and
yes they might have an eyeball you might
be able to scan that uh but but but
that's really not you what you want
right and even just to add on the now
right as long as there's money at stake
I mean we have synthetic while the
signup process between the user is
absolutely Anonymous and privacy
preserving the orbs themselves are not
their behavior is public and um there
are methods you can use to actually
revoke the people that's the the fake
accounts that might but but they are no
no fake accounts okay that's that's the
second part if they are not fake
accounts um
then the system works as intended in a
way and you make a very good point that
proof of the Primitive and you need a
richer ecosystem of things around it the
example Chan da um you have you want to
implement one person one vote if you
just do this and allow all of the world
ID verified users to vote on this and
your like social community is only 5,000
people you can easily get swamped you
don't have a very strong governance
system that way so you do need to
incorporate this in more complex
systems I 100% agree can I add something
yeah I kind of
like I get all the points but I think
like the like forgetting the orb or the
eyes and stuff so I agree that overall
identities and I don't believe in
Universal identities because like
identities are have to be built for the
governance purposes so we should like
come up with Frameworks that increase
the coordination quality among the
humans and then decide the depth of the
identity how it should be built when we
talk about the proof of personhood it
has like two Dimensions right one is the
proof of uniqueness and I agree for the
real world and especially in multiple
cases just uniqueness proof and badge
does not guarantee the quality of
decision- making or coordination and
then we have to rely on passports or
like citizenship or the age or like all
the other stuff and the thing is that
like if we like for example for voting
refer to the passports the dependency on
this document is so big that we can
generate the uniqueness Based on data
and we might not need any type of
Biometrics additional to it right and I
think like like in a way that's the
purpose of identity so I don't believe
in Universal identities I believe of
defining whether we like fighting AI or
or we like fighting the misinformation
stuff the only systems that are
dynamically evolving and improving are
the ones that have these kind of fluid
identity aspects and not just the
universal ones like on the example of
Twitter and the community noes right so
just labeling is just creating this very
low barriers in terms of defining the
permissions what you can do or what you
can't do as a human or not and like you
said yeah there's a kind of North Korea
scenario there's kind of a dystopian
scenario where we might be like creating
market right for the eyeballs and stuff
and like you got two kidneys you got two
eyes and then what happens next right so
well what you raised is an interesting
point about governance right because in
some sense the the the yeah right and so
even if you do succeed uh in
authenticating Unique Individuals in
North Korea how do you actually enforce
that and what you're saying is Well you
need richer governance mechanisms we
need to express identity in different
ways right as a complement and if you
just have that one identity system
ultimately enforcement would require
surveillance and of course surveillance
results in everyone becoming
informationally the same so I want to
shift gears Martin and poke a little
holes at circles I think it's a great
experiment but one of the things I
noticed on your slides is you know
you're you're talking about currency and
money I think of them almost as
Community currencies and like nest and
networks of coop tribution right that it
shouldn't just sort of be like an hourly
rate that's a kind of um you know
another kind of Ubi that has its own uh
pitfalls because it's not tied to
incentives and um you mentioned a 7%
interest rate these things seem
arbitrary and does they don't seem to
leverage incentives or people's voice
choice and stake in a community so how
do you think about that yeah I mean on
on the should they receive the same
amount um I I would say comes together
and decides to use something as money
then just that coordination effort to
some extent creates value uh to whatever
and I would argue that the fairest form
of Distributing this uh this value that
has been cre created by just this
coordination effort uh would be to
distribute it equally among those that
uh join this coordination effort super
important to understand that that that
that doesn't mean that everyone needs to
work for the same hourly rate or it
doesn't need that's absolutely not the
case so it's just uh it's just that the
coordination effort is in a way or the
the benefit of that is equally um uh
distributed sorry there was a second
question that I well just you know than
you know acknowledging that there's
different levels I believe 7% that
that's 7% right yeah so so um so that is
probably the only parameter in circles
that is um uh yeah well that that that
that has been said and that that's
therefore debatable and yes you could
say everyone every Community should be
able to set that themselves uh that
would make coordination much much much
harder um because why well because then
you would need to um or in in in circles
it it is meant to be so simple that I I
I I issue circles and then I know I can
kind of trust that other account I can
issuing under the exact same rules if
everyone could Define their own rules it
would be much harder to negotiate of how
much should my money worse uh uh
compared to use to your so I would say
for a stable equili or the goal of
circuits is to have the stable
equilibrium where
um where yeah trust or or the exchange
rates between circles are are just one
to one the goal would be to say c one
circle is one Circle and and it's kind
of abstracted away the fact that under
the hood we have all those different
just like in the in the in the dollar
system right now um technically speaking
if you have a dollar at One bank and a
dollar at another bank those are not the
same those are not the same dollars um
but the system is built in such a way
that usually it feels like one to one
because if everything goes well you can
exchange them one to one but if it
breaks you will realize oh the the bank
the dollar at a bank that just went
bankrupt is different from the other but
the US and Euro have floating exchange
rates why can't you say again the US and
Euro have floating exchange rates for
sure for sure for sure so in circles yes
you or I mean the expectation is they
are with in a connected cluster the
exchange rate is is one to one but yeah
there can be uh different clusters where
within the cluster the exchange rate is
one to one but between the Clusters um
there are um floating exchange why not
just rely on supply and
demand no well it will be I mean I mean
the price between those clusters will be
defined by supply and demand and what we
actually supposing um in our upcoming um
upcoming uh um yeah relaunch I'd say or
or restart or or um or reactivation it's
the continuation of the system is that
uh people people or groups can change
rate uh for for those circuits so
defined by supply and demand um but as
long as people trust each other then
then they are essentially creating
additional um yeah one to one demand
between those currencies okay maybe we
need to go back to the identity uh well
no but it's it's it's uh you're
expressing identity in a different way
and so it's I just want to dig on that
but I want to turn to lha now Mo uh in
this constellation of ident identity
protocols what what like differentiation
do you see that you're
bringing I think
we tried to use the both Sid of the
world such as like passports as an
instance first but then extend it with
like graph like and capture more depths
of the
interactions and uh what I would say is
like how we try to solve the identity
problem or enable the buildup is very
use case Centric and like I say the
governance entric the fact that like we
understand like this voting stuff has to
be done that way it gave rise of solving
the uniqueness problem in a certain way
but that doesn't mean that that same
uniqueness should be reused like
universally across other use cases and
so like going at A Primitive level of
these kind of Registries and the kind of
building blocks and you having more like
this kind of flexible framework I think
that's the way forward and as well as
we've seen mostly right on the kind of
regulatory pressure or like this kind of
collusion risk I think the
permissionless and empowering of the
users going forward should be like this
kind of core principle that no one
should kind of violator across the line
for so we only have three minutes left I
want to quickly do one minute each on
where you know AI is
a part of identity is helping us
leverage AI to communicate with each
other also to govern AI so starting with
you Remco um where do you see the most
immediate use case with worldcoin in in
the near future um and world or World ID
uh interfacing with AI will you know
open AI uh for example Grant free access
if you have a world ID um what is the
sort of immediate near-term goals on
that interaction I mean I can't speak
for um regarding AI um I think I think
we need to embrace the fact that it's
going to be some sort of like human AI
hybrid operator I I I'm a big believer
of like AI is just making humans better
versions of themselves so this is why I
think it's so important that you
distinguish between a capture and a
proof of personhood which are different
Primitives um with different use cases
and we might not even be that interested
in the capture use case what is going to
be a very important Pro U problem is
like I don't think proof of person alone
is a solution there but I do think it
can be an important part of a
functioning solution that allows us to
authenticate content and information
Lasha any immediate applications yeah in
my world I don't have this like as
humans in AIS and kind of like the
separate camps of the camp I more see
and question like okay what is the first
thing like I own multiple AIS so the
First Dimension is how do I control it
so how do we build this my me my Ai and
of identifying these relations and
control and then zooming out like all
the AIS of individuals or like the
systems how do they coordinate and what
are the mechanism for us I don't know
like lower down the computational
capacity or like just shut the certain
things down and just like abstract them
this is a kind of a next level of the
governance problem yeah um I I think
it's certainly good to have a robust
identity
is is relational because I yeah for the
reason in the very beginning so I like
to see a version of something like like
circles that's completely permissionless
as a base layer built on on this um
trust graph but then uh yeah projects
like um or or or World ID that can
essentially provide additional um yeah
attestations what I would call it um to
those open um base layer identities can
bring us a very robust system overall
um where humans can uh coordinate if
necessary maybe against AI yeah well
each circle have its own AI agent that's
a good question whether a AI agents will
also use circles or not I don't know yet
they could all right let's give them a
round of applause everybody thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you thank you so much Puja for a
wonderful moderation and everyone for
joining next up I would like to welcome
Rob Knight to the stage who's going to
speak to us about zup pass and
credentials Beyond
[Music]
identity ready um so I'm I'm Rob from
the zup pass team um I hope I now most
of you are familiar with what zup pass
is you will have used it to check in uh
for this event and I can see some of you
have collected some frog hats so you've
been playing frog crypto um so you're
kind of basically familiar with uh with
what zass is um originally I had a slide
here where I was going to talk about um
you know Zupas is a kind of uh zero
knowledge data manager for your personal
cryptographic secrets and and and that
kind of thing but um I think it's just
easier to talk about some of the things
you can use zup pass for um so we have
here uh eth Berlin the voting for The
hackathon so you prove that you're an
attendee at eth Berlin uh and you can
anonymously vote uh for the winner of
the hackathon and that was used to award
prizes uh you used it to check in at
Devcon uh you used it to play frog
crypto and you won uh some some frog
merch uh maybe you were at devc connect
and you sent anonymous messages to the
telegram Group by proving that you are a
ticket holder and then the bot would
anonymously send your message uh if
you're at zuk connect you might have
participated in a distributed clinical
trial using uh a data Gathering device
that would then store that data and then
anonymously uh prove that you
participated in the trial when you
submit it um maybe you were at edges
mlda and you participated in the Run
Club using straa and you were able to uh
compete anonymously with other people to
see who could get the uh could cover the
most miles um maybe you voted in the
quadratic funding round for the Zulu
community and again you you will have
used zass to prove that you are a member
of the Zulu ecosystem that you attended
previous events um and here at Devcon
you might have also participated in the
speaker Q&A so again you're proving that
you're an attendee of the event and then
participating by creating questions and
getting answers from the
speakers so zass is is basically all of
these things it enables all of these
things to happen um
and I kind of want to give a bit of a
philosophical reason for why Zupas does
things the way that it does so rather
than going into how it works if you're
interested in how it works we're doing a
CLS on that tomorrow um but if if you
want to know why uh Z and why
decentralized data um this is a sort of
philosophical
background so there this concept um
called conviviality and conviviality
means living together from the Latin you
know con and VI means together living
and it kind of connotes this idea that
we create our our our lives together we
we collaborate in creating the meanings
uh that our lives are made up from and
this book uh by aan ilich I think
written in the 70s
um applies this view to technology so he
he has this idea of tools for
conviviality where a convivial tool is
is something where the user of that tool
is empowered to find their own use for
it the tool doesn't tell them what to do
it gives them options and they figure
out what those options mean and how they
want to uh how they want to make use of
them so we regard zpass as being in that
sense a tool for conviviality it's a
tool that doesn't tell you who you are
or what it means to be a person it's
it's a tool that lets you collect data
and decide within your community what
that data
means so there's a bunch of philosophers
throughout history who've thought about
this stuff um one of two of my favorites
are alist McIntyre and Michael walzer um
McIntyre thought about this question uh
he wrote a book called who's Justice
which rationality which again was on
this question of meanings like what does
it mean for something that are possible
what what exists what's real um um and
his view was that different Traditions
do this in a way that is kind of in sort
of incommensurable meaning that you
can't have one system that incorporates
all Traditions every tradition has its
own notion of what constitutes truth
goodness Beauty and they need to find
their own representations for those
things um similarly in spheres of
Justice Michael walzer uh makes this
defense of pluralism and equality um and
he's arguing against a view of kind of
egalitarianism where what's fair is that
everybody has the same thing thing and
instead he's saying like what's fair is
that uh everybody is part of a community
that gets to determine its own sense of
what's valuable and its own sense of
what's good so instead of being put in a
single Global hierarchy you have many
different hierarchies and people get to
have a leading role in their in their
own kind of smaller
community and then finally uh just two
more references uh so one is the Society
of the spectacle by G Bard uh written in
the 60s um and he talked a lot about
this of order givers and Order takers
and how Society is divided into people
who tell other people what to do and
then people who have to do what they're
told um so the people at the bottom take
orders and and and they receive not just
orders not just being told where to go
and what to do but they receive an order
they receive a system they receive a
whole idea about who they are and what
their role in society is that is given
to them is not something that they
develop for themselves um so he was very
much in favor of the idea of people
creating and
co-creating U that that sense of meaning
um from from their own
interactions um and another very recent
book came out in the last year called
the uh the ordinal Society by Maran uh
fard and uh Kieran Healey um they kind
of apply that sort of analysis to
computers and they look at the ways in
which computer systems provide order
they they they take the chaos of of life
and they produce numbers and facts and
figures and databases that kind of we we
use to understand what's going on around
us um in fact um I was going to ask if
we have any french speakers here um
because in French the word for computer
is ordinator uh which means it it it
gives order it ordains things in in
pretty much the same way that God
ordains things um and so that idea that
that something being in the computer
makes it real that idea that the
computer says what is real or says what
should happen um is kind of built right
into the word at least in French um so
so how do we live in awarders
ourselves um so naturally this is where
I transition into talking about Zupas
again um so we have these three things
um that are kind of new and are kind of
interesting uh called pod GPC and Z
called pod GPC and zapi um there's a QR
code for the the documentation site
there um and pod stands for provable
object data U so it's basically a dat
format a very flexible data format GPC
stands for general purpose circuits um
which is a flexible system for making ZK
proofs and zapi is a new thing that
we've recently built uh that enables you
to embed zup pass functionality directly
into your own
apps um so pod lets you create your own
data structures you know if we think of
of an order sort of a system of of
understanding as being made up of
structure you know ontology what's real
and logic that tells you what you can do
with those things pod lets you define
the structure so here we're defining a
frog if you've played frog crypto you've
interacted with this structure um and it
it tells you what's real in the world of
frogs it tells you what exists um
anybody can issue them and verify you
know have a list of maybe valid issuers
that they would accept as as real so
it's a very
Authority and then GPC lets you create
your own logic and this is where things
start to get interesting because the
question of what does it mean to have a
frog is determined by what you can do
with it and what you can do with it in
at least in zup pass is determine what
by what kind of proofs you can make so
if I can prove that I have a frog of a
particular type maybe in some space in
some community that allows me to do
something if I can prove that I have
three frogs maybe that proves something
else if I can prove I have a frog and a
ticket maybe that has a different
meaning and these are kind of contrived
examples but you could imagine doing
this with any kind of data type you like
again with pod you can make your own
data um so you can kind of reinvent this
system however you like and then zapi
lets you embed this directly into web
applications so this is zero knowledge
this is cryptographic data and zero
knowledge proofs directly in the browser
in something that looks like a basic
standard ordinary web app again you've
probably already interacted with some of
them while you were here so frog crypto
uh would be one miacat would be another
so if you submitted uh any q&as during
any of the talks uh you will have
interacted with an app that does this
and it it uses pods it uses GPC proofs
uh and it it also gives you cards back
um for for participating in
that um there's a kind of cool one there
shulan engineering I think is is new so
that's again it's a community project uh
I think that came out today which lets
you take two frogs extract Venom from
them and create a psychedelic substance
so again the meaning of of these things
is in the hands of the developers it's
in the hands of the communities that
that want to kind of figure out what we
can do with this stuff for
themselves um so thank you very much uh
for listening me to me about philosophy
uh as I say if you want to learn more
about how this stuff works on a
technical level we have a CLS tomorrow
uh very happy to see all of you there um
we also have documentation website which
has a link to a telegram group if you
want to come and talk to us in the
telegram group uh please do thank you
very much thank you rob
Knight and thank you very much
[Music]
hopefully this can be just as good as if
I was there
um uh you probably already are familiar
with the community notes you y but just
in case you're not um here's a note
attached to a post on x um this note was
written by a contributor a basically
regular user and before it was shown was
rated as helpful by other contributors
um who attended to disagree in the past
um this lightning icon means that the
note actually appeared within the first
uh hour of the post being created which
is happening more and more since the
system's been speeding up uh
recently another way notes can appear
really quickly on posts is VI media
matching so you can write notes on um on
images or videos that will automatically
apply to all their posts with those uh
uh that same matching
media um because the data is public uh
external researchers have analyzed it a
ton and I'm just going to share some
highlights of what they found so one
group uh found that notes are 80 98 or
99% accurate about covid vaccines
according to them uh and just want to F
that although notes are already pretty
rarely in accurate uh one great property
is that uh inaccurate notes attract
additional Raiders and as a result the
system can quite often be
self-correcting um which is pretty cool
um another group ran some a survey where
they compared some uis um one that's
kind of like Community notes versus um
one where they had a community flag or a
traditional fact checker flag and what
they found is um that the community note
is found bipartisanly by Ser B
participants to be more trustworthy than
the others and then also um and Survey
participants rate post as less accurate
when they're displayed with a note
versus without um which is pretty cool
we uh do not algorithmically rerank
posts based on whether they have notes
or not for instance in the foru page but
there is an organic uh change in
engagement Behavior after po get notes
so just uh we observed in 2022 in an AB
test that the um like and repost rate
dropped by
30% um after a post got a note and then
in 2023 and 24 um external research
groups found uh about a 50% drop in
engagements after a post got uh noted so
that's really big by the way if you've
ever ran experiments on big social media
platforms you're probably familiar that
1% can often be a really really big
change and these are these are you know
in the 30 30 and 50% range um so it's
quite large uh posts are also much more
likely to be deleted by their authors
and then this is really hard to measure
but there's just an incentive change uh
authors don't want to get demonetized or
have the stigma of a note so um
anecdotally some users say they post
differently um given that notes
exists I think very relevant for this
talk is the idea of credible neutrality
that we aspire to um similar to um some
other crypto projects um I think um some
things we do towards this end are number
one contributors are regular users uh
right they they do have to have a
verified phone number and have signed up
six months ago Etc but for instance
they're not employees or something like
that um separately we don't take in
external ground truth labels either so
instead of we use this clever bridging
mechanism that'll talk more about uh and
then uh we also are open source
transparent reproducible and verifiable
so for instance X never manually edits
or changes the status of a note to take
it down uh you can actually go to our
website and download the code download
the data and run the code on the data
and verify that it matches exactly what
was in production two days ago that
two-day delay is just to prevent
manipulation um but that's pretty cool
to be quite uh so transparent and is
very rare among simil more companies um
okay so the core mechanism I think
that's interesting here is this bridging
algorithm um which is what lets us not
use external ground truth um so here's a
note of one of our contributors
explaining it to someone else uh doesn't
work by majority rules uh it's not an up
vote down vote system where we add it up
we we actually look for uh ratings where
there's agreement between people who've
disagreed in the past um this gives us
some built-in manipulation resistance
that's pretty cool uh if in this little
cartoon here um just to help you
understand why this might happen uh is
if you think of these circles as people
and the colors or viewpoints
uh if you get some off platform Brigade
of people from Discord or something who
all decide to go rate a note a
particular way uh you know that group
alone can't determine what notes get
shown um it's pretty great property
um uh another interesting thing is that
the data set's quite large so it's it's
sparse there's not a lot of users that
have rated many of the same notes in the
past so what we have to do is we build a
model we uh use a matrix factorization
approach so we construct The Matrix of
users and and notes and the ratings on
them and we uh train this model that's
quite similar to uh a traditional
recommender system you'll probably
familiar with this but rather than
personalizing what note we show to each
user we actually learn this Global note
score um which we call an intercept term
here um which is the same for all users
um and the way we train it is we add
extra regularization to those terms
which force to be explained by the
viewpoints whenever possible so if the
if ratings are um uh occurring on a note
in a totally Viewpoint consistent way
then The Intercept term will remain
neutral uh what this looks like in
picture format is here's a scatter plot
of notes um the x-axis is the Viewpoint
of notes the y- AIS is The Intercept
score um most of these notes fall in the
yellow circles and that's not um a
problem with the algorithm often times
these notes um just aren't great um uh
the the green notes uh are the ones that
are seen by users on X um everything
else is just seen by contributors and
then the red ones who actually penalize
the author is
for um so that's the core mechanism and
how it works uh there's a ton of other
mechanisms on top of that um which I
don't fully have time to explain all of
them but for instance uh we also do a
similar Matrix factorization for tags so
if we find bridging based con that a
note is incorrect uh we don't show it
even if it was found helpful for
instance there's also needs or help tab
uh this can and needs your help
notifications so this can help uh number
one address selection bias we can make
sure there's enough Raiders with each
Viewpoint that have rated a note to help
get notes showing faster um we can
detect or mitigate coordinated
coordinated manipulation like those
brigades um if the distribution from the
needs your help tab is very different
than the organic distribution
um I think of particular interest to
this group is probably similarities uh
with prediction markets so you can think
of each note as being kind of like a
prediction Market that resolves to its
final status uh whether it's helpful or
not helpful and your Rider reputation
goes up if your radar matches the
outcome and down if it doesn't so your R
reputation is kind of like your currency
in the prediction markets um the
uh the thek Market doesn't always
resolve of course um as prediction
markets also don't always um which is
fine it's it's a valid distilled
mechanism um uh in that case and I guess
maybe the biggest difference is that
there is no bet sizes um so you each
user gets one rating Max
um I think uh the incentives for
reputation well first call out that some
users just aren't very incentivized by
it and they're just going to uh rate in
ways that uh they're going to try to
impact What notes shown in the platform
above all El but as far as users who are
following the incentives number one for
your ratings to count you have to have
high enough reputation uh number two in
order to earn the ability to write notes
you have to have high enough rating
impact uh and then uh in order to unlock
some superpowers like media notes if the
build up be writing
impact I think one pretty
straightforward idea here could be just
making prediction markets that resolve
to whether there's community notes on a
post uh but I think uh you know vitalic
has been blogging a lot recently about
um Community notes and prediction Market
mashups um and you know what's the
what's the best way and I think many
others are excited about this what's the
best way to um build community notes
that could say something interesting
about the future um What mechanisms
could work there um I think I just want
to end the talk by saying things that
I'm personally interested in I think uh
those mechanisms um and as well as
multi-dimensional bridging um more notes
faster in more places like matching an
llms and um you know just to uh I think
bridging algorithms um Beyond notes like
in the foru page for instance would be
cool um or collaboratively writing wikis
or or uh policies um you know no
guarantees this is just my personal uh
interest so no guarantees about the
company um doing anything there but uh
if any of this is exciting to you uh
we're hiring a machine learning engineer
um it's also linked to my bio and
definitely especially because I didn't
get a chance to come there in person
please uh reach out and DM me with any
questions or comments you have thank you
so much thank you
Jay next up we have Robin Hansen the
brilliant mind behind a lot in futaki
and I'll hand it over to Robin thank you
so much
[Applause]
long
ago I was part of a group of people who
imagined the worldwide web before there
was a
web many people didn't think it was very
plausible I left grad school to go off
to join people working on that but then
within a few years I started to have
doubts about some of the Visions people
had about the web and what it could
achieve and I tried to think about other
ways to solving that problem and I came
up with the idea because I was hanging
around a lot of rabid
Libertarians that betting markets would
be a powerful way to address many key
questions in society and uh I started to
write about that and within a few years
I helped develop some exchanges and uh
experiments and then about 10 years
later I.E I started writing about
this stuff 35 years ago 25 years ago I
realized that the highest value of
information aggregation is when you can
inform decisions closely so I focused on
what I call decision markets advising
markets that advise decisions I wrote on
that about 25 years ago and one of the
concepts I described was
futarchy and then uh in the decade after
that I was working on combinatorial
markets which I'm going to tell you a
bit about and then in the last year
we've seen a number of concrete
experiments on this concept of futari or
using conditional markets for governance
I'll tell you a bit about and that's
exciting and why I'm here and why you
should just wait if necessary till
you're old have ideas when you're young
and wait till you're old because then by
then something might have
happened so I'm an economics professor
and we social scientists have a number
of lenses by which we understand society
and human behavior Behavior Uh in
economics the most straightforward
standard one is just exchange of goods
and services but we also have Game
Theory where we understand power and
strategy and political science is big on
that sociology and anthropology are big
on understanding things in terms of
norms and Prestige which I've been
focused on for the last year and
catching up on things I didn't
understand but another lens for
understanding human behavior is the idea
that we reveal infer and aggregate
by our behaviors and we have a lot of
social institutions that do that and in
some sense the activity of economists in
the last half century has mostly been
focused on modeling this aspect of human
behavior how we are signaling showing
inferring and aggregating information
and when you look at the many
institutions we use for that one small
institution now stands out for its
exceptional abilities and that is except
speculative markets
uh in comparison after comparison they
just beat all the other institutions in
terms of their ability to produce
accurate estimates uh timely and uh
using modest amounts of resources
compared to other things so that creates
this Vision I have which is could we use
speculative markets a lot more elsewhere
in society to produce the information
aggregation that we are now producing in
worse ways through other institutions
like gossip news voting Academia Etc now
these four lenses probably aren't
everything there's a lot of social dark
matter and that should make us a little
cautious about any claims we make about
how to change society but we should be
trying this vision and seeing how far we
can get with
it
now one way to see my vision here is
just to for the moment set aside your
doubts about how feasible this is and
think about all the different things we
could apply this sort of thing too so
for example we could have markets on if
x dated Y how long would their
relationship last when you have a new
hire what would their employee
evaluation be in a few years if you have
a project with a deadline will it make
the deadline how would that change if
you had changed resources requirements
Personnel you could admit students to
universities and other places based on
expectation of graduating or GPA
conditional on
admission you could fire the
CEO uh based on whether that was
expected to change the stock price uh
you could do security analysis based on
whether red what the chance of red teams
penetrating security is given that you
changed uh some approach you could do
various kinds of policy in terms of
changing crime policy how does that
change the crime rate the FED changing
interest rates how does that change
predict inflation uh even things like
antitrust uh you could ask whether an
industry will be healthy or not in many
years later if you make a certain anti
Trust move once you I think once you
start to see these examples and look
around you you'll see this everywhere
all over your world are decisions that
could be improved by speculative markets
just like even this conference we could
have had markets about well on what date
do we have at what location what kind of
speakers we could have outcomes like how
many people attend or other sorts of
things all of those are possible now you
hopefully I presume at this point you
have doubts many most of you probably
think yeah but this isn't feasible just
couldn't do this there must be something
in the way because we're not doing it
now this is I'm a teacher most of my
students are basically always assume
anything that isn't the status quo just
must not work and even you probably have
doubts so but let me go farther with the
vision a little bit before we get into
how these things work the grandest
vision perhaps I tried to pick what
would be the most aspirational grand
applications of this idea of conditional
markets and that would be governance so
at the moment you can think of our
democracy it's a system where we have a
bunch of citizens the elect
representatives who pass bills and if
the bills meet a constitutional
constraints they become laws and along
this process we have various information
institutions that inform both the
legislators and the public about their
beliefs about what bills have what
consequences my alternative which I've
called futari long before I knew the
other Association of the word sorry is
that we would still have legislatur to
decide our values to decide what
outcomes we want and they would
basically vote vote on and create a
measure of national welfare but in
addition uh we they would no longer
decide what bills passed in said people
could propose new bills say through an
auction agenda mechanism and then we'd
ask the markets is National welfare
going to be higher if we adopt this
proposed Bill versus not and we just
adopt the bills that do so that would be
a way to do governance full governance
using uh betting markets so markets just
have a lot of advantages over other
institution they're numerically precise
they're consistent cross many issues
they're frequently updated turns out to
be hard to manipulate actually uh
they're and the key thing is when we do
experimental ver tests comparing their
accuracy to other institutions are
either about the same or substantially
better that's the key thing that excites
me and should excite you about using
this in more places and the vision isn't
to just make betting markets and see who
has fun betting there and only have the
markets that people find fun the idea is
that if you want to know the answer to a
question you subsidize a market on your
question and then that attracts people
to trade because of the subsidies you
put there and then you get the answer to
your question but you paid for it so the
idea is this is a market for information
you offer to pay for the information you
want people who have or could get the
information they generate it and then
you get better
estimates uh so we know lots of Tricks
about he how to make this stuff work
better market makers allow a lot of uh
advantages you can limit sabotage it
actually works better to have winners
from one market only only winners
allowed on the next Market that's more
accuracy uh and you can have problems
that are hard to judge uh be judged only
randomly and bet on what would happen if
they were
judged we can do things like just having
any sort of distribution of a curve and
basically estimate the curve and you can
make an edit and move the curve and then
that's the new thing everybody else sees
or you could have a big hierarchy like
who's what the field of a of a Nobel
Prize is going to be in and you could
edit anywhere in that hierarchy at a
very fine grain level or a high level
this is all quite feasible and to show
you just how far we can go with the
technology I'm going to tell you about
Comon tutorial markets which have been
implemented I'll tell you the the idea
is not only do we have a set of claims
but we let people bet on all possible
combinations of those
claims and the straightforward way is
you have an edit based interface that is
you see a bunch of idents you're allowed
to go pick any estimate you want and
change it that becomes a bet and then
the next person who sees it they'll see
the number you put there but in addition
you can assume any number you see assume
any particular value and now everything
else you see is conditional on the
Assumption you made and you can make
several assumptions and that's a general
way to browse and edit a full
combinatorial
distribution and it turns out that the
subsidy you requireed to subsidize a
combinatorial distribution is actually
no more than subsidy for the each of the
individual claims now of course a full
combinatorial distribution has a vast
number of parameters too many to be
explicit but there's a standard way to
deal with what that calls a Bas net and
an aasian network uh cuts the explosion
by making key Independence assumptions
and I was actually part of a project 10
years ago where we had a thousand
questions we could have had more where
we had a full base Network connecting
all these questions so that you could
edit any part of this network and your
updates would propagate through the
whole network and we did the exact
updates and exact management of people's
assets so this is actually
possible yeah it might be a little hard
than the blockchain I haven't worked on
that um so do people actually do this
stuff well for a long time we've had
conditional markets on elections because
we've had markets on who who's going to
be nominated who's going to win so the
ratio of those two is in fact the chance
of winning if you're nominated and
markets have long been giving the
parties advice about who to nominate
that mostly they've ignored but it's
there but in this year we actually had
two websites metaculus and manifold
which are not full money prediction
markets but they have some incentives
offering conditional estimates on the
election and number of policy things so
this is a real thing that's now
implemented and live for people to trade
uh this election no doubt will be even
more popular next time
around uh many years ago actually on
this combinatorial site I talked about
we actually had conditional markets on
changing the blockchain size for Bitcoin
at least in order to estimate the
consequence of policy there so this
happened
and in the last few years as I mentioned
we've had a number of efforts to apply
this concept of conditional markets to
governance first there is a secretive
india-based Med government medical
organization that's done roughly a half
a dozen uh markets where they've asked
hundreds of thousands of their uh
customers to bet on various Health
policies that they've adopted or not and
I think they adopted five out of six uh
a little bit later we have the metad Dow
which has apparently now done 23
proposals for governance of the metad
Dow uh and only six of those were
rejected they have some customers now 14
proposals volume and trade Meadow is now
apparently focusing more on using
governance to advise say metad Dow Grant
uh estimating the consequence of a grant
proposal and seeing which ones to fund
that I do know know about is called
buttery and they're also focusing on
this idea of uh funding projects terms
of estimating the out comes for the
projects and I'm uh advising lots of
these efforts and in particular I am
chief scientist here at uh fy. which was
previously named quiver uh we have at
least one customer which is nosis to do
governance for them and we'll do it for
ourselves and we are interested in the
question of how to do governance for
organizations without bothering the
bosses who don't want to be replaced and
one promising application there is the
relationship between investors and
managers often they don't they're in
dispute about when to raise more money
and maybe a govern a fuing mechanism can
s sit as an intermediary there to help
them make that
decision all right
now but I warned you about social Dark
Matter key thing is that this I've been
describing simple elegant idea there are
a bunch of issues that we worked through
in a talk yesterday I went through a
number of the uh technical issues and
problems but just in general
all real world things are not just
simple elegant ideas they have a lot of
messy
details and so we just need real world
experiments to work out those details
because in some sense we don't fully
understand human behavior there's a lot
of social dark matter there's a lot of
ways in which we make simple theories
that should work and they don't so we
just need to try
things uh let me elaborate a bit imagine
we put an autistic person in the sea
Suite of a typical
Corporation they are a person who knows
the business very well they are uh very
knowledgeable and uh informed about key
decisions but they have no social Savvy
whenever a topic comes up they just
blurt out whatever they think the truth
is without having any idea whose agendas
might be squashed by that such a person
will just not last in the sea Suite they
might become a trusted adviser of
somebody else nearby but they won't be
sitting there but that's in essence what
prediction markets are they are very
smart and knowledgeable things that
speak the truth without knowing who's
bothered by that
and that highlights the fact that modern
organizations a lot of what they do is
politics and massaging of messages and
so we need to search in the space of how
to uh Place Market applications and
hundreds of firms tried them but even
though they typically had more accurate
estimates uh satisfied users though
experiments didn't continue largely
because of objections from managements
who really got pissed when the market
disagreed with them and the market was
right and so we need to deal with that
so A more concrete example even think of
a project manager who has a deadline
they want to know what the chance of
making the deadline but they also want
to have a good excuse if they fail how
will they do that well their favorite
excuse if they fail is to say well we
were going along just fine until the
last minute when something came out of
left field some weird thing it's so rare
and it'll never happen again so let's
just forget about it and the problem is
the prediction Market gets in the way of
that because it tells you a long mind
before you were going to fail you're
going to fail and you can't say we
didn't know that until the last minute
so you can see uh we need to overcome
this sort of a problem in organizations
in order to be able to fi them and
that's why we need to be doing these
experiments which I'm excited to be
doing and that's my
talk thank you so much
Robin next up we have David Minaj who's
going to speak to us about AI agents and
prediction Rockets
that much further um here on the right
we see some arguments from Robin Hansson
regel ham and then um you can also see
it with for instance uh poly Market
traction over recent years however human
participation poses limits to their
usefulness um probably you all noticed
that um like everywhere in life it's
about attention attention attention if
you want to attract people to
participate in markets um then they need
to be interesting to us so we tend to
participate in markets that are center
around politics and
sports and the other thing is uh it's
actually quite cumbersome to participate
in markets I mean if this is a market I
have some sort of knowledge about
because I work in the industry or or I
just feel about it in some way great um
but once those markets become a bit more
specific then I need to research um and
I have limited proessing processing
capacity uh the next thing is I can only
focus on one market at a time in fact I
can if I do prediction markets I can H
can't hang out with my friends I can't
do other valuable things right so that
limits the scale of the amount of
prediction markets we could feasibly
ever have uh at any given point in time
and then some markets are simply too
complex or uninteresting for humans I
mean there's some markets I could not
even understand which maybe some
software system could um and others I'm
just not going to bother getting
involved in so that limits the types of
markets we can get involved
in and finally um we all know that
humans um are biased by emotion and in
um uh um other other influences and
obviously the market argument says those
things won't matter um but there's clear
evidence that especially for some more
Niche markets these things very much do
matter and then these markets become
somewhat useless so how do we solve all
this uh well I say let's repl humans
with swamps of autonomous AI agents and
uh we have actually done that uh so we
have uh that life there's like uh
basically different types of Agents some
create markets some close markets um and
others trade in markets and this is
decentralized so it's like hundreds of
people running these uh agents uh on
their behalf participating in prediction
markets the way we do this is in a sort
of Free Step way we create an onchain
mechanism to actually coordinate
multi-agent system of Agents uh we have
actually developed like a specific
mechanism for this which we call proof
of active agent uh you can learn about
it at sings. Network basically what it
does is it defines a set of kpis which
uh sits sort of alongside uh the actual
prediction Market platform um which
create like further incentives for the
agents to engage uh with those markets
open them close them
Etc uh we also made it very simple for
people uh to basically run agents so
there's a reference set of reference
implementations that people can run in a
desktop app uh and you can do so too so
you basically download PE uh you fund it
um with some EXA it's currently on nois
and um then these agent will start
participating in those markets and
they'll use um different forms of um AI
there's some rule space AI there's some
reinforcement learning um we obviously
have large language model uh in play
that is speaking to the reference
implementation obviously you can come
and uh create something entirely
different and uh it's working so we have
uh a site here this is one example of a
market um uh which you can click into um
we have life agents growing very rapidly
in recent weeks over 300 now um
participating daily ruction so over uh
30% of Lifetime save transactions and
around 60% per month so where do we want
to take this um well it's a
decentralized
um uh approach to uh incentivizing
agents to participate in prediction
market so um I'll speak about what we
are planning to do um we're in the
process of onboarding more operators so
those are end users like yourself you
can literally do this right now and
download it and play with it um there's
more implementations obviously from
Builders um you can do the same um and
uh we're interested in deepening
liquidity and integrating Crypton native
demand site um if you want to learn more
about this there are free resources like
you can learn about the system as a
whole you can go to the site and see the
markets and then also learn about the
data science angle um on hugging face um
thanks for having me um my name is David
and I talk to you about prediction
markets with agents thank you David and
last but not least in this morning of
public epistemics we've got a wonderful
panel please could I invite up all the
panelists van from bu will be moderating
and we've got a number of panelists that
we had from today we'll have Robin
Martin Cass and CJ thank you for
joining I'm gonna give you this mic
hello everyone and uh can you hear me
awesome um I'm vaugh Mackenzie landal
I'm one of the co-founders of butter
we've been working in the governance
space for a very long time and um
obviously very excited about futar in
prediction markets and that's why we're
all here we have this incredible panel
full of lots of people who I love and
admire um and I'm going to just hand
over to each of them to give a very
short introduction and and then we'll
kick
off yeah I'm I'm Martin um so in a
previous live and nois we started with
prediction markets and uh wanted to
implement fut fut key and other things
um so in in general yeah I I'm
absolutely a super big fan of that uh
but I think in this panel I will a
little bit play the the skeptic here um
because yeah I think as as Robin
mentioned well you have the idea and
then you have the all all the details
that need to be uh figured out so I I
think I can a little bit bring in that
perspective I just talk so I'm Robin
Hansen so uh I'm Calvin also ctif uh I'm
the co-founder
of. um we are uh just announced our
project a few days ago uh our plan is to
help um Dow and other organizations make
great impactful uh positive de decisions
um yeah hi everyone uh I'm CJ from from
Limitless we're building uh like uh
basically we're processing around
million dollars in a day bets right now
for like zero de contracts on financial
markets uh I believe that like with
crypto we can build the the world's
largest economy uh on Chen uh outside
the jurisdiction of any one particular
nation state and I think that uh as well
as that we need to build really
efficient Global marketplaces on on top
of the infrastructure and so that's what
we are doing at Limitless
Labs thanks guys really appreciate that
so we're here at D today and um so the
first question is how to prediction
markets tied to diak how do prediction
markets and epistemic tech make the
biggest impact in the vein of diak on
differential progress defense and
democracy over to any one of the
panelists one ring to rule them
all if you could have reliable
prediction markets on whatever policy
question you have then you can just do
better on all of your other areas of
life you could have better know how to
pursue longevity better know how to
pursue decentralization whatever it is
you're trying to do having better
information on that can make you do that
better so that could we do much better
and how does that map directly to say
for example
defense yeah no I I can just replicate
that so um so yeah I think the promise
is is is very clear so the promise is
whether we we talk about um yeah even
simple things like this community note
or uh so from from micro from micro
decisions whether to show that Community
note or not to show that to extremely
large micro macro decisions should we
raise the interest rate or should we
make this huge uh um um well defense
spending here or there uh in general the
promis is that um this is a tool for
more more robust decision- making to
bring in yeah to to have a better
quality of of of of bringing information
that actually um show shows the true
true impact of a decision yeah so I'm
going to make a comment here like so
over the last uh few weeks uh everybody
has seen uh a lot um lots of people are
talking about uh prediction markets of
course predicting uh who's going to win
the election and and uh this made a lot
of uh generated a lot of excitement uh
but uh actually the most interesting
thing is not like predicting only
predicting probabilities that normal
prediction markets they do but uh
predicting the consequences of of things
so if you could have for instance uh
conditional markets on uh inflation on
uh GDP growth on um um spending on
unemployment conditional on uh
candidates right these would be even
much more interesting for for democracy
you could actually see like a scorecard
for the candidates right like a game you
can pick one this one's better on this
one this one's better on this other
thing right so this is the promise of
using conditional markets for decision
making yeah sorry man go ahead maybe let
me let me throw in one kind of uh uh
concept to challenge this this idea so
to say I mean I'm just pulling up here
uh coin Gecko and and and look at prices
of of of crypto and well they change by
67% a day um so I think prediction
markets rely on the assumption that
markets are so efficient um that out of
those prices we can uh get reliable
information um or better information but
I would would argue well there is also a
lot of noise uh in in in markets and I
would say that uh markets here um prices
change by 6% is largely not related to
any meaningful signal but is is or well
I need to be careful in the statement
but but there's still a lot of noise so
that that's I guess my question how how
can is is there enough signal in the
noise so when you compare head-to-head
this mechanism to other one
consistently this wins so that means all
those other mechanisms have more than 6%
mistake think about any committee you've
ever been on think about the gossip
Network do you really think that's
within 6% of the truth come on like
being 6% close is great compared to what
we usually
have yeah I would I guess I would come
at the like the whole question from from
a little bit of like a different angle I
think that definitely in in a crypto
context what's really interesting and
Powerful uh is the fact that essentially
we can build these like Global efficient
marketplaces and so I I really believe
that markets in general accelerate human
progress like if it wasn't for markets
we wouldn't be where we were today in
almost every field uh and even like they
have positive trickle down effects to
like positive trickle down effects to
like fund like moonshots and and science
funding that's a trival example in in in
a global context but still kind of
proves the point and I think that like
building prediction markets on chain can
be defensive in the sense that uh we
actually have a capital formation and
wealth generation outside of the the
nation state in this kind of global
onchain economy uh and I think why
that's defensive is because we can build
these kind of resilient independent
decentralized systems that manage to
kind of form their own Capital like
without for example being taxed on it
also without the very heavy regulation
which is a big issue there are only 16
designated contract makers in the United
States There are 16 licensed derivatives
exchanges but money cannot move globally
at the speed of info in the traditional
system here it can and we can build
these really powerful marketplaces that
are Global and accelerate human progress
I completely agree I think markets are a
very important piece of technology I
actually do believe that one of the
reasons that we are able to accelerate
defense particularly with prediction
markets is because we're basically
getting rid of any Authority's ability
to lie to us right because we can
delegate information and Truth to
markets I think this is great and um
actually speaking about this if you
think about futaki so far as you said
we've had lots of messy details I'd love
to know what you think the key
challenges in implementing fake will be
for a world organizational
decisionmaking right uh so um some some
some challenges of course uh Robin
mentioned uh the matter of the autist
and the in the boardroom uh so there's
always this uh this risk that uh uh
prediction markets and also decision
markets are um some sense threatening to
uh the power of uh uh Insiders on some
organizations that maybe are not making
the most uh uh efficient uh uh decisions
so this is uh for sure uh a big
challenge uh so another challenge uh
that is uh marching up uh I'm going to
try to connect the previous question
from Maring to uh the combinatorial
market idea from Robin which is part of
our basically Grand Vision on futarchy
which is uh um so matter of noise um
when we evaluating a potentially a small
or mediumsized uh proposal or decision
in a company um many of those if there
relatively small or medium you're not
going to have a clear impact uh visible
impact on on the share price uh so that
makes it really hard to um to use this
directly to estimate uh but if you had a
a full Network or a full tree uh where
you can see like you can you could have
uh markets for a share price or token
price but connected to these you also
see the kpis market for different kpis
number of uses Revenue uh uh other kinds
of metrics important for the company so
uh you could actually see okay maybe I
don't there's a lot of noise I don't see
the impact of this decision on uh the sh
token price but I see the impact of this
decision on this minor kpi that has but
it's minor kpi associated with this
major kpi which is in then related to
the share price so I think that's a this
is BR vision for many decisions is
actually have the markets all the
information connected to each
other maybe the to kind of reorient the
question what problems are you running
into I I I can say uh one one hard
problem to just uh find traders that are
comfortable kind of going into those um
into those positions and just to give
you give you an example of um let's say
we would do this for ethereum we would
say Okay conditional we we might go this
route road map or that route map um and
then um we want to use this futy
mechanism so essentially people can say
conditionally to this Rod map I I buy
eer and conditionally to that I sell but
then to to practically do that you need
to you need to believe that the going
back to this correctness of and I think
there is the could be a range of some
people believe it should be 10,000 and
some people would believe it's could be
less than a thousand so uh so if you are
in the camp of it should be 10,000 then
kind of probably probably in even in
both uh in both decisions you would say
well I want to be long eer I want to
hold eer and if you're in the camp of
well this is really not worth it it's
just worth 10,000 then again in both
sides so you need that person that says
well the price is pretty much much right
now and really that decision makes a
marginal difference for me to um uh to
hold the asset and then let's say let's
say there's a really good proposal and
you really like that so you go long on
that now you hold this conditional yes
now the next day some external
completely unrelated event happens where
the whole crypto Market crashes by 50%
you hold this uh yes
proposal and hold it under a price of um
well the price from yesterday um you
still think the proposal is good but now
your incentives are to um for the
proposal absolutely to not pass because
then you would hold all the dollars and
not the asset at a price that's now 50%
um uh or where the real asset is now 50%
cheaper from from what you bought it so
not sure if anyone could follow but
those are kind of the challenges I I I I
see so so 20 years ago we had a burst of
applications of pred markets including
in corporations so I think we saw
typical failure modes there that are
instructive about
today typically if you went to work with
a company about setting a prediction
Market you would say well what are your
most important issues and and you know
numbers you'd like to track and let's
set up markets on those and they would
usually say that's a little sensitive
let's do something a little safer and
they would pick safer topics and then
they'd get accurate estimates on them
and satisfied users but they go yeah but
we didn't really care about those so
you know that would be one outcome or
you know they would say talk about
something important and then management
couldn't resist having opinions that
disagreed with the market and the market
prediction markets on which tests would
actually go forward so they put up they
try to make a lot of tests and a lot of
them don't actually happen because they
have to coordinate a lot of different
parts of the military to make a test
happen if one part isn't there the whole
thing has to be scrapped and a lot of
money is lost and so they wanted to know
which things would actually happen and
they actually were able to better
estimate which tests would actually go
through it and maybe saved money by
cutting back earlier but then it was
more legible that they knew ahead of
time that it wasn't going to work and
that was a management problem so they
didn't want that anymore they'd rather
pretend they don't know how these things
are
failing yeah uh like I guess I'm going
to like talk about this from more like
consumer product building perspective
youi side and I think definitely like in
historically it's it's absolutely true
that marketplaces like very hard like uh
products to to Bo TR and to activate
like the atomic like Network effect uh I
think that like uh uh to incentivize
like market makers or liquidity
providers especially if you can always
build the model for for like elections
or Sports markets or especially in
Limitless cases like the financial
markets right you can use the the
volatility to understand how to price
them and so it can be attractive to
institutional market makers because it's
essentially like a short-term retail
option flow um but at the same time I
spoke to Robin about it in Berkeley like
kind of obsessing about incremental
improvements in the amm uh which we see
like for example like Paradigm just
launched the P PM amm right we're
actually going to spin up a contract for
it to see how how much of of improvement
is it uh but I definitely think that
challenge is like how do you incentivize
the market makers either you you use
cash or you use your token or what but
it's still a huge expense uh for for
bootstrap in like the initial Network
yeah but uh maybe over time it will be
will be worth it all right brilliant
thank you so much seeing us that's all
we have time for
[Applause]
thank you all for joining the morning
sessions we're going to have a quick
lunch break and be back here at 2: p.m.
there will be vitalic kicking off for
the biod defense this afternoon there's
a set of another amazing speakers in
this section so please grab some food be
back here at 2 p.m. bring some friends
this afternoon is going to be great
thank you everyone
[Music]
oh
you
[Music]
for
[Laughter]
[Music]
e
[Laughter]
[Music]
e e
welcome back everyone to diac day so
excited to have such a full room right
now we are going to get kicked off with
this afternoon session we will have a
mix and get started with biod defense of
italic buterin will get us kicked off
and then we'll go through a number of
different
rapid uh talk so when it comes to Q&A we
would love people to have Q&A and there
will be a section outside there's a
little Q&A Corner that the speaker at
the end of their talk will go to and
you'll be able to just go out there and
speak to them so please utilize that and
make sure you ask lots of questions
falic welcome to the stage thank you
[Music]
okay um so welcome to diak biod defense
uh so I think I'll start off by just
briefly recapping like how the hell I
even got here right uh because uh
basically you know I started off being
the ethereum guy and uh I'm historically
you know not a bio person and more of a
math and computer and economics person I
was definitely interested in longevity
almost since the beginning I read uh
Auber Gray's Book ending aging back when
I was 13 and that just really impressed
me both like the sheer importance of
solving aging but also the fact that
there is a road map to actually get us
there and so I was uh excited about
longevity the the whole time ever since
uh but then for D bod defense in
particular in 2021 there was this big
mem coin Mania that I'm sure you guys
all remember so first in 2016 there was
Dogecoin and and Dogecoin went up really
high and then during the 2020 21 bubble
a bunch of people basically started like
copycatting Dogecoin and making their
own dog themed coins and hoping that
they'll go up to and so some of these
people decided as a strategy that they
would put a large portion of their
supply into my wallet balance and then
publicly say vitalic buan supports this
coin even though I never touched it and
some of these coins just like went up
way higher than they should and so one
of this one of those big coins was
called CH but you knew there were also
others and I sold a bunch um um a bunch
of uh them and I donated some uh to a
couple of organizations in one of which
is crypto relief India so at the time in
India there was this big covid crisis
that was happening lots of people were
getting sick it looked very bad from
outside it looked like no one was really
caring about the situation and so I came
in and donated to this uh group that
originally B introduced me to and uh
first I donated a little bit and I
donated an amount of Sheba tokens that I
thought would be worth a few million
dollars at most but then and they ended
up managing to cash out like literally
$470 million and so after that
we so 470 million ended up being like
more than crypto relief India needs for
its whole road map and uh I was also
started uh researching and understanding
Co and bio and pandemic related topics
more heavily and bvy between myself and
some of my science advisers like
basically slowly formed and ended
up spending a significant chunk of that
mcoin funding on uh basically moonshot
topics that would that deal with uh all
kinds of anti-pandemic related efforts
in general so biod defense is important
right so compared to the natural
environment pop population density is
way higher than before urbanization
continues to increase we have very easy
worldwide air travel in the best case
scenarios we might even have like
rockets that will take us from New York
to Bangkok in one hour but uh I me Eli
Dorado told me that like that's probably
not going to be commercialized anytime
soon because Rockets are a little too
dangerous but we have supersonic Jets
they might take us there in like four or
5 hours and so I expect your travel to
just be even more ubiquitous factury
farming creates lots of pandemics
man-made pandemics so gain of function
research you know continues to happen
and uh basically continues to be a
source of risk and also synthetic
biology as a science growing potentially
making artificial pandemics even more of
a problem so biod defense is a big deal
uh Toby or in his book The precipice
talking about existential risk his view
is that the number one risk is AI and
the number two risk is a pandemic so
pics are important both because of like
big picture reasons and because of very
clear near-term reasons Co showed how
Humanity was underprepared for pandemics
and how centralized biod defense fails
so we saw this happen at every stage of
the pipeline we saw at the very
beginning of the pandemic December 20 20
or 2019 January 2020 a lot people
speaking out about the pandemic at the
beginning then in the spring there was
this very crazy situation where uh the
World Health Organization very publicly
and stridently announced that covid-19
is not airborne and of course at the
beginning this was like and this get
often gets defended as being a
well-intentioned um effort to basically
stop people from trying to stockpile and
like grab up all of the masks because
the p uh like pandemic emergency care
workers and need the masks but as often
happens with these kinds of social
engineering tricks it they ended up over
fit into a particular situation and as
time progressed like this basically just
turned into like this massive
misinformation that just confused people
for years and we saw years of delay on
basic air precaution measures and at the
same time people just pointlessly
wasting hours wiping servfaces um we saw
failures of centralized social
distancing mandates so mandatory
quarantines mandatory closing of
everything lots of people in lots of
countries just freaking hated it and
I think if you took the if you imagined
social the social distancing that was
forced on Humanity in 2020 and you
mentioned it as a pill and you think
about the kinds of side effects that it
might have in terms of the social fabric
the collect psyche and so on it would
have never passed um FDA approval not
even as an emergency treatment um so
also vaccines and I think vaccines are
good but at the same time there's a lot
of things about how vaccines were done
that can and should be criticized so
vaccines were mandated and at the same
time there was this very closed Source
information culture both the closed
Source process of actually developing
these vaccines but also the process of
safety testing them and again this was
this effort to try to create this
centralized message that would be
basically very clear and much cleaner
than anything is actually possible in
reality right that basically tried to
say vaccines have no risk and you and
you basically have to take them the real
of course is that vaccines have some
level of risk Co itself has even more
risk and so if you're interacting with
people you pretty much should take a
vaccine anyway but at the same time
vaccines do have you know like nonzero
risk and uh like basically yeah over
time the like trying to craft this
overly clean message actually ended up
sacrificing a lot of credibility right
so centralized biod defense has lots of
problems that we saw diac shows better
Solutions so the things that you'll hear
about over the next two hours include
one a lot of work on Clean Indoor Air so
in this room you see a lot of these
boxes they are passive air filters they
make this room much more covid safe than
pretty much any other room in this
conference venue and most other venue
rooms that that you'll see technology is
sticking things up your nose the future
of Co testing is either personal sensors
that we can breathe into or just passive
sensors in rooms that can just
detect when viruses um even exist open
epistemics so open public dashboards
that can help people understand where
pandemics are happening open vaccine
research open vaccine development the
development of types of vaccines that
can be easily manufactured anywhere in
the world and uh also research and uh
treatment so a lot of uh work needs to
be done in better understanding long Co
so for Co in particular the long-term
symptoms are basically the primary
reason why you should take it more
seriously than something like the cold
or the flu and there's a lot of very
important research happening and like
actually deeply understanding the
underlying mechanisms and then finally
actually treating these diseases so the
collection of these solutions that we
outline here basically will make
Humanity much more P resilient to
pandemics passively As a matter of
default regardless of what kind of
pandemic it is regardless of whether
it's a repeat an old one or it's gain a
function or it comes out out of a
factory farm or if someone created it
intentionally to start World War III
regardless of what you think your thread
model is Airborne diseases are the most
dangerous Cate category in terms of
causing catastrophic harm and this and
this will just across the board
passively make Humanity safer um and
there are some Active Solutions but they
only need to be turned on while
pandemics are actually happening and
even they are vastly less intrusive than
what we saw in the past finally Bridges
between diac longevity and BCI so this
bio is a connected field and a lot of
the work that is being done here is work
that is also valuable in these other
fields viral persistence a mechanism
that is the source of L covid also
explains mitochondrial dysfunction
inflammaging cognitive decline better
understanding of microbes in general
helps everyone better open imaging
technology is good for medicine and good
for treating and understanding diseases
also good for brain computer interfaces
so technology that I will talk about
here will improve our ability to
understand disease understand aging and
understand ourselves all across the
Spectrum and I'm excited for the next
couple of hours of diak Bio thank you
thank you
vitalic and next up we will have Elina
chin who will be dialing in remotely
please welcome to the stage Elina
[Music]
and and once the lab League hypothesis
was taken seriously by experts Broadley
that's when I went to the bulletin of
atomic scientists and asked them to
please convene International experts to
think of new Frameworks around uh risky
research that could cause pandemics and
so in the next 10 minutes I'll tell you
about ways that I think we should
structure a a future effective biorisk
and bios safety approach so as vitalic
mentioned that the number one takeaway
that most of us had from the covid-19
pandemic is that actually experts are
not very reliable during times of Crisis
and that they themselves can be a source
of uh misinformation and we saw that in
the covid-19 pandemic this this ranged
from you know human to human
transmission where the masks are
protective how the virus spreads whether
it's Airborne how to protect yourself uh
what is h immunity and and whether the
vaccine would prevent infection and and
most of all whether the pandemic might
have started in a lab and so so what do
you do about the situation right where
the experts are not even able to tell
you what is happening in real time so
fast forward 5 years since the pandemic
began we now know that expert experts
broadly around the world agree that both
natural and lab leak hypothesis are on
the table and briefly this just ranges
all the way from an animal at the market
infecting people to perhaps a villager
getting in infected and then traveling
to uhan or maybe a scientist was
infected in the field while collecting
samples and then went to uhan or that
there was an accident in the lab where
this virus was being handled uh
ultimately everyone agrees that the
original virus the precursor of this
virus must have come from bats but we
just do not agree on how it made its way
to uhan and so all the evidence today
remains circumstantial no natural or lab
Source has been found or
reported and and surprisingly 5 years
later no external investigation has been
conducted and what we know now is that
there were influential scientists who
sought to squash the theory calling a
conspiracy theory uh and this started
all the way at the beginning of the
pandemic so I was really fortunate to
publish my analysis of why I think the
evidence strongly points towards a lamb
origin in the New York Times this year
and just to sum this up but if if this
is the first time you've heard of this I
really recommend you check out the
article why do I think that covid-19
likely started in a lab this pandemic it
really could have been caused by any of
hundreds of different virus species and
any of tens of thousands of wildlife
markets in this region and in any of
thousands of large cities and in any
year but it was a SS like Corona virus
with a unique furin cleavage site this
is a gain of function feature that
emerged in uhan less than two years
after scientists there sometimes working
at low biosafety propos collecting and
creating viruses of that very same
design and all the hundreds of other
salac viruses we know today none of them
have such a feing CLE
side so this story why why haven't we
found the origin of covid-19 it's
because an incredible amount of data
continues to be withheld uh so This
concerns early cases the transmission
chain the Genome of the virus was
withheld in the early days including
early sequences still being withheld we
still do not have access to the
activities and cataloges at both the
wildlife Market in the city as well as
the Laboratories in the city so all of
these were not put out in the public a
lot of it was withheld and private
Communications private databases in
scientific journals and under peer
review sometimes an editor would reject
a paper and it would stay hidden for for
years uh and and private research
documents as well as thesis and Grant
proposals we only know about all of
these data today because they were
Unearthed by mostly internet sloops so
in independent vigilante sloops as well
as scientists and journalists and some
of these other documents were leaked by
people inside the US government or
others were sued for TR Freedom of
Information act so these things had to
be painstakingly pulled out of of the
sources uh what the covid-19 pandemic
really showed us was this complete lack
of interest in finding the origin of
covid-19 so if you look at the US
collaborators of the uhan scientists
they they admitted that their
collaboration never had never given them
access to the pathogen samples so these
are samples from bats and and even
people collected and stored in uhan uh
they could not reproduce the database of
the samples or virus sequences indeed
they they did not have access to the
database in real time that was in uhan
so they didn't even know about viruses
collected after 2015 even though the
funding covered their work through 2019
so that that's foure gap they do not
know about the viruses collected after
2015 in
uhan they did not ask their
collaborators in uhan if they had
started on experiments proposed in 2018
so this included experiments where they
were inserting furing clearage sites and
other gain of function features into s
like viruses in
uhan so some would say this is strategic
IGN ignorance right maybe they didn't
ask because they didn't want to have
information that they would then put
them in a difficult spot but I would
actually argue that it was structural
because they they never structured their
collaboration in a way that gave them
full access in real time to the samples
and even the
sequences and this problem really it
goes Way Beyond eal Health Alliance to
even up upwards in government earlier
this year the department of Def in the
US said that they had not been closely
tracking their funded projects they
could not even tell how much how much
funding they given to to Chinese
research that would enhance pathogens
with pandemic
potential and unfortunately the new US
government policy on this sort of
research that kicks in next may still
leaves many loopholes open in fact the
entire research pipeline that could have
caused the covid-19 pandemic Remains Not
subject to oversight so you can go
anywhere collect any novel pathogens no
oversight you can serly passage them so
adapt them to human cells even human ay
cells and even humanized Animals still
not subject to oversight so really
nothing has been done here to deal with
this risk of pandemics coming from labs
in this manner so unlike other
Technologies you know like nuclear
chemical even in transportation even
even flying planes where where you have
a serious accident there's no
independent body here for these sort of
pandemic risk research to to Really
conduct external oversight so there's no
independent external organization that
will uh have oversight of the of this
work around the US let's say and and and
when that's an incident there's no
investigation to go in by this in
independent body it's is usually all
self-investigation self-reporting
so this is a real problem because we are
we're now truly in an era of of pandemic
starting from Laboratories unlike 20
years ago today research for pandemic
risk is proliferating due to many
technological advances in gene
sequencing and synthesis as well as
dropping cost so now more and more labs
are gaining access to this ability to to
to create viruses in the lab from from
scratch just from based on the sequences
it's not very expensive and it uh and
unfortunately a lot of this is happening
at low bios safety in ways that cannot
contain airborne viruses like covid-19
let's say and it's importantly not being
systematically tracked so there's no one
really systematically tracking it even
at a national level in the
US so why why is the case and I think
that that the two problems here that
that really underly the challenge so the
first is that there are many penalties
and in fear of retaliation for for
virologists to be calling out their
peers so imagine if you start pointing
fingers at your at your colleagues for
doing risky research you can immediately
find yourself alienated and shut off
Grump uh funding applications as well as
Publications so this would essentially
destroy your career uh and and those who
have for gain of function so they they
want gain of function to happen they say
that you you can't put regulation on us
you can't put all this oversight on us
because then the us will lose the
Competitive Edge so the problem with
this is that even even these scientists
these leading experts as as seen in the
case of covid-19 cannot accurately
predict the risk of their cutting age
experiments it's really hard for them to
know what will happen when they're
working with novel pathogens and putting
in new
features so the the second problem here
is that we we are kind of stuck in this
9911 the Coty of of outbreaks being
either natural or deliberate and and
this is a problem because I think that
the risk risk of pandemics coming from
lamp accidents is much higher than the
risk of a pandemic coming from a
deliberate uh biot Terror incident so
unfortunately this story of let let's
defeat the bad guys let's let's defeat
the terrorists it gets much more
interest and funding it's much more sexy
than then telling people let let's just
stop people from having accidents let's
protect the good guys from having
accidents in their Labs so that this
whole field of accidental lab leaks has
been really neglected in my opinion and
and it it it is it's it compounded by
the fact that many many virologists are
afraid to call out their peers so very
little is being done and I have this
quote that really exemplifies this
problem so early on in the pandemic an
influential virologist said it really
bothered me that this was some
suggestion this was a lab construct so
the virus was causing the pandemic if it
turned out to be true it would really
bother the hell of me not just because
of people dying and so forth it's an
indictment of the field right so these
virologists and and not just him they
think that if covid came from a lab it
would indict the entire field of
virology so this this is a major
conflict of
interest so where do we go from here
clearly we should investigate the
original covid-19 so that we can restore
public trust imagine if you know a few
decades on the road it's found that this
pandemic started in a lab we need to be
able to look back and see our public
leaders as well as our scientists
leading the charge on investigating and
finding the lamp origin we don't want to
look back and see them being complicit
in the cover up suppressing an
investigation so the Tre three things
that I think should inform and a viable
bios safety strategy so the first thing
is that ENT is necessary but during a
crisis as we have seen is challenged by
Miss and disinformation a great amount
of information is actually kept private
and and not even for malicious reasons
we need a system to counter
misinformation from experts uh and and
journalists especially should be much
more skeptical and seek diverse input so
that they don't find themselves
amplifying the
misinformation and finally we we really
truly need an independent organization
and regulation that focuses on reducing
the risk of accidental pandemics so
thank you again for inviting me to give
this
talk thank you so much and next I'd like
to invite Rea to the
stage thank you so
[Music]
much thank
you um I'm going to tell you about what
we've done with um fund in from bvy but
first I want to explain the context and
why I'm so concerned about um the risk
of unnatural
pandemics these are just my
declarations I'm a physician and
infectious disease researcher from
Australia um so we hear about epidemics
all the time right we hear in the news
about Aven flu about impo um we know
that these things are never ending there
uh and actually the data shows the risk
of new emerging infections is increasing
really important to understand the past
and the present in order to look at what
the risk is in the future and this case
is a really good one because it
illustrates all the problems with the
medical community accepting the
possibility of unnatural epidemics and
this is bhagwan Shri Raj Nish whose cult
perpetrated the biggest documented bi
terrorism attack in the US in
1984 um the public health authorities
including the CDC judged that it was a
natural outbreak and there was a
politician who said no I think the Raj
Nishi did it and he was ridiculed and
shouted down uh and even six months
later when rajnish confessed that they'd
done it he wasn't believed so if you
even a confession isn't enough to
identify an unnatural outbreak where
does that leave us and then a full 12
months later the FBI was doing a ra a
raid on the ranch of the Raj Nishi and
came across their illegal biolab which
had far more dangerous pathogens in it
than the one they used for this
attack there's just so many examples
that I don't have time to give you about
the inability of the medical and Public
Health Community to ask the question
even about what is the origin of this
epidemic let alone identify unnatural
ones s Francisco in the 1950s the US
military sprayed bacteria over from a
ship in the ocean over the San Francisco
to see how far they could disperse a
biological weapon and people did get
they thought the bacteria was harmless
but people did get sick and one person
died no one knew anything about this
until 30 years later when a journalist
uncovered the truth um and the medical
community did not recognize that it was
an unnatural outbreak
then in the 60s the US military dropped
light bulbs into the subway system
filled with trillions of bacteria that
were a proxy for Anthrax it wasn't
actual Anthrax but a similar related
bacteria to see how the spores would
disperse in the um tunnels um in the
Soviet Union an island called vros Dena
was used as a biological weapons testing
facility and in 1979 they exploded a
small poox bomb
on this island there was a ship passing
by 15 km away uh where someone got
infected and it set off a big outbreak
of small pox a highly fatal outbreak in
the town of Aral and there's numerous
other examples including um a a pandemic
of flu that occurred in the 70s which
was traced back to an improperly
inactivated vaccine strain of the virus
and for 30 years scientists kept saying
denying that it was an unnatural
outbreak um this man Ken albeck was the
deputy director of the Soviet Union's
bioweapons program bio preparat and he
WR defected to the US and he wrote this
book which really details some of the
pretty mindblowing things they were
trying to do in the 60s and the' 70s
when the tools were much more clumsy
than what we have today so they were
trying to engineer even more fatal
versions of small poox shorten the
incubation period and to combine genes
from smallpox with other deadly viruses
like Lassa fever and if they were doing
that today it's just so easy to do it
whereas back then fortunately it was
much more difficult basically anything
with DNA can be edited um whether it's a
virus a plant a human being and of
course Human Genome editing started in
in 2016 in 2018 a Chinese scientist
caused an uproar by not only editing two
embryos but bringing them to B those
children being born he presented the
results at a conference and there was
this enormous Fae outrage by the whole
Global Community uh but very soon
afterwards the all the superpowers
jumped on board into what I think is the
new arms race which is engineering of
human beings um in the UK
and of course the objective is to
engineer super soldiers um in the UK you
can't even uh request a Freedom of
Information you can never find out what
they're doing so you can bypass
mandelian inheritance you can insert
hereditable characteristics you can
prime a whole population in the type of
attack that could be done today includes
um you know releasing in something that
would prime a population to make them
more vulnerable and then a second attack
with with uh a biological
weapon so like every type of Technology
whether it's robotics or AI biological
research has dual use potential so
mostly it's used for good um but it can
also be used for harm and we could be
living in a Jurassic Park of viruses and
not even know
it in the first synthetic virus was made
in 2020 and it was uh in 2002 sorry 20
25 years ago about 25 years ago by some
American scientists who created a
synthetic version of um
polio and then some Australian
scientists created a version of um Rel a
virus related to small poox that was
100% resistant to the vaccine and
universally fatal and that all that
research is open source which means
someone else can read it and copy those
methods in 2018 Canadian scientists
created uh a pox virus very closely
related to small pox called horse pox
and if you can make one you can make any
of those orthopox viruses um and there's
been a range of other quite scary
research including synthetic Ebola um
and ever since the SARS outbreak in 2003
scientists have been fascinated with
creating a SARS version too and there's
numerous Publications prior to the covid
pandemic detailing This
research so the the the guys who um
developed the can you put the slide
forward for me my pointer isn't working
um the the scientists who developed the
synthetic um horsebox virus they um uh
so the two so the two ways in which
unnatural pandemics can occur error or
teror teror and the picture on the left
is the sov anthrax outbreak um that was
a town in which the Soviet Union had a b
a weapons facility someone forgot to
replace the filter on an air vent one
night and all night long they were
pumping weaponized Anthrax into the town
next door and at least 100 people died
um but the Soviets said it was a natural
outbreak they said it was due to the wet
markets they made a big show of killing
dogs in the markets to to prove that it
and the interestingly at the height of
the Cold War the Americans agreed with
them completely that it was a natural
outbreak so from the medical and
scientific Community the consensus was
it was a natural outbreak and it wasn't
until the fall of the Soviet Union that
Boris yelson confessed that it had been
a lab leak um and in the case of um
Terror one of the other examples of an
anthrax outbreak is the one after 911
where it was pretty obvious because the
anthrax was mailed in envelope es with
threatening
letters today you can uh anyone can
create a biolab in their home um just as
you can make a meth lab in your kitchen
so too can you do a do it yourself
biolab and the um the possibilities are
really endless the scientists um that
made the synthetic pox virus said the
advance of technology means that no
disease-causing organism can forever be
eradicated because you can always make
make it in a lab and that's the
declining cost of Gene synthesis in that
same paper showing how accessible it is
today uh illegal biolabs in
2022 uh a code officer noticed a hose
sticking out of a warehouse in Reedley
California and uh very very slow and
inadequate response from us authorities
it took them three months to get a
warrant by the time they searched it
they found humanized about a thousand
humanized mice vials labeled Ebola HIV
SARS kv2 Etc and it was a biotech
company that was propos supposedly
making covid rapid antigen tests for
which you do not need animals or um live
virus and that's still um being
investigated as to how that happened but
it just shows you how wide open the risk
is in terms of current epidemics the
clay one empo in Democratic Republic of
Congo is a huge um problem 70% of the
cases are in children 80% of the debts
are in children this is much more highly
lethal than the empo that caused the
clay 2 epidemic in high inome countries
in 2022 there's a long sting in the tail
of SARS CO2 it's still causing
substantial excess
mortality and our research showed that
long Co um has major economic impacts in
2022 alone we estimated long Co cost $9
billion of losses in the Australian
economy from people being unable to work
at full capacity or not at or only at
partial capacity and then
h5n1 bird flu in the US 30% of
commercial milk samples on the
supermarket shelves are contaminated
with the virus if it's pasteurized milk
it's probably not live virus but if
you're into drinking raw milk it
probably is and it's just a matter of
this virus switching its preference from
birds to humans which have different
receptors in the upper respiratory tract
and then we've got a
pandemic now how do we detect these
pandemics when they are rising um the
risk is there how do we detect them the
traditional methods we use uh like lab
Lab diagnosis that depends on having a
test if it's a brand new disease there
is no test these are the graphs showing
these are data from w ho showing on the
top the date of symptom onset so that's
the day people got sick and on the
bottom the date of reporting so you can
see there's a substantial delay so by
the time you get official notifications
it's usually spread which is exactly
what happened in um Co so we've got
evidence from blood tests showing that
Co had spread through Europe and the US
in November December 2019 so we
developed an early warning AI system
using open source intelligence called
epat now a true epidemic disease grows
exponentially and that's why you go from
zero to 100 in a short period of time
and why Health Systems collapse and why
critical infrastructure collapses
because of this exponential growth so
time is critical and we're trying to
find the signals very early before
governments are aware of it and
literally the co response did occur in
the Red Zone um so we use three
different AI systems and we search in
over 50
languages in fact 70% of all the
intelligence we get is in non-english
languages which tells you how important
that multilingual intelligence is we
visualize the data in a number of
different ways and we do a pandemic
watch looking for undiagnosed
pneumonia we've published quite a bit of
research on it including um looking at
epidemic signals in Ukraine
um that in 2022 all um formal
surveillance ceased so there were no
more reporting of covid cases of TB of
HIV nothing so um we were able to give a
very comprehensive picture of what was
going on epidemic Wise from open source
data uh we also looked at radiation
signals in Ukraine using the same
methodology um but ultimately a tool
like this like epie watch and this is
where bvy has helped us as well well
with the philosophy of bvy as well is
that it's no good having a tool like Epi
watch being used by an elite few in some
building in Geneva or wherever really
has to be used at the Grassroots by
local health workers on their mobile
phones so that they're aware of what's
going on and they can connect the
intelligence with what they're seeing on
the ground and so we launched an app in
Hindi in
2023 um working with the um government
um the National Institute of
epidemiology which is a government
agency in India and we're continuing
that work now uh looking at evaluating
the use of this app hopefully next year
so thank you very
much thank you
Raina that was fascinating really
appreciate next up we have Tom who is
going to speak about Alzheimer's to
pandemics be VAR is a bio technology
company focused on preventing the
transmission of infectious
diseases we founded varo in early 2020
with the recognition of two
facts first the rate and spread of
infectious diseases of epidemics and
pandemics has been steadily increasing
for over 20
years despite that during the same time
frame there haven't been any significant
Innovations in preventing the spread of
diseases so why am I at
Devcon varo shares balik's vision for
diac and for decentralized pandemic
preparedness we believe in empowering
individuals around the world by giving
them access to technologies that allow
them to protect themselves and their
communities
varo has built a platform to detect the
presence of pathogens and
aerosols in real time with exquisite
sensitivity using easy to use and
affordable
devices actually let me stay here for a
second so aerosols are the tiny droplets
they're about a micrometer in size that
we release when we
breathe these tiny droplets hang in the
air they can stay in the air for days so
when an infected person is in an indoor
environment like a room like this for
example they release these aerosols and
they contain the bacteria or the viruses
that they're sick with and those just
hang out in the air and wait for someone
else to breathe them in this is how the
majority of infectious diseases
certainly respiratory diseases are
transmitted until now there really
hasn't been a way to Det detect the
presence of pathogens and
aerosols and that's what the varo
platform is designed to
do so the basis of our biosensor
platform is the micro amuno electrode we
call it the
miie the m is essentially a modified
semiconductor what we do is we take an
electrode and we attach an antibody like
molecule it's what we call a nano body
and that's what binds to the or the
pathogen that we're looking for to that
electrode this is a technology that was
originally developed by
neuroscientists at Washington University
in St Louis named John Sero and Carla
yudi and the name is not a coincidence
John Sero is my brother uh he's a
professor of Neurology uh at Washington
University and he originally developed
the M technology to study brain
chemistry and Alzheimer's disease he
would implant the amuno electrodes
into the brains of mice in order to
study the proteins that cause
Alzheimer's in 2020 John realized that
the same electrode technology that he
puts down into the brain of a mouse he
can stick up into the air to detect
covid he pulled in another collaborator
from Washington University an engineer
in aerosol scientist named Rajan Shakari
and these are our scientific Founders
and we've worked very very closely with
this team over the last four years to
develop this platform to where it is
today so I'm going to show a brief video
of our scientific Founders talking about
how we're leveraging the M platform to
develop two devices that are designed to
prevent the spread of infectious
diseases those two devices are the
breath-based
diagnostic and the air biodetector
so can we play the
video this is going to be a game changer
you are not just looking at the current
strains what is prevalent right now we
are also getting ready for what could be
in the future whether it's something we
know or it's an emerging pathogen Road
and have it ready to go gives us another
tool to work with in order to really get
on top or ahead of something like Co so
we won't be kind of slow like we were in
the pth we're using this in two devices
then the breathalizer and the air
quality
monitor if you wake up in the morning
resp own this you go to the pharmacy to
get a test the technician behind the
counter doesn't have to be trained um
they'll take this they'll pull off the
cap that activates the device breathe
into it um a single breath is enough to
get a reading here you then hand this
back to the technician who turns the
knob they then take this plug it into a
permanent device and then within 60
seconds from when you blew into it you
get a result of whether you're positive
or negative their quality monitor will
determine when pathogens are present it
also tell you when the pathogens are are
gone so you you can know you can
re-enter a room so you keep business
business open you keep people safe and
healthy um and you can still go about
your daily lives if you can identify
that initial route of where the infected
virus is being spread from you can
control the further spread of that
virus by deploying this device we also
want to ensure that the inequity which
is prevalent in the world is in many
ways
[Music]
addressed great so I want to take a
minute and talk about these two devices
that we're developing first is our
breath-based diagnostic what Carla
called the
breathalyzer the breath-based diagnostic
is capable of detecting multiple
pathogens from a single
breath in 60 seconds with sensitivity
that is comparable to
PCR it is a true point of care
device oh sorry
um so you can imagine going to a
pharmacy you get your diagnosis you can
get your medication before you leave
you can get a diagnosis with whatever
the known pathogen
is you can get your medication you can
get faster di methods like swabs or
PCR we recently completed a clinical
trial with this diagnostic device and I
don't need to go through all the details
of this I don't have time to do that
today although I'll be here afterwards
if anybody wants to talk about this
further but the clinical trial was a
great success it showed we have
Exquisite sensitivity and specificity
and patients reported that they
preferred this method of diagnosis which
is of course non-invasive compared to
PCR or the swabs that we've all become
familiar
with our second device is our air biod
detector so there's never been a device
like this before this is a device
that'll sit in a room like this
passively
sampling the air in that
room so if somebody were to enter that
room who were sick and infected
producing pathogenic
aerosols the air biodetector could sense
those those pathogens before you could
infect most if not all of the people in
that
room so This truly gives us the ability
to interfere in the transmission of
disease and prevent it in those
environments where people are most
susceptible which is in in indoor
environments during covid we know that
the overwhelming majority of cases of
covid were transmitted in indoor
environments through
aerosols so what does this mean for Dak
and what does varo mean for
DC so both of our devices rely on the M
technology but the m is a true platform
technology and we believe that there are
many applications for this some of which
we probably haven't even thought of
yet we want to empower people around the
world to innovate with this technology
and develop new things new ways to do it
people that have different backgrounds
different ideas different goals than
what we have at
varo by empowering people by giving them
access to this technology we're giving
them the ability to protect themselves
protect their families and protect their
communities so how are we doing
this varo has adopted an open-source
business model we're making all of our
plans designs and data publicly
available we've signed a pledge that we
will not enforce our patents against
third-party
innovators in fact we're going to
encourage people to adopt this
technology we're hiring an open- Source
Community manager to put all this
information and make it available
package it up so that it's easy for
people to access and even promote people
to come and enter into the open source
community and learn about our technology
and hopefully motivate them to take up
this technology and uh this has become
sort of the core of what we're doing in
Faro this is the core of our business
model see infectious diseases don't care
about
patents right they don't care about
borders they don't care about
intellectual property rights and we all
know this right we all live through the
same hellish pandemic for the last four
years what we want to do at
varo is open up all of this
technology you know we recognize that
it's a small company it's going to take
a lot of time for us to be able to
access markets like southeast Asia or
Africa viruses bacteria don't have those
restrictions so by empowering in
governments and companies and
individuals around the world to practice
our technology and to innovate around
that technology we're giving them the
ability to protect themselves protect
their people and protect their
economies it also allows us to ensure
that important Technologies like this
can get into markets in low and middle
income countries that may not normally
have access to these types of
Technologies and hopefully address the
gruesome inequity that we all saw during
the pandemic which vitalic actually
spoke about during his his opening
remarks so typically in the
pharmaceutical industry patents are your
competitive Advantage right and I've
been in this industry for my entire
career I've developed drugs and gotten
them approved by the FDA I've started
about a dozen biotech companies right
patents have always been sort of the
Bedrock of the biotech
Community but patents are a negative
right patents basically give you the
right to tell someone else they can't do
something what we're trying to do at
varo is turn that on its
head instead of standing behind our
patents and preventing Innovation we're
going to leverage our patents and
promote
Innovation we're going to get all of
this out into the world our competitive
Advantage instead of our patents will be
our
R&D so we're based in St Louis Missouri
uh we're in this great area called the
cortex Innovation community and we're
building a state-of-the-art
manufacturing facility to produce
mes and our challenge our competitive
advantages will be to produce the lowest
cost highest quality Mes in the world
and then Supply those to our
innovators give them the ability to
innovate and give them that secret sauce
the mes that they can incorporate into
their own devices or they can build
capacity for their own
countries we're doing something else I
haven't been uh keeping up with my
slides there we go so we're doing
something else with our R&D platform
that's important when we think about
pandemic P pandemic preparedness as well
we're creating a nano body Library so
you may remember I said at the beginning
of my talk that nanobodies are the
proteins that we link to our electrodes
to make mes and those are what bind
viruses and
bacteria we're creating a library with
trillions of different
nanobodies that will give us the ability
to develop mes very quickly against
whatever the next emerging pathogen is
whether it's SARS kv3 or monkey pox 2 or
whatever comes along that threatens to
become the next
pandemic our platform our R&D capability
will allow us to produce new mes against
those emerging pathogens Within within a
matter of weeks and deploy devices so
that hopefully the next time this comes
around we can get out in front of it we
can either bend the curve or maybe even
prevent the spread by getting those
devices for those emerging pathogens out
into the
world so at varo we're very passionate
about preventing the spread of
infectious
diseases
um we're grateful of metallic for his
support uh and for his support and
support supporting a new you know
business model for innovation in the
Biotech Industry so I will be here uh
I'll be out in in the back I have a few
demos that I can show of the uh the
breath based diagnostic device I have
some mes that I can show um so feel free
to come up and talk so thanks again for
having me and uh it's been a great
day thank you
Tom next up we have leis guestling he
will be joining joining us and there
will be some prizes so pay attention cuz
you have something to
[Music]
win hey everybody uh my name is Lewis
I'm from entropic engineering which is a
uh Design Services contractor in the
states um and we work with open Aeros
and the OS of project uh who are all
recipients of some uh uh money to do
stuff around
air quality indoor air quality
especially um preventing viral
transmission uh in the wake of the
pandemic so um I want to flag first of
all that uh I'm an engineer by trade so
I write software I wrote the software on
the toy that you saw in the booth out
there um and I got tagged into give this
presentation so you going have to bear
with me on that front um so here's a
question and uh we're going to do prices
right rules so closest without going
over um you eat about 1.8 kilograms of
food a day you drink about 2 kilograms
of water a day does anybody know how
much air you consume a
day hands somebody give me a hand yes
11000 11,000 liters I want it by
mass I heard 10 kilograms who was
that yeah all right toss him
one yeah let's say so 12 kilograms a day
that's a lot of air and there's stuff in
that air
um stuff in the air bad air is a bad
time so this is a this is from a study
about decision-making versus carbon
dioxide content so if you ever see uh
you know you know about uh hypoxia
effect on the brain long before you ever
get to anything like passing out you
start making really bad decisions so if
you wouldn't uh sign on a house drunk
you probably shouldn't sign on a house
above a couple thousand uh PPM of CO2 or
you will make terrible choices uh the
inverse effect is also true um bad air
is a bad time also uh because it leads
to Airborne infectious disease we all
know about covid but there's plenty of
other stuff tuberculosis chickenpox
measles all that stuff um some of it
there's great vaccines against some of
it nobody really knows and you really
don't want to catch it even if you have
a not particularly symptomatic case
there's a really interesting talk about
that you can stick around for
um also um the economics of it are
incredible um trying to do clean
air-based interventions is an excellent
way to reduce things like um heart
attacks uh um sorry heart attacks
um
uh blah uh children's test scores air
purifiers in classrooms are one of the
most economically effective way to boost
test scores compared to anything like uh
teacher training other interventions you
can find direct links between uh indoor
air quality in education spaces AB
ISM um and eventual health and economic
outcomes for for the people in those
spaces um so at entropic Engineering in
open Aros we think this is pretty cheap
and easy to fix you can have some really
high impact effects um masks especially
with fit testing this is another place
where we received some funding from bvy
to work on open- Source uh condensation
particle counters that can make it
really easy to do this kind of work um
portable air cleaners you can see one in
this picture of our office um Windows
these ones don't open but if you're in a
place where it's thermodynamically
acceptable you can open your windows
that's an excellent way to do some
mitigation of this kind of stuff um
simple HVAC upgrades like dropping in
better filters making sure you actually
change your filters um and we also do
some work with uh skin and eyesafe 222
nanometer germicidal UV light like this
one here there's also one on the display
table outside on the front um unlike
earlier 254 nmet Technologies this is
stuff that it's uh Rel relatively easy
to deploy because the threshold for skin
and eye damage is much much higher so
it's something that you can retrofit
into existing spaces a lot more easily
um is an excellent drop in
mitigation um so here's the real
question if this stuff is so cheap and
one of the big reasons that it's not
already fixed is it's invisible
literally when we're talking about
particulate in the air we're talking
about particles that are so small that
measuring them requires Innovative
Technologies to make them grow
physically large enough in the device
that we work with via condensation to
make them countable because they're so
small they don't meaningfully reflect
enough light to count them even under
laboratory conditions let alone with
your eyes like think about when you see
smog outside well that is the aggregate
effect of looking through a bunch of
particles in the air when you're inside
you just can't see it and you can't tell
um what kind of particles they are how
big they are and you also can't tell
what CO2 concentrations are like so you
can't tell the extent to which your
judgment is impaired and you're going to
expect poor health outcomes like that so
um what I'm here to talk
about is uh ukrit air also known as the
Clean Air tamagachi is something we've
been working on for the last five or six
weeks um this is a portable air quality
device uh that includes a virtual pet so
the idea is uh in low power mode there's
an e in screen on top which will wake
and update periodically um you've seen
them on in the Kindle so that supports
really low power operation um we hope to
get at at least a week or two out of it
um the hardware we have outside is
pre-production Hardware uh but we are
eventually hoping to sell these things
um virtual pet character and the whole
pitch of this is that when you think
about air quality especially indoor air
quality it's something that's really
easy to ignore like you can you can sit
there at work and think to yourself I
have kind of a headache whenever I sit
in this conference room but I got
something else to pay attention to and
that builds up every time you're exposed
to high CO2 levels every time you're
exposed to high particulate
concentration The Chronic health effects
of all of these are cumulative which
means that um you can ignore it and
ignore it and ignore it until 30 years
down the road it turns out that you've
had sqa from multiple uh low intensity
viral infections or you have developed
chronic lung lung problems from exposure
to particulate matter um so the concept
that we have here is a sort of
gamification approach where you in the
virtual are exposed to the same air by
virtue of it being with you it has
onboard sensors that can measure carbon
dioxide concentration and particulate
concentration and a couple other fun
things um except the virtual pet reacts
in real time much faster than you do so
what we're doing is sort of hacking your
judgment to say well you know you know
intellectually that there's going to be
long-term negative effects to uh bad air
quality that you're exposed to but uh if
we give if we make those B long-term
negative effects happen on a very short
term to this little guy especially if
he's cute um it's a it's sort of a way
to hack that decision-making
process um so you can play with him you
can arrange Furniture uh you can buy for
him various clean air interventions like
those that we have here you can buy him
an a HEPA filter you can buy him UV
lights you can have him wear a mask all
of that fun stuff that we think are sort
of
[Music]
um straightforward you know relatively
easy and effective interventions you can
also work uh apply to your character
um and that uh and the idea is uh let's
take this thing that for you know on the
on the human time scale and on the human
health time scale is essentially
invisible make it very visible
especially in a relatively fun way
um make make it make a lot more sense to
pay attention to that so
um that's the concept uh I'm not going
to try and do it during the talk because
I was uh very politely informed that
they're going to drag me off stage with
a shepherd's crook if I go over but um
you can catch me after the end of this
track out front and we'll probably do a
little bit of trivia and give away the
units that we have that are
pre-production you can find more
information about them at uk.com or
there's that information outside
um yeah uh so those are all
pre-production you can tell 3D printed
case um we assembled them inhouse so
they're a little bit of a precious
commodity but we're going to give them
away
um fun little bit of a crash project
uh blew blew the uh inseat Power circuit
breaker on the plane which apparently
they can restore um got to do some
laptop power management limiting to get
back on the road building these things
but um some other cool tricks that they
have up their sleeve compared to other
commercial air quality sensors is they
do barometric comp ation for CO2 so if
you live anywhere other than sort of uh
median height in in terms of elevation
or if you're on a plane or you're
climing Mountain um your air quality
sensor that you already have is almost
certainly lying to you if it's not
barometrically compensated so this is a
fun little trick that we do um this is
me flying from uh the last leg from
Korea to here where you can see that
without barometric compensation you're
underestimating carbon dioxide
concentration in the cabin by a couple
hundred PPM um so we think that's a fun
little bit of Special Sauce that went
into this project um they also have a
bar barometric pressure sensor on board
so if you uh want to climb a mountain
you can track your your altitude as you
go um and the other trick that we think
is really cool and should become
something that people expect in
mitigated spaces is on the topic of uh
these Airborne you know these air
quality problems being invisible if you
if you buy something like these HEPA
filters how do you even tell if they
work well one way you can do it is you
can keep track of the carbon dioxide or
um particulate concentration in the room
for HEPA filters you're looking at
particulate but for ventilation to
outside air like you're going to open
the window you want to look at carbon
dioxide um and you can do something you
can you know you can affect an
intervention like open a window or you
can affect an intervention like turn on
a HEPA filter and you can watch the rate
at which these Airborne contaminants
drop and with a little bit of math that
is baked into the UK Critters um you can
calculate uh you know what the what the
CO2 concentration change or what the
particulate concentration change tells
you about the um mitigation choices
you've made in your space usually
measured in air changes per hour which
is sort of one air change per hour means
volumetrically all the air in the room
would be cycled through once an hour um
that's great for measuring CO2 so if
you're going to affect some mitigation
like turn on your HVAC you can watch the
change in CO2 you can see a drop and if
you have a UK Critter with you it's
logging um so you can you can compute
the effectiveness of that intervention
and if you're going to switch on HEPA
filters uh you can take your UK Critter
and look at the record partic recorded
particulate concentration information
and compute what's called an effective
air changes per hour number
so
um I think that's the that's the last
cool trick for the UK Critter right now
um oh it also works as a Bluetooth
sensor you can talk to it over Bluetooth
and pull out current air quality
readings um um but it has Wi-Fi hardware
and we're excited in the future we're
hoping to ship some updates that will um
let us do privacy preserving uh
aggregation of air quality statistics
sort of like existing air quality sensor
networks um but that extend to places
that might not otherwise be reached like
you know the places you go in your daily
commute that fixed sensors aren't
appropriate for um this is open
source uh work it's uh you know we're
we're still in pre-production so you
can't I don't think the schematics are
up there yet but if you pester him in
the Discord maybe you'll get him to post
them um so if you have feedback we'd
love to hear it
um the website's out there it's also in
the firmware if you get one
uh please reach out if you'd like to
collaborate um I'd also like to say
thanks to bvy thanks to the ethereum
world I'm not a crypto person personally
but um the work that we've been up to at
entropic working on the uh clean air
tamagachi but also at open Aros and the
other efforts wouldn't have been
possible without you guys so um it's
something we really appreciate I think
I'm going to wrap it there but
uh thank you so much
leis and those air filters are outside
in the far left again for questions if
you got questions for leis head outside
to the um section to the right and he'll
have questions and answers over
there and next up we have Phillip uh
please join us on the stage
so thank you all for inviting me to come
and speak to you I want to talk to you a
little bit about some of the molecular
biology work that's going on
implications of how pandemics do more
than just harm individuals they actually
harm the social trust that exists
between individuals and a proper
pandemic preparedness plan has to have
in place widgets that can deal with the
virus but also Information Management
schemes so that we can prevent the
social harm that happens to societies by
the loss of trust that naturally occurs
between people when a virus is creeping
through and harming people and you don't
know what is happening so you're going
to see that the this is a tour through
some molecular biology work but I want
you to notice ways that information
management and blockchain kind of
Technology can make our societies more
robust to Future
pandemics so early on um I and several
other people noticed that the SARS cove2
virus had some really weird
characteristics if you do an alignment
of this virus against its most recent
common ancestors you find out that it
has a lot of mutations that are what are
called nonsynonymous mutations that
cluster in the receptor binding domain
uh it looks very engineered it's a
circum it's a remarkable coincidence
nonetheless Ness we made a bunch of PCR
primers uh regardless of where it came
from we made PCR primers and started
developing a test in our laboratory just
so that we could figure out who had it
and who didn't and maybe keep the
University of South Carolina functioning
properly uh we made this kind of a a PCR
test with our own primers and protocols
and proved that the PCR really will
detect um the virus and it'll detect it
down to single molecules in the well
this PCR essay does not have a false
positive problem you can cycle forever
and not on a on a negative sample and it
will never fire um but it can accurately
determine how much viruses in any sample
we then kind of accidentally discovered
that raw saliva works better than the
nasal swabs we discovered this for a
funny reason during the pandemic
lockdowns we ran out of nasal swabs and
ran out of RNA purification reagents so
we just tried it on Raw saliva and it
turned out that it worked fine it worked
even better than than the standard uh
procedures and it's kind of funny given
all the gatekeeping that has gone on
about nasal swabs and the type of swabs
that you have to use and all that sort
of stuff you don't even need any of that
stuff uh I tracked the virus uh as it
went through lots of individuals
students at the University of South
Carolina and families um and and I could
prove to myself that the virus was real
and that the PCR protocol was actually
predicting illness this is a family here
where some of the people got it and some
of them didn't and the the PCR signal U
predicted perfectly who was going to get
sick and who never did this family on
the right that's me and the blue curve
is me whenever I brought it home and
gave it to my wife and two daughters and
then they got sick later so I had access
to validating verifiable information
that the PCR results were tracking with
symptomology most people didn't have
access to this kind of verifying
information and after a while they kind
of became suspicious of hey is this
thing really telling me the truth or not
and they didn't know anybody like me
that they could ask to see is this is
real or
not another kind of interesting
phenomenon about this virus which
probably will see this again is the
asymptomatic super spreader phenomenon
now you may have heard about this I know
it's real this guy here was the brother
of one of my students that was working
in the lab and it we were testing
everybody every day as we were
developing this test and and we were
using all of our friends and family
members negative controls this guy blew
a positive and he had more more virus in
his saliva than there are people in
China but he had zero symptoms and on
day three he went on a sevenmile run and
clocked his normal time but this guy
could infect the whole world if he tried
and he would never have known about it
so this phenomenon is actually real
there are silent super spreaders that
walking Among Us and and reasonable
people grew suspicious about hey maybe
this PCR is like bogus maybe this is
lying to us or something like that cuz I
it's not really working when we're
trying to just quarantine People based
on being sick and again future pandemics
need to respond to this kind of
situation in a way that preserves social
trust we need to plan on this as being a
real thing and I think that the
information blockchain might be one
solution to this
problem here's here's a result of a
whole bunch of positives that we I'm
showing you from just one month of
testing we did like 300,000 people
300,000 tests over two-year period And
this is one month of positives and I
want you to notice the distribution of
CT values in PCR space um it's minus the
log of the CT value is kind of related
to two to the log of of of how much
starting material there is so these very
low CT values down here at 10 they have
a lot of virus and these higher CT
values around 30 or 32 they have a small
amount of virus those people at the
bottom in that Circle have a billion
times more it's a log scale they got a
billion times more virus than the
average those are what happened in the
Wuhan Market someone was infected and
didn't know it because they were an
asymptomatic super spreader but they had
enough virus that they could infect
everybody that was shopping that day or
that week this happens um it's a very
sneaky virus um and it causes mistrust
to develop because people are getting
sick and you don't know who they were
exposed to you know are they somehow um
you know worshiping the wrong God or are
they in the wrong political party or are
they guilty of wrong think and then the
the natural human brains tendency to
turn on each other takes over and it
fractures social trust and Society
begins to deteriorate this is what this
really really happened uh during the
pandemic and we're still dealing dealing
with the consequences of it
now okay a few words about the MRNA
vaccine the MRNA vaccines came on the
scene uh they were deployed under an
emergency situation we didn't have time
time for public trust to develop
organically okay it just we had to go
For Broke um because it was a dire
situation initially it was reported that
these vaccines were 90 something per
effective at preventing infection that
only lasted for about a month and then
they became very ineffective at
preventing transmission they do have
what appears to be durable protection
from Death about 80% of the time it does
reduce the probability of
dying this is still hotly debated
because people don't trust the
information that they're getting from
various sources we need ways of having
raw data being uploaded to some sort of
an information blockchain so that people
can see how the data is accumulating and
not be suspicious of who other is
gathering the data so that they can come
to their own decision about whether this
is real or not anyway um there's a lot
of side effects uh uh that are
unexplained and they tend to be
flippantly dismissed and this causes
more
distrust I use a lot of sequencing
technology in my lab we're Gene jocks
we're cancer Gene jocks we sequence
things all the time and we can discover
mutations or DNA sequences that we
didn't know we were looking for I did
this on vials at a vaccine okay this is
basically an internet dare that uh
somebody put me up to somebody else had
done this and I said this is crazy so I
did it myself and lo and behold I
discovered a bunch of DNA pieces uh in
the mRNA vaccines I thought wow this
might be the explanation for some of
these side effects that people are
seeing we should check into this and see
if these little bits of DNA are getting
into the Human Genome of vaccinated
people the public deserves to know what
they're taking if it's a vaccine or
anything else the public deserves to
know what's in it and molecular biology
tools can do this for
you this is kind of the sequencing
result of uh that came out of my lab
using a
um a a modern very cheap uh Deployable
sequencing platform I'll tell you about
it later if you ask me about it uh this
this technology you can use it in the
field if you want to you could sequence
something this is here all the little
pieces of DNA we discovered in a vaccine
there's a lot of them um and using this
technology you don't have to know what
you're looking for and you can see
what's in your saliva what's in your
vaccine what's in your food what's in
your environment all these things can be
answered by sequencing but public trust
can only be generated ated by making
this data on some sort of a public
Ledger and and it' be collected by
multiple sources and everybody can just
inspect it to see what's there think of
this kind of data as a form of a
contract you know or or some sort of a
blockchain of currency that you might
want to generate public confidence
in so we are doing some studies now
where we're monitoring The genome
Integrity of vaccinated people just to
see if this stuff is ever getting in
there I made some PCR primary against
the the DNA sequence that I found this
is what realtime PCR looks like in case
you want to know the cycle number here
at the bottom is how many cycles of the
machine does it take before you start
seeing product and the more Target was
in the well to begin with the fewer
Cycles it takes before you start seeing
stuff and the less product is there the
more Cycles it takes so that's why it's
backwards and it's a log scale but we
can quantify down to the molecule number
we can literally count molecules in any
sample with this with this kind ofch
technology and it doesn't suffer from a
false positive uh from too many cycles
um it's it's
reliable so we did an experiment can the
little pieces of DNA that are in the
vaccine um ever get into the human
genome and modify it I know it's this
was theoretically possible and I said
this publicly about a year ago well we
did an experiment to prove it we took
some normal human colon organoids these
are normal cells and we vaccinated them
in the lab by just putting the VAC seen
in the media and let it incubate for a
little while and then washed them and
then grew them and washed them over a
month and kept washing them and
passaging them and then we did the PCR
on the genomic DNA and lo and behold
there's stuff there and it's the exact
same frequency that I predicted about a
year ago about one in a thousand to one
in in 10,000 cells have taken up
different pieces of this vaccine and
it's a permanent fixture of their
genomes now okay this is not surprising
based on molecular biology first
principles we've been doing this for
years in the laboratory this proves that
it happens with this contaminating DNA
which is why I was so weirded out about
this stuff when I first discovered
it we've been looking at a bunch of
tumors from cancers that have shown up
uh since the vaccine rolled out and we
just looked at like 50 tumors so far uh
that were not really selected for
anything other than the fact that they
developed in the last three years and
we've got a couple of them that appear
to be positive for bits of this DNA now
we don't know if this is a driver event
or if it's a passenger event and we're
doing more investigations to try to
figure out where it landed and if it has
anything to do with the tumor or not but
it does happen so this is what we need
to the public needs um a careful
accounting of this so that their
confidence uh can be or lack thereof can
be appropriate and Based on data not
based on marketing or anything like
that so a final couple of words about
another kind of genome modification it's
called DNA methylation so your genome
has methylation methyl groups added to
cusine residues at cpg Losi in your
genome and and these modifications are
part of a developmental program that's
been going on since you were first
conceived and continues until you die
where you slowly change the methylation
landscape of stem cell genes and
eventually those stem cell genes begin
to be silenced and and you lose stem
cells as you grow older as if aging is
just a natural extension of the
developmental process that goes on in
utero and you eventually just run out of
stem cells and you die we can tell how
old you are by looking at the methyl
groups on lots of Loi in your
genome we've known for a little while
now that when your DNA methylation age
is disconnected from your physical age
especially if you're DNA ages too old
you're at high risk for all cause
mortality this is really a thing um and
there's a lot of interest in in finding
out what kind of things or interventions
can I do that will make me younger right
that will delay aging and we can have
surrogate markers for this with this DNA
methylation aging the same sequencing
platform that I was telling you about
earlier will measure methylation on the
fly at the same time we're figuring out
sequence alteration ations so you know
sequence analysis of normal blood cells
uh can agnostically monitor
for sequence changes and methylation
changes and figure out if some sort of
an intervention has altered the
methylation age all right so I did this
on a sample that was just available to
me this is me um pre- and
postvaccination and there are spots in
the genome that the methylation age
changed this is a real thing this is one
to people pre and post postco and pre-
and post methylation to see are these
interventions once you know what you're
looking for it's very cheap and easy to
do it a final thoughts pandemics stress
test the trust that people have in each
other low trust societies Faire worse
than high trust societies molecular
biology tools can measure these things
but molecular biology tools can best
increase public trust and future
pandemic preparedness if we make the
information available to the public so
that anyone can see it
um we should do this now and I'll stop
there thank you for your
attention thank you so much philli for
wonderful talk and for those of you who
are in the room if you remember these
talks you will actually get to win some
of the prizes that are outside that
everyone is going outside for so stay in
the room to enjoy the talks and actually
learn uh next up we have soam wonderful
to welcome you to the stage
[Music]
hey folks um I'm s sankran I'm the
founder of a company called Popa which
works on uh verifiable open source
vaccines intended to save millions of
lives from the developing World up and
I'll explain what all of that
means first let me say something that I
think has unfortunately become
controversial of recent times vaccines
are one of the most effective Public
Health interventions known to man uh
over the last 50 years they're estimated
and this is just childhood vaccines are
estimated to have saved over 150 million
lives across key pathogens that uh that
attack uh younger Children and
adolescents and when you add adult
vaccinations there are uh likely tens of
millions
more but there are pathogens uh
important pathogens that are quite
prevalent for which there are no
existing vaccines um these include uh
tuberculosis uh Strep a and hcv in
particular so just these three pathogens
and here I'm talking about tuberculosis
in adults not tuberculosis in children
uh kill uh over 1.8 million people per
year across the world and there are no
effective vaccines for them
today unfortunately instead of speeding
up vaccine development is slowing down
uh it it took uh the malaria vaccine
which is one of the more recent
infectious disease vaccines to be
licensed 35 years to go from concept to
lure um and uh these programs now
routinely cost 1 billion plus dollars
which is a a very large amount of money
to invest in a in a single drug um and
then because they're only dos let's say
between one and three times usually
unlike say glp1 Agonist like a zic which
are which are dose considerably more
frequently uh farmer companies do not
see them as a particularly High return
on investment and so they have pulled
back especially in the postco era from
investing in new infectious disease
vaccine programs in particular for
pathogens like TB which they see as
being only relevant in developing
countries which are
poorer uh but there's a potential
solution here so this is a a a sort of
graphic of the top 10 vaccine
manufacturers in the world by volume in
2021 uh during covid but excluding the
covid-19 vaccines and what you can see
here is that Indian vaccine
manufacturers including the serum
Institute of India are very substantial
in their presence they account for
almost 40% of the volume of vaccine
doses shipped
um and so why don't we vac so to speak
why don't we uh accelerate vaccine
development by relying on uh this
capacity that we have in India and other
developing countries um and also the
fact that you know you can do things
cheaper in countries like India right we
can do this we think 10x faster and 10x
cheaper and you might ask why aren't
people doing this already there are
already these big vaccine companies in
India surely they must be thinking on
these uh lines um unfortunately India as
a country spends almost nothing on
research and development um it is a joke
how little we spend on R&D across
government uh and across Private
Industry and Indian companies including
vaccine companies are not particularly
interested in taking technical risks uh
such as developing new vaccines for
pathogens where vaccines have been hard
to develop um and so Popa is trying to
solve this problem we are trying to
solve long-standing problems in vaccine
design including the three pathogens
that I mentioned where people have made
attempts but no success um using mRNA
and computational protein design to
tools that have just reached the point
where we can actually use them to make
novel vaccines that couldn't have been
made before as I'm sure many of you are
aware uh Demis sabis John jumper um and
David Baker just won the Nobel Prize in
chemistry recently for their work in
protein structure prediction and uh and
protein design and so these tools are
just now reaching the maturity where we
can actually use them productively um
and we want to leverage as I said the
talent cost and speed advantages of
operating in India which is to say uh
you know we are the only company or one
of the only companies doing this kind of
Novel vaccine development in India and
so the best talent in the country folks
who want to work on these world uh
changing problems but you know don't
have the opportunity uh essentially come
to
us unfortunately no one wanted to fund
Popa when I started this three years ago
um VCS and nonprofits essentially didn't
believe that the talent pool existed in
India to do this um The Gates Foundation
gave us an early 100K check um but that
was not enough to build a vaccine
platform or take anything uh to Clinic
as I said these vaccine programs they
routinely cost a billion dollars even if
you can do it for 10x cheaper that's
still hundreds of millions of dollars
right um and uh we had some good early
data about you know two and a half years
ago uh but it had rendered both me and
the company bankrupt uh then there was a
massive pump in Sheba Inu coin which I'm
given to understand is a meme coin of a
meme coin um and vitalic founded the
biocurity and Public Health Organization
balve uh and one of their Investments
was us um and so they've now funded us a
cumulative 15 plus million doar and I
think it's it's interesting that it took
uh vitalic somebody who is outside of
the sort of General hierarchy of of you
know Public Health funding to see what I
think is obvious which is that the
talent is there it was really a resource
constraint that meant that folks in
India had not had the opportunity to go
after these problems so let me talk a
bit about what we've actually done with
that money and and what that means for
the future so this is extremely dense
and I apologize in advance but I'll
explain what's going on here uh that
green thing that you see there is the
receptor bind against that particular
protein are the key drivers of
neutralization and protection in the
covid vaccines so it's a subset of the
spike protein that I'm sure all of you
have heard of it's not the entire Spike
it's just a part of it right what we've
done is we've pioneered an approach
where within mRNA we can encode uh a
self assembling virus-like particle
which is what is in the blue um that
basically displays a whole bunch of
copies of this RBD protein and in doing
so we've achieved two things one one is
uh We've achieved considerably more
potency so what that if you look at at
our sort of uh highlighted you know
bolded bar here two micrograms of our
RBD vlp display mRNA which uses this
approach provides 22x greater
neutralizing antibody response which
correlates quite highly with protection
uh compared with two micrograms of the
full Spike mRNA sequence from one of the
US approved covid vaccines and this is
all in mice uh and what's particularly
interesting about this is you know we
can use it to make a vaccine that's more
potent we can also use it to make a
vaccine that's potentially safer uh
because we can achieve with 95% less
dose as you can see at the top with just
0.1 micrograms we can achieve the same
result as you would without using our
strategy with 2 micrograms and so I can
inject much less mRNA much less lipid
nanoparticle and have potentially a much
safer product overall and the kinds of
things that Philip was talking about uh
you know all get worse as you increase
the dose of whatever your vaccine prod
or drug product is the other interesting
thing that we got here is breath so uh
if you think about covid-19 and why the
vaccines were less effective as we got
later into the pandemic the reason isn't
that they they didn't have a durable
response the reason is that the pathogen
evolved uh variants of the pathogen that
were no longer susceptible to the
antibodies El listed by the original
vaccines became prevalent um and as a
result of that we ended up with a
situation where uh what were very
effective vaccines at even preventing
transmission became relatively
ineffective as new variants evolved
however using this mRNA encoded VP
strategy what we've been able to do
actually is elicit antibodies that
neutralize a whole bread of of variants
so our uh construct is the red line
which is able to potently neutralize you
know even as it's diluted a whole bunch
of these other V variants while type
gamma Lambda Omicron ba1 um whereas the
the US approved covid vaccines the
original ones in blue not able to to
neutralize those other variants so this
approach which we are uh you know among
the first to to Pioneer in uh in MRN
protein design has potential substantial
gains for covid and and for other
pathogens like
influenza now let me talk a little bit
more broadly about what strategies like
this are actually trying to do right if
you think about any pathogen uh you know
it has a whole bunch of antigens which
are in the case of a virus those are
going to be proteins um that elicit
certain kinds of immune resp responses
certain types of antibodies right uh and
then some of those antibodies are going
to be uh functional you know they they
they they might sort of uh neutralize
the pathogen right some of those
antibodies are going to be
non-functional they might bind but not
neutralize or or not bind at all right
and then within the context of of these
functional uh antibodies there's some
subset of antibodies that you might
consider broadly functional and what
that means is even as the pathogen
evolves even as there are additional
variants that come up those antibodies
which are some subset of the the
original antibodies remain effective so
the intention of our vaccine design
approach is basically to move the
distribution of antibodies listed
whether it's in an animal or a human
towards these broadly functional
antibodies which have a chance of
providing durable protection against
even new variants that might emerge um
and this is relevant in the context of
of Co for uh this variant Evolution
story uh in the case of some of the
other pathogens that I mentioned for
example hcv it is absolutely essential
because hcv as a pathogen like HIV
evolves within it own host and so you
know if you were to be infected with hcv
you might have thousands of different
variants of the hcv pathogen within your
own body and so uh an antibody response
that is effective against just one of
them is not going to be effective at
clearing the pathogen uh so we've used
this uh you know we've used a variant of
of what's called an epitope scaffolding
approach uh to basically attempt to
elicit specific types of antibodies that
provide this kind of broad functionality
and Broad protection um and what we've
been able to do in just three uh these
these novel immunogens which can elicit
these antibodies uh much faster than
anybody typically does in in vaccine R&D
programs again as I said leveraging the
fact that we can do this research much
more cheaply and much more quickly in
India uh and what we found is mRNA in
particular gives us an advantage here uh
mRNA is of course not the actual
immunogen what you're injecting in mRNA
is almost code that encodes a a specific
design of immunogen that's intended to
elicit some antibody response um and so
because we're using mRNA which is a
stand standardized process we can test
thousands of different immunogens um and
then when we all light upon one that
that actually gives us the response we
want we can translate it not just into a
sort of lab environment but into an
actual GMP manufacturing environment
apologies uh we can translate not just
into a lab environment but into an
actual clinical environment into a into
a clinical study very quickly which is
not something that you can do with
conventional vaccines as easily which is
why you get these extremely long
timelines
right um and so what what we know so far
is basically this vac approach in India
it works right uh we've been able to do
this uh at 20x cheaper than you would
usually spend on a pre-clinical vaccine
program to build a new platform and get
to phase one uh We've 10x the testing
through P of a normal vaccine program uh
We've tested you know thousands and
thousands of of novel l&p formulations
of Novel designed immunogens which are
basically vaccine designs we've tested
them in vitro but we've also tested them
in Vivo 500 plus and we've been able to
achieve the results you saw in the begin
which is that our vaccine appears to be
much much better than the existing
covid-19 vaccines so what that means is
I can take 10x the number of shots on
goal for the same amount of funding as a
company in Boston or San Francisco and
potentially save 10x the number of lives
in the long run right if somebody gives
me 300 million dollars a company in
Boston and this is all based on a real
comparison with a uh you know with a a
biotech company that's developing
vaccines and doing quite well doing so
uh you know they might take uh one
candidate to a through a phase one
clinical trial and be getting ready for
a phase two clinical trial with a new
platform for us we've been able to build
a new platform and with that amount of
money with $300 million we would be able
to take 10 new candidates to phase one
and two and potentially bring multiple
products to lure and again you know in
the long run that saves a lot of lives
right because every year we wait to
develop these vaccines millions of
people are
dying um another key piece of this is
that we've built our own GMP
manufacturing facility so what that
means is uh we have the ability within
our own facility to make clinical doses
uh in a way that's safe to inject in
humans uh such that we can very quickly
take these new candidates and Advance
them to clinical studies and here I'll
reference what Philip was talking about
a little bit right I think it's critical
to ensure uh that we build a process
that is not only uh you know safe by the
standards of existing regulatory Norms
but is legible enough and is
understandable by the general public
that they trust what comes out of our
work right um
and so the good news here is and in fact
I'll be I'm announcing this today we
just announced it via press release this
morning is that niad which is part of
the US National Institutes of Health has
selected our next Generation covid-19
vaccine as part of the US government's
project NextGen for a phase one trial
which will happen in the US early next
year which to my knowledge is one of the
first clinical trials of an Indian
design vaccine in the US in fact no
Indian vaccine or Indian design vaccine
uh has ever been approved in the US no
Indian company's vaccine has ever been
approved in the US and Our intention is
to to have our vaccines available all
over the world right not just in rich
countries not just in poor countries but
but to everybody um and so this is very
exciting news because I think what this
means is our approach uh which as I said
up top is an approach that at the
beginning nobody supported right nobody
believed that we have the talent in
India to do this nobody was certain you
know or people in fact were quite
certain that we wouldn't be able to do
this right and it took an early bet from
Gates and a substantial bed from vitalik
and his team to support this has now
been essentially co-signed by one of the
most credible organizations in public
health right so niad thinks that this
vaccine works very well um at least
preclinically and they think it's worth
evaluating in in
humans uh the covid vaccines have you
know have been somewhat maligned but
best estimates suggest they saved tens
of millions of lives we can quibble
about specific numbers but it's it's
likely a very large number right but
again as Philip was talking about
there's been there have been a lot of
questions about whether the process
followed and approving these vaccines um
you know were processes that are
appropriate for human health um and at
the same time you know on the other side
of the coin the reality is that a lot of
people who wanted these vaccines in
developing countries didn't get them uh
because fiser and Mna were not that
interested in selling their vaccines at
knockdown prices in poor countries right
um and so what what we've done is we've
worked with Bal to come up with a model
um where we will be open sourcing our
covid-19 vaccine we will not be
enforcing our intellectual property on
that vaccine uh for a number of years
and what we'll be allowing people to do
is to verify ify not just the R&D
processes that led to That vaccine but
also the manufacturing processes so that
manufacturers across the rest of the
world uh can not only make copies of
this vaccine themselves they can
distribute at low cost um but also that
uh people can understand whether the
processes that we've used in developing
and Manufacturing this vaccine are
compatible with what we say out in
public um and are safe for them right
they can have independent scientists
evaluate these processes in a way that
existing vaccine companies don't make
enough information available to do um
and that's something that we can do
because we are comfortable releasing far
more information than anybody has ever
done um for a vaccine development or
manufacturing program before let me just
briefly talk about what we call the Popa
Million Lives Mission uh as I said there
are these three pathogens that
collectively kill 1.8 million plus
people per year um we want to develop
effective vaccines against all three of
them that we think can save over a
million lives per year um we want to do
this using a new sustainable model for
funding for public health vaccines
similar to what we've done with vitalik
and his team um where you know we will
provide full details needed for vaccine
verification R&D Improvement and
Manufacturing openly we'll cap profits
in developing countries and allow for
open licensing on transparent terms of
of this intellectual property um and we
will have uncapped profits in rich
countries right and this is a model that
you know that we want to advance uh that
we think could be the future of of
sustainable vaccine
development uh yeah I'm I'm happy to
take your questions outside and please
feel free to email me if you're
interested in working with us funding us
or collaborating with us thank you so
much thank you so much that was great
and next up we have a remote speaker
that will be dialing in Amy so please
take it away
[Music]
hi I'm Amy proall I'm the president and
research director of poly bio Research
Foundation and today I'm truly excited
to talk to you about viruses and chronic
aging building a research community so
where am I going with this first what I
want to talk about is viruses as drivers
of Aging processes this is really not
discussed and as understood as it should
be and there's so many compelling
examples of how viruses can contribute
to Chronic aging processes this is
really important for the longevity
community and for people who are just
dealing with many forms of chronic
disease if we understand these
interactions we can better figure out
how to combat them and how to best uh
create strategies to mitigate uh viral
effects on Aging so let me give you some
examples of viruses and how they
contribute to aging processes so there's
definitely many drivers of human aging
but here are some of the three main
factors mitochondrial dysfunction these
are the Just Energy powerhouses of
ourselves and they become dysfunctional
as we age often inflammaging which is
basically just the fact that over time
as people get older tend to have more
chronic inflammation more immune cells
that are just activated in an
unproductive way that's called
inflammation and cognitive decline
obviously people who are getting older
and aging have memory problems they have
brain you know dementia even post
Alzheimer's type phenomenon even
sometimes so one thing to understand is
that as we age and in fact as we are
born um and across the Scopes of Our
Lives we inherit um viruses from our
parents chronic viruses sometimes um
they past in some cases in the womb plus
we also over the course of our lives and
this happens with exposures with other
people it happens from our environment
and sometimes the foods and other things
that we consume we accumulate different
viruses and they become part of what is
known as our human virum the virus is in
us and there are many viruses that
become a burden in our systems as we
just live these are the herpes viruses
the papala viruses um and increasingly a
growing number of RNA viruses are also
understood to be um persistent viruses
that are with us for life now what is
this virum then do to aging well
consider just some of these virum
components this is you know sometimes
when people are let's say in college
they gave mono and people understand
that people get sick they get a sore
throat they don't feel well they're
feverish they try to avoid people for a
while what really means uh when you get
mono is that you get the abstein bar
virus it's a herpes virus and that virus
stays with you again this is a
persistent virus once you have it it
does not clear your system it stays with
you for the rest of your life this is
the thing if someone's immune system is
robust if it's in a good shape if it's
active what the immune system does
technically is keep these chronic
viruses like the Epstein by virus if you
get it and over 90% of people in the
world by the way Harbor upstein Bar
virus keeps these viruses in check it
keeps them in a dormant form the immune
system keeps them in a latent form and
that way they technically cannot
activate and create more proteins or
things that can actually drive disease
or potentially aging
processes
now however if viruses do become active
if they are moving out of a state of
dorcy because something happens to the
immune system this could be many things
it could be another infection it could
be just exposure to pollutants to
chemicals to many things that wear down
our immune systems over time viruses can
become more active and one of the things
that viruses do when they activate is
that they affect our mitochondria
directly in fact this is one of the key
things to understand about viruses our
health and aging is that viruses are
actually obligate intracellular
pathogens and what that means is by
definition they are not even alive they
must in order to replicate and create
new versions of their cells they must
pull the substrates the backbones to do
that to create new versions of
themselves from our human cells from our
mitochondria so they do this every
single virus hijacks our mitochondria in
order to create new versions of itself
and do basically anything that it does
this is a paper that I wrote about this
phenomenon with my colleague
neuroscience ITI at Poly bio Mike vaner
who also is a neuroscientist at Harvard
we wrote about how pathogens bacterial
viral fungal parasite pathogens even
hijack the metabolism or the
mitochondria of the host cells they
infect to just gain those basic
substrates again to just create new
versions of themselves this is core to
what they do this is a diagram from our
paper this is basically a human
mitochondria in the diagram at the
intermediate of that paper of the you
can see the TCA cycle that's a very
important part of just gaining
substrates for our own energy metabolism
so that we can function buring glucose
you know burn other fuels that allow our
mitochondria to make us uh energy
producers in a in a good way the blue
boxes contain different human viruses
that are part or can be part of the
human virum persistent chronic viruses
and those are just the different parts
of metabolic pathways that they hack or
hijack as part of their ability to just
create new versions of themselves or
replicate okay so I mentioned before
that inflammaging just chronic
inflammation often accelerating over
time is also strongly associated with
human aging and issues with longevity
for example in this paper now what
inflammation often results from is the
activation of immune cells including
cyto kindes which become active and
question one of the questions is why but
we certainly know that especially cyto
Namine cells become active now is 11 is
an example of cyto so it's an
inflammatory molecule in the human body
that can become more active When Things
become inflamed now this doesn't may you
know seem too surprising then in this
paper this team showed that inhibiting
this inflammatory molecule the cyto uh I
11 extended Mamon Health span and
lifespan suggesting that inhibition of
some forms of inflammation is helpful
for in that regard now what though in
the first place was causing that cyto 11
or interlan 11 to be active to be more
active than it should be well one of the
biggest driving factors again that so
many viruses and other bacteria or
pathogens or parasites do is they
activate immune cells as part of their
persistence what happens is the immune
system recognizes them tries to Target
them or to keep them in check and in the
process becomes more active perpetually
more perpetually active so here is a
study showing that that cyto um I 11 or
interlan 11 is actually stimulated both
in animals and in the lab by viruses
including respiratory viruses so these
are drivers of inflammaging most
pathogens can be direct drivers of
inflammaging okay now we just have the
ability that viruses and bacteria but
I'm going to focus on viruses here can
basically just hack the signaling
Pathways that are the heart of our
longevity health networks for example
there are Pathways in the human body
that control processes associated with
cellular syence for example that's the
ability of a cell to correctly divide to
correctly grow not overdo that not sort
of underdo that process but to do it
robustly there are networks in the human
body that scientists have calculated as
mattering in terms of human signaling
associated with longevity well this team
did a network-based analysis and they
uncovered dozens of viruses that encode
proteins experiment demonstrated to
interact with proteins associated with
these human aging Networks including sin
Essence so so just dozens of viruses and
and thousands of interactions between
these viral proteins to the point where
they ended up calling dozens of viruses
in the study that they identified age
disorders because of the fact that their
proteins could have such detrimental or
modulatory effects on these aging
networks in other words their
reproduction and their ability to
replicate benefits from directly from
interference with their host aging
processes and here on this chart are
just some of the top viruses that were
basically shown to have proteins that
interfered with human cellular syence
Pathways there're the herpes viruses
which most of us acquire over the course
of Our Lives the papala virus is
interestingly influenza A virus was one
of the top drivers of aging and we never
even think about the flu type viruses
which is influenza in an aging capacity
um but we probably should a little bit
more so with that in mind
then this is a final takea away from
that paper this is what the team
concluded owing to the considerable
number of human viruses this
evolutionary minded view encourages a
reconceptualization of the locus of
Aging no longer exclusively focused on
our own genetic material but expanded
towards a larger set of genetic entities
interacting with our species such as
viruses so Boom the heart of Aging all
right now what about cognitive decline
what about just direct mechanisms by
which viruses or other pathogens can
drive cognitive decline here is one this
is a team that we work with at Harvard
Medical School they're really cool
they've been using models of a brain in
a dish where they actually recreate the
neuron structures of a brain in a model
or just experiments in mice to show that
the Alzheimer's plaque the ameloid beta
plaque that is the the plaque that forms
in the brains of patients with
Alzheimer's disease that defines the
disease actually acts as an
antimicrobial peptide or part of the
immune response that forms in response
to pathogens directly in order to combat
them so basically what happens is
there's a virus that gets into the brain
tissue model and then the plaque forms
around it as part of the response to the
virus that's what they were showing in
this study and response to the herpes
viruses but this team is also shown the
same Phenomenon with bacterial pathogens
and with fungal pathogens this places
infection at the heart of the driving of
amalo plaque in the Alzheimer's brain
here's another example of a team who's
working on the same phenomenon Ben re
heads group at Arizona State University
this is an image of cyto megala virus
which is another herpes viruses that
many of us just carry with us for life
it's look in the image here it's
concentrated in the micral immune cells
of the brain around the plaques of these
cells along with the axin and dendrites
of neurons again that are inflamed and
directly part of the Alzheimer's disease
process so there are growing number of
teams connecting viruses directly to to
neurod
degeneration now this is an interesting
study okay what do we do well there's
some really low hanging fruit no one's
even doing anything about this and this
is an example of just easy measures we
could take to control the impact of
viruses on Aging if we made it a
priority this is the team in Taiwan and
what they did is they tracked people
over time some of whom were given just
affordable herpes virus existing generic
medications so for example let's say
someone gets ginal herpes they're giv
Val checks it's just an over-the-counter
herpes anti- herpes virus drug so some
of the people in the study were given
more of those anti-herpes virus drugs
and some weren't when they looked at the
group that was given these anti-herpetic
medications they had a much lower risk
of dementia than the people who didn't
in fact up to a 10 times lower risk of
dementia so really it's extremely low
hanging fruit to maybe start to use some
of the drugs that we have to inhibit
viral activity in the context of human
aging now what about in Co long covid
now I know we're all a little burned out
on Co but really like part of what our
group does is study still The Chronic
consequences of SARS Co 2 we have to
it's because it's one more virus that is
one of these players that could
contribute to chronic disease and
unfortunately aging processes and you'll
hear about long Co and it sounds like a
vague phenomenon when you hear about it
in the news often really it's not though
a lot of us that are directly studying
long covid realize that the Persistence
of the SARS c 2 virus in tissue and the
human body over time in other words SARS
c 2 potentially becoming just another
member of the human virum is happening
in at least a decent number of people
with Lan Co and here's a paper that a
group of us of lanco researchers wrote
about SARS CO2 persistence as a driver
of postco symptoms here's an example of
a team that we work with this is in the
bottom right gut tissue from the lining
of the gut collected from someone almost
in one case over two years after they
got covid and in this case the person
did have symptoms they had chronic
symptoms but still this that what you're
seeing there in the purple that that
pink part is the SARS cooku virus still
there in the gut tissue after over two
years sort of embedded there with immune
cells around it clustered preventing it
potentially from being cleared so it's
there in a persistent capacity which
means that at least in some people SARS
c 2 may be acting or seems to be acting
as a persistent virus that can also
contribute to chronic disease and aging
processes in fact this is a table from
one of our papers that just this is just
some there are some of the studies that
have shown persistent SARS cope 2 up to
again over two years or more after
initial infection in at least a subset
of people okay so then what do we do
about this well one of the drugs we're
actually looking about in the long covid
world is rap ayin which I know that some
of you will be familiar with in the
context of mitigating aging or or
extending lifespan so we are actually
running at Mount Sinai um in New York
where I serve as the scientific director
of a clinic called core um which is a
treating people with conditions
initiated or exacerbated by infection is
we're actually running a trial of
rapamycin in patients with long covid
rapamycin is an mour inhibitor that has
you know different properties on the
immune system now one of the things
that's really interesting about Ramy is
that in some studies at least rapalogues
or analoges of Romy and drugs similar to
it have been shown to in a low once a
week dose not in a high dose in a lower
dose to enhance parts of the immune
response that can better control viral
infection so for example that trial that
I showed you gave patients two rapalogs
over the course of six weeks and a
couple things happened first they showed
that people taking Romy and an increase
and interfere on induced antiviral gene
expression with interferons being one of
the primary molecules or parts of the
human response that combats viruses and
keeps them down also the people in rap
the ramyon group everyone in the trial
was given the influenza vaccine but
those who took Ramon had a more robust
response to the vaccine in other words
their immune system seemed to activate
more and create more antibodies in
response to that vaccine also the
participants on rapy even though they
just took the drugs for six weeks
reported a lower rate of infection for a
full year after being on the rapy this
includes respiratory infections UTI
though all a multiple types of infection
suggesting again that rapamycin was
helping to control viral activity and in
a related study the team found that
rapamycin in some patients um improve t-
cell exhaustion and again when viruses
persist they tend to knock down te-
cells uh and their activity which are
parts of immune system making them
literally exhausted EV Romy was shown to
potentially improve that again so rap
ayin we're triing now to see if it might
help patients who have a persistent SARS
C2 or other virus problems in Long covid
better control those infections and what
this means is there's you know a use of
rapy in terms of potential viral control
that is also probably relevant to human
aging well that was fascinating I really
enjoyed that one um a big thank you to
Amy for dialing in and next we have Mary
L jabson who has some exciting gadgets
as well to go through on stage with us
welcome to the stage
Mary okay Round of
Applause hi great to be here uh just
first a brief intro to myself
um I'm a hard tech Pioneer in moonshot I
created multiple multi-billion dollar
products on the hay edge of physics
former MIT Professor Brown University
PhD in physics and about eight years ago
I started my latest project it's called
open water and in rooms like these we've
been building the fact that our
bodies can be penetrated by infrared
light ultrasound and
electromagnetics and a belief that maybe
we could leap frog current Health Care
Systems and even drugs by modulating the
phase of light and
sound so we've been doing that for a
while um and and the reason that I did
it is I've shipped a lot of innovative
silicon chips so using silicon
manufacturing that's coming online in
consumer electronics and phase
wve
steering I knew that we could steer
beams of light decode phase with
interference and even
selectively select uh or destroy certain
cells or stimulate certain cells so we
built these systems up for about four
years got pretty interesting results
filed a bunch of patents a lot of work
and decided in early 2020 to get them
into hospitals start testing this on
people and the results are somewhat
spectacular first in stroke large vessel
occlusion stroke is the number two
killer in the world if you could
diagnose that stroke in an ambulance you
could get the patient to the one of less
than 5% of hospitals million dollars
from the Shibu enu coin woohoo thank you
non delative and it made it's made all
the difference with that
money we've been able to reduce those
carts from really laser the size of a
room
to this that's going into production
next month and those next month this is
a platform with a life-saving pan
disease potential for not just stroke
but all cardiovascular disease not just
gleo blastoma but all cancers not just
mental disease but potentially all
mental disease and
Beyond so open source make hardware and
software open source open sourced all of
our
patents you still need approval to use
it on
somebody it's FDA it's regulatory
approval the reality is in a
comprehensive paper published recently
the average cost of a novel theraputic
medical device approval is now $658
million in capitalized cost in 13 years
so even if you open source it huh what
do you do well the key is here 85% of
that cost isn't in clinical trials it's
in the
device so that takes a lot out further
another 7% of that is in safety so share
the safety do we want a safer device or
a less safe device will the regulator be
able to approve a device pan cancer
disease with lots with a 100 times more
safety data will that make a choice
easier or not will a doctor and patient
find it easier to be able to access the
safety data we think it's yes on all of
those running those numbers our
hypothesis is we take 653 million out of
the cost of developing a novel medical
device with a denovo approval so down to
5 million sub three
years so how does this work phase wave
modulation well these are the waves in
light and sound and what we do for
example on these yellow emitters is we
delay the phase from emitter to emitter
so we can focus that sound near or far
right or left up or down anywhere we
wish to in the brain or the body so gleo
blastoma cells can hide out among
healthy neurons and the neurosurgeon you
know they can't take them all cancer
cells have really large nucleuses and
small
cytoplasms and we can exploit that like
an opera singer can ping this wine glass
hit that note and destroy that wine
glass and harm nothing else in the room
so that's what we're doing with gleo
blastoma we did sonification parameter
sweeps found the frequencies this is low
intensity ultrasound lower intensity
than used for Diagnostic reasons on
pregnant women and their fetuses for the
last 50 years in rich countries but
these cells can't take it we're
destroying
them and here at a different frequency I
can tell you the frequency of this is
400 khz the other one was 150
khz we're able to turn on stimulate
or um Des stimulate uh neurons and
that's been helpful not just for
non-invasive brain computer interface
but also for pulling people out of
mental disease addictions and so forth
It's all together I
think we're enabling read WR brain
computer interface while we're trying to
solve mental diseases it's they're
impossible to separate so another module
this is our read module uses that laser
I just picked up that we've reduced down
this
laser and a bunch of camera chips four
camera chips that are in your smartphone
and those camera chips are super small
we take the lens off and they've got
they're cheap because they're small they
have pixel sizes the size of the
wavelength of light so we let that light
go into oh that didn't play okay we'll
let that light go into the head and what
we see on that camera chip is this and
it looks like the waves on the ocean and
we can read the waves on the ocean like
a sailor can read the waves on the ocean
and know where the fish are know where
the land is here
we interrogate a blood vessel and the
pattern changes because where the light
hits the moving blood cells it Ricochet
is differently changing that pattern and
we we can read blood flow very accurate
accurately with this way in fact we can
read it 20 times more accurately by some
measures than multi-million dollar MRI
or CT scanners with this laser and some
camera chips so that's not just good for
stroke but all cardiovascular disease
and all Micro Motions of the body we
believe so to get this far we've been
working with a whole bunch of great
institutes but everybody wants it so
that's why we Shrunk the system down and
decided to go into production and also
you you can build it it's all on GitHub
you can build it yourself if you'd like
to everyone that want I want to mention
here there's also evidence we may be
able to suppress cyto storms as Amy just
discussed the impact of them treat
inflammation even deactivate covid with
the same way we're
deactivating Leo blastoma cells there's
some evidence we're working on that in
our labs and we're using our devices to
do research on long covid and micr clots
we can see if we can ID them and if we
can break them
apart so as we
discussed this is the problem $658
million in 13 years it's why we don't
get any new devices it's why Health
we've got 20 to 40 year Innovation
modes so here's what we're doing about
it we're flipping it on a side to make a
open- source General general purpose
platform and the apps on top of these
are the treatments so those are the ones
with regulatory approval 3 years $5
million then we get into they call it a
510k substantial equivalent sub $1
million sub one
year so the question where look it's
free as in beer free as in speech not
free as in beer like you can publish the
recipe of the beer you can go make your
own at home most of us just go to the
store to buy it but by making more of
something it's cheaper we enjoy a
portion of that savings is
profit we engender trust that's new we
don't charge $1,400 for an EpiPen one
day if we Mis step on something if we
screw up you can go get it made yourself
but we ensure quality standard that's
IRB ready and FDA ready where ISO 1345
compatible by safety sharing we have the
cost of clinical trials and double the
speed for our customers Plus everybody
just benefits that's a cycle of
innovation that's not a 20-year
Mo so here are these new units I've got
them out here Liu and open motion all
the electronics are going into the
Mechanicals and being tested so they'll
be ready next month here's more and this
brings me to a moment we also did
something uh just to save another
$150,000 using our smartphone and
metallic are you going to come up to get
scanned in so this is just
in so we prepped a little on this so
this is the whole unit that's replacing
that room and so if we put this on
you
H I can actually turn it
on can see it so and then I
will oops the strapping is being
perfected it's I don't think it's sticky
enough can you all right so what we do
oops thank you for doing that I just
open the wrong nap so I'm just putting
in a number here and then I
start and
uh it's just saying unable to focus okay
try again okay
um
okay so I'm just taking some pictures of
him with the
camera that's all you have to do is walk
around and then we have to get the top
of his
head okay
that's it so that's all um so we can
take this off now although we should
leave it on if we were actually going to
uh sonicate him so
now we scan him
in and
pallic has an amazing brain and we get
to look at it right here although this
isn't the interesting part of it this is
an MRI he did last
week and what we're going to do is pick
a spot
for a Target the anterior singlet is
going to make him
happy we know that and so okay we
scanned him so these are what the
pictures look like and then this is
making him
3D and this is so we can know where the
the I'll show you what this is does so
here we overlay the 3D MRI with his scan
so we match his bone
structure and then we look at with the
transducers are and we know exactly
where they are and now we sit the Target
and we compute what phase delays we need
on the
transducers and then we nail that Target
I would love to sonicate him on stage
but we don't have permission from the
Thai government
yet however I metant somebody that got
permission to do 200 people at eselon
recently so next year we'll do something
but yeah this is how it works for any
part in your body and the interesting
part is as we develop our read part the
part seeing blood flow we can get away
from the MRI machine and use different
scanning technology that's lower
cost so with that this is somewhat like
a smartphone moment from 20 years ago
smartphones changed our lives look a
silicon Hospital can happen if you think
of your smartphone there's a dozen
radios in it four cameras and so forth
as we populate this it can treat us for
the diseases we have again you might be
asking can I have one my company would
country whatever yes everybody can have
one everyone has permission you can
build your own I'll be showing these
prototypes out in the hall shortly and
thank you
[Applause]
thank you vitalic thank you Mary L
japson it's incredible how this has
progressed um that was an amazing
section so a massive Round of Applause
for the biod defense section and
everything that was in it
[Applause]
woohoo we're going to take a 5 minute
break so stand up just move your bodies
a bit talk to the person next to you
don't leave the room cuz if you leave
it's going to be hard to come back and
we're going to get started again in 5
minutes thank you so much
[Music]
e
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
y
[Music]
oh
all right let's bring back the energy to
the room if you see people outside
please grab
them we've got three more sections left
as we go through this diak journey today
um next up empowering a safer internet
and first up let's invite quintis to the
stage to speak about Hardware security
quintis come and join
us hello everyone uh my name is quintis
I'm from the flashboards research team
and today I'll be talking about secure
Hardware um the sort of premise and the
context for this talk is that uh as the
quote goes software has eaten the world
and as most of you may know software
doesn't run literally in the cloud uh it
always runs on some actual so some
actual hardware and so all of the
digital technology that we rely on uh
today um actually means that we rely on
Hardware uh and so this applies to the
cars that keep us on the roads the
planes that keep us in the skies our
Hardware wallets and our you know
somewhere safe I guess your your uh
password manager on your phone um the
server your bank runs on all of that um
every time we use these Technologies we
make the assumption that the hardware
that is supporting this this technology
is actually working in the way we expect
it to work um and is not actively
working against us um but this
Foundation is not nearly as secure or
rather we have no reason to believe that
it is secure um and that's kind of the
the topic of the talk today
so this is um from Ledger's website for
those of you who may not know Ledger is
a very popular Hardware wallet now
Ledger has every incentive to convince
their customers that they are super
secure and that the hardware um is you
know serving you and protecting your
keys um but if you if you look at their
website what is actually the case is
that even their low-level software some
of it has to be closed along with the
full Hardware design um so this means
that you are trusting the U Hardware
providers you're trusting Ledger um that
the um Hardware is not uh doesn't come
with a back door that it actually has
the defenses that you expect it to have
um and this isn't a a ledger specific
issue um because of the difference
between the open Hardware uh open source
design open fabrication process um
because the difference between that
cluster of things and the closed
alternative Hardware companies have this
choice between more secure more
performant more cost efficient um
products and improving their trust
pretty much everyone has to at some in
some way choose the more efficient
outcome and uh take on board these trust
assumptions now the the reasoning behind
this is is um quite sound in some in
some regard the the user mistakes
software bugs um all the thousands of
hackers out there who don't have access
to your device these are more legitimate
threats and if we were trying to secure
a system tomorrow these are the attacks
we'd spend most of our time on um the
more difficult attacks uh that can be
executed by fewer actors are much less
likely and these are the the attacks
require access to the hardware or um to
be implanted in the manufacturing
process but I don't think that this is
actually a good reason to dismiss um
worrying about Hardware security and one
reason for that is that they actually
just have been uh a lot more um
vulnerabilities than people have
realized or that you know I was aware of
before I looked into this um and you
have to ask yourself if there are
examples of governments implanting back
doors into Hardware of um you know
corporations potentially under the
influence of governments uh implanting
these kinds of back doors um what reason
do we have to believe in this world
where all of the hardware is closed
anyway that there aren't like active
Hardware back doors active troan Among
Us right now like in this room
um and then another angle to this is
just that you may not expect a hardware
manufacturer or someone in the hardware
supply chain to be malicious but they
could just be lazy they could be selling
you chips that are not um up to scratch
and so you expect to get a certain level
of of uh protection when you buy this
this hardware and in reality it is just
a much lower uh much lower degree of
protection and you have no way of of
validating this or it's much harder to
validate and this is um an example from
one particular study a couple years
ago so one part of my motivation here is
like this old piece of wisdom that uh if
you're going to build something you want
to make sure that the assumptions that
this system relies on are strong because
when the going gets tough uh and your
foundation is not strong things collapse
pretty remarkably
um and I guess the image I always have
in my mind as you think of all these
these cars on the roads all everyone
who's using a ledger so so such so much
value in the crypto ecosystem um that's
you know could be attacked in one uh
felt swoop I guess but another more
optimistic take on this uh sort of
securing this this uh rant I I would say
this talk is um in favor of securing
Hardware is that there is um a growing
movement I guess in the crypto ecosystem
and outside of it like the open AI quote
I have up there to use um assumptions in
Secure Hardware to actually do more than
we have been able to today um we are in
an industry of improving uh trust
assumptions and secure Hardware provide
us provides us with another primitive to
improve these trust assumptions and
unlock new use cases um and so if if if
we are able to improve these uh trust
assumptions in the OR to bolster the
security that um um mention to I am here
to say that this is something we should
pay attention to and that it is
something that we actually can do
something about there is no technical
reason or yeah no obvious technical
reason that we cannot uh address this
problem and to make that case I I'll
briefly go through some of the research
that's out there today um that taken to
its completion con constitute some of
the puzzle problem so we can break break
out this problem for um most Hardware uh
into two sub problems and then I'll I'll
speak about two other ones but um the
first is taking a piece of hardware and
being able to actually look at it and
see what is going on Imaging this piece
of hardware and the other is
having something to compare that image
to there's no point in being able to
look at a piece of hardware and see all
of these you know wires and transistors
and uh not being able to compare that to
something for which we understand the
logic so first understanding the Imaging
um I'll point to one sort of research
Direction uh pursued by a guy a legend
uh called bunny um and for context what
has been the issue in the uh Hardware
Imaging world for a while or like one of
the issues um is that Imaging techniques
are destructive or very very
expensive
um what bunny has pioneered is using
shortwave infrared light to image chips
without having to destroy them without
having them to ship them to having them
shipped to a facility in Switzerland the
size of you know several homes um and
this is actually something that we
ideally could scale uh so that there's
testing facilities and you know um as
for a reference this is a this is a
really challenging problem and probably
the one that we as an ecosystem can put
um much of our weight
behind currently as I was alluding to
earlier so much of the technology that
we rely on is closed um
and there are projects that are taking
this problem on headon and are directly
working on either developing their own
open- source IP or on I guess purchasing
from other people um and they are moving
this barrier of trust lower and lower
and lower but still they have not been
able to open um open source the
information we' need to be able to
assert that this uh this piece of
Hardware does not contain contain a
hardware back door and their motivations
are are pretty pretty uh pure from the
other open source uh angles they want
people to be able to itate on their
designs and to not be worried about
vendor lock in but the security angle is
still not completely addressed and so
one thing we can keep we we can do is we
can add our weight to this um to this
movement and and push for completely
open source designs but there are also
um many pragmatic ways to get around
this problem um in which we navigate uh
without going into the details we
navigate this problem of having um you
know Fabs which don't allow for the
low-level design descriptions of chips
to be made public um to to uh circum
circumvent these these closures using ZK
proofs of uh chip validity and and other
forms of proofs and I'll I'll link to
something at the end that goes into that
and so the solving these two problems
solves the the easy case and so um this
solves a case for Hardware that you have
physical custody of this is for your
phone for your Ledger um and
this solving this has already like
changed the world I would say um but I
was talking about tees earlier uh and
using um secure Hardware to be able to
assure someone who doesn't have physical
access to the device that the hardware
is is uh operating correctly to address
this problem we need to solve two other
sub problems one is how we generate a
key and tie it to the hardware in such a
way that we can be convinced that the
key is not compromised and is is
uniquely available to the logic and the
hardware
um the sort of magic answer here is
Puffs which are really interesting
technology that use the inevitable
Randomness in the uh manifestation of
the chip in the physical chip to uh
create a secret and so anyone trying to
investigate the chip to get to the
secret inevitably disturbs the chip
structure destroying the key
um pretty cool
technology uh and one that has actually
been tested out there their existing
Puffs in the world today uh it's not
like Spacey magic um then on the
attestation front the question is how do
we uh now allow someone to investigate a
physical chip and then convince a remote
user who doesn't have access to the
physical chip that this chip is is what
they expect it to be um and in order to
do this uh there are actually some
investigation protocols some
verification protocols that we can
Implement where the user has to only
assume that some threshold of actors in
a committee is honest or rational uh and
there's you know we've uh proposed one
specific protocol for doing this but
there are many um improvements that can
be made to it and so I'll I'll uh
encourage you to to have a look at that
the real point that I was make that I
wanted to make today is that look this
is a a very important problem and it is
a problem that we can solve we've mapped
out some of the technologies that can
solve these problems we've mapped out
the the sub problems that need to be
addressed to enable these Technologies
what's really left um and obviously
there's a lot of work left is energy to
do it buying from the community and if
the if
that the large Hardware companies that
make trillions of dollars in their
incumbent position with the world
relying on them trusting on them have no
incentive to move from where they are in
their comfortable position if they are
if there are a group of people who can
move the needle and breathe energy into
this it should be the group of people
who are working on trustless
Technologies and the group of people who
are trying to improve the trust
assumption in the world and have the
ideological orientation of the people in
this conference venue so this should be
something that we care about because
it's it is an important thing that we
actually can make a difference in
and so I guess my my first call to
action is to go look at this post that
um several of my co-authors and I put
out where we go into more detail about
what I was describing now um there are
many or there are several academic
research teams that are moving the
frontier they need funding there are
several problems that people with like
formal method skill sets with Hardware
design skill sets in this room can
address and I think even more broadly
just having this be acknowledged as an
important problem in our space um will
surface more and more of these people
and so I I hope I've communicated that
to you
today thank you so much
quintis and next up I would like to
invite Marcus H to the stage he is with
Etho and they're building some
incredible Hardware devices that we'll
be learning about today
[Music]
welcome hey everyone my name is Marcus
I'm building uh
ethos um so the first question is what
is eos so three years ago putting eum
into the OS layer because we think that
basically current os's see f as more you
know as an app but we want to really
Leverage The protocol so
what the first thing that we did was
basically put a light note on it and
um yeah and um so for example we have uh
on the uh on EOS we have a system Lev
wallet or Os level wallet so we took
basically a signer put it into the OS
and any app can basically connect to it
and make signature requests to the user
and the uh upgrade for the users they
don't have to switch apps or anything
and it just works there's also basically
uh upgrades to privacy and security and
um basically the reason is uh it doesn't
do any outbound internet transactions so
you also don't need any internet to uh
sign anything also yeah as I mentioned
before we put uh right now on ethos we
have two light client proxies so um when
we first started we uh wanted to put a
the first thing that we wanted to was
put a light note on it and at the time
we didn't have much to choose from uh so
we took the GE light node put it into
into the OS as a system server and
basically what happened was it uh really
turned the phone into a pocket warmer uh
the battery really really uh drained
pretty quickly but it did work when you
uh had a stable internet connection it
would connect to peers and then you
would have a local RPC with which you
can send transactions uh get blockchain
data and also any app could connect to
this
RPC yeah as I mentioned right now we
have Helios and the Nimbus verified
proxy they're both currently light
client proxies not full light clients
because of the merge the um uh ge light
node stopped working because the beacon
chain uh was added to ethereum and so
right now basically you still need an
centralized RPC but it does verify some
pieces of data that it gets from this
RPC so this is pretty cool and also like
for the ux for the user we wanted to
make it so that it's like as simple as
turning on and off Bluetooth or Wi-Fi
you can turn on your light client and
just like have a local RPC on your
phone and so uh this brings me like to
the first issue that we have basically
There is almost no mobile native dabs
currently so um basically I'm a big fan
of like native dabs um currently the uh
like all of the dabs are like web dabs
and then there are some that are
progressive web apps but they still face
the from risk of you know Apple and
Google can shut you down if you are a
pwa and so basically what we created
last week actually is like a um
basically an app wrapper that is a
native it looks and feels like a native
LA and but it actually opens up a web
view that auto injects the OS level
wallet into the web tab so for a user
it's just like you know opening AA and
uh the wallet is connected and you can
start like um
basically uh you know doing transactions
and so um this uh brings me to basically
our announcement from last month we uh
uh announced our first Hardware so
basically what we uh first did when we
first started was basically bring your
own device we have a we have still have
a web installer where you can basically
buy a pixel by yourself at a local store
it has to be bootload or unlocked you
connect your phone and it just just
installs ethos on it for you but like
people ran into some issues so basically
you know because you had to get a
specific pixel and it had to be bootload
or unlocked and some carriers actually
lie about it being bootloader unlocked
and so basically we then started like uh
selling pixels pixel 7A uh running EOS
but then we also came into a roadblock
and basically the the roadblock there
was that uh it's very hard to reliably
get pixels and so we were just like hey
let's do some hard where and so we
started talking with some phone
manufacturers and they sent us like some
phones that they did in the past but
they all really looked bad and we were
just thinking okay nobody's going to
replace their like iPhone with you know
uh random crypto phone and so we thought
to ourselves hey let's first make a
really cool fun and exciting secondary
device that you know because it's a
secondary device it doesn't have to be
boring and basically it's called the D
one because it's our very first device
device and it's our first device on our
journey that we want to like like our
big mission is like self- Sovereign
Hardware um and basically what is
self-sign Hardware I'm glad you asked um
so basically I wrote a blog post about
it last year and for me self-or Hardware
is where basically not only the uh OS
that runs on top of it is open source
which we have currently Etho is fully
open source but also the hardware is
open and inspectable like literally from
the uh CPU instruction all the way to
the app it's a big mission but I think
it's very important because currently
with like um if you look at the current
Hardware wallet landscape for example if
you take a ledger you really rely on
security for obscurity and that's very
very bad especially if you're storing uh
large amounts of crypto on it and
basically um not only that but also
basically uh last year uh there was like
this big controversy if you remember the
Ledger they uh announced like this
Ledger recovery program where they
basically said like yeah uh with a
firmware update we can extract our
private keys and it was like oh my God
uh okay so basically if a ledger uh can
a firmware update can extract your
private key what stops a malicious actor
from pushing a a malicious firmware
update it's basically the uh Ledger
firmware signing key now I assume and I
hope that they hold it very dearly and
very secure but this is like a huge
trust assumption for like every ledger
to be secured by basically one uh Ledger
firm signing key so this is like very
bad and so for uh selft Hardware it's
like a natural use case for crypto
because you don't have to trust there's
no trusted modules everything is open
and like that's the one of the like big
big things with like the current phone
landscape like the iPhones is like the
worst because it's like okay closed OS
and closed Hardware you can insect it on
any level
but with Android it's a little better
you can inspect the OS but you there's
still like proprietary Blobs of code
like for example like Play services and
like uh device drivers for Hardware
which they don't allow you to open
source just like um Ledger they can't
like open source like uh some things on
the like lowlevel stuff and so this is
like you know very bad as as as soon as
you have crypto uh in it as well because
you're like okay I have this phone it's
has uh you know uh this OS and it's open
source but there's still like some
trusted like Blobs of code uh that are
closed source and you can't you don't
know what they
do and so basically yeah that's like our
uh big mission and yeah the DJ one is
like our first step towards that mission
um thank you very
much thank you so much marus
it's really exciting to see all of this
this Hardway being built and next up
we'll have a remote speaker we have
flipped things around so we're actually
going to have Michelle Shen right now
it's different on the program so if
you're confused that's why welcome
Michelle to the screen
[Music]
hello everyone greeting from Taiwan I am
michelon product director at hco today
I'm going to share how H Empower
internet safy through a Community Driven
approach to scan reporting and
prevention
entitled so in the digital world chust
is the fundamental to the online
interaction at hoso we are committed to
building trust by combining cutting Age
Technology like Ai and with global
partnership this approach aim to create
a safe Collective space where user
activity and participant in combating
skills hco was found in uh 2012 and we
are founded by uh the chust te company
Google look so Google look now has a due
headquarter in Taiwan and tyan so for
over a decade we' were collected with
government for while including the
police agency across Asia and to enhance
antis skan uh
solution and we now have the more than
250 employees around the
world so for those who um never heard H
Co before or you never inst H Co so here
I want to um give you a very quick
introduction through a video
[Music]
spee
sh
[Music]
okay so um we just published a book uh
this is a book work include more than
thousands of the skin scammers Cod and
weight is more than seven kilograms so
this book is just a concept that we want
to give a simple uh introduction of Po
cope that is if you cannot remember all
the scammer codes the easy the easy way
to protect yourself is to install H
C so uh why we can do it I think now
because we has the largest number
database in east and south Asia and
every year we uh block more than 2.6
billions of spin call and messages so we
help us to identify the stress and stay
protect every day so now reach the more
than 100 downloads over uh 100 downloads
worthwh so who go over not only the
color identification as uh SMS filter
but we also um evate our new features so
right now we also can help user to do
the personal uh data leaking Monitor and
also we can detect Mr species uh website
and also now we are trying to uh uh
provide some defect SC
detection the reason why we are
consistently in evolving and to meet the
new threat is because the scan uh become
a new normal according to our annual
scan report in APAC only 1.6% of people
they never account scan before in a year
so means that people will at least
account once a month even some the
people uh more than 50% of people they
were accer every single day
and I think the most uh uh important is
that the
scammer they are so SM they were
involved with
technology so with this uh new
technology such as social engineering
fishing and defect The Leverage the data
science big data and AI to power
themselves so that also give us a learn
even at aspers acknowledge that is a
a battle that we cannot win only by
ourself we need to fight with the
network so that's why we want to build
an involving Network to comp better scin
a part of our s and AI technology to PR
scans and public database we also Cate
it with govern including the lawyer type
police most importantly we believe that
we should work with our users soon let
report we can discover the new trending
scin is
happening so who are these the hidden
Heroes what outcome that they contribute
in the past years these report users
they submit over four millions of scin
code reports through husco so who are
they uh after speaking with them uh some
of just the uncle or Auntie that you
will meet every single day so this
Community Driven ever refresh a strong
sense of justice among our users and the
only purpose they want to report is that
they want to pretend they loved like
they believe the report they build and
help more user Pretender SKS so we also
found that this value to share it will
transcending age even gentle and
demographics so while Community Driven
reporting is ex active you also uh ra
some of challenge so such as how we're
going to ensure the report is
trustworthy and we also have some chall
into meeting the regulate uh regulator
compliance so I think uh we also seiz a
uh opportunity such as incorporating
blackchain could author and Report
Origins and data uh Integrity will help
us to overcome this
challenge so in closing Unity is the
essential in competing scale at who
scope we are build for chust and uh join
forest with users partners and
governance to create a s internet
together I think uh we can make a
meaningful
impact thanks for you are listening this
is gole look from this is Nelle from
gole look thank
you thank you
Michelle and next up to finish off this
section um we're going to have Isla and
una come and join us and they are going
to be speaking about Di back as social
Tech from a Swiss
perspective welcome to the
stage thank
you yeah hi everybody uh really excited
to be here talking about
DC um so we want to tell you about Dak
the Swiss way um UD and I are working on
Switzerland which is a network State and
Society sandbox that has yeah so how did
all of this begin um we were at Zulu in
Montenegro and had just an incredible
time literally life-changing experience
uh if you haven't been to a zillu pop-up
City yet um it's
definitely a very different experience
to a conference experience and really
meaningful
and um it's led to us actually really
coming up with a concept of how we want
to launch a permanent Network States
sandbox in
Switzerland um and we're working on a
joint venture Now to create a livable um
living lab uh in in Switzerland in a
beautiful Alpine region so I'm going to
tell you a little bit about
that why a permanent sandbox
um when vitalic made the call to
decentralize the Zulu movement I was uh
very honestly slightly
upset the experience in Montenegro had
been so amazing and I couldn't really
imagine a space like this being created
again in the same way by a random bunch
of people in a decentralized manner um
and I wrote a big post on the aora Forum
about how free social spaces were so
important and that this what was created
with Zulu and Montenegro was kind of
like a social technology that had been
created and a free social space that had
been created where radical social
Innovation and Technical Innovation but
personally most interestingly social
Innovation can happen and um a place
where we can work
with existing models and new models and
experiment and iterate in really
interesting ways and I was worried that
we wouldn't keep that free social space
alive and that sandbox alive if we
decentralized but interestingly we took
the challenge on and we said like well
Switzerland is the home of the ethereum
foundation and it's home to many many
early crypto companies
and if if not in Switzerland then where
should there be a popup city so we went
a bit
deeper and we really started looking at
Switzerland and what can we actually do
in Switzerland as a pop-up City that's
very
meaningful uh and you may know this
quote from balic diak or defensive
accelerationism um essay where he says
actually Switzerland is often considered
to be the closest thing the real world
has to a classical liberal governance
Utopia
and it's very much true um you know
values back and forth uh and everyone's
going to have their favorite thing
Switzerland is an incredible country uh
I've lived there now both of us have
lived there around 10 years and it's
incredibly successful so number one for
Innovation per capita in the world uh
for the last 13 years running uh it's a
direct democracy um and it's still
working and I think that that's what
makes it fascinating it's one of the
only direct democracies and I think a
lot of people are scared that
democracies don't work especially direct
ones uh and Switzerland has made it work
in a way that we think is very very
interesting and they've actually been
working
on decentralization and democracy for
the past 700 years and they've been very
much a part of the humanism move
incredible social technology that's
developed over literally 700 years of
iterating and working together and we
realized as we started thinking about
this more that this is a soci social
technology that we should be building on
top of rather than starting from
scratch um and we realized also as we
looked into it more that the secret
source that a lot of Scholars actually
write about why switzland is successful
is actually defensive accelerationism in
other words um so they Define their
mentality as having a very good balance
between caution and progress uh they
manage to innovate but they do it in a
way where they don't they move reason
ably fast but they don't tend to break
things uh and so Switzerland has managed
to become not only fast and a great
innovator but also a very stable and
strong economy and actually even has for
example a kind of a Ubi um if you become
unemployed for whatever reason in
Switzerland you have up to two years
your income covered by so an insurance
um so instead of leaving people on their
own when something happen
they in they reinvest in the people and
in their human capital and it's quite an
interesting model because it's based on
sort of insurance rather than a purely
um social support um so it's an
incredible place and there's a lot that
we can learn and we believe that it's a
great place for Network states to uh
iterate and to build a Sandbox where we
can build our own kind of network State
and Society but also iterate and build
other network States and societies and
have them build with
us um and core piece here is the balance
of the state between the individual
interests and Collective interests and
this is really what we think that
switzland does well is they balance the
cipher Punk values with this solar Punk
values and when in doubt they protect
individual freedoms and things like
privacy
uh interesting example of kind of some
of the weird stuff in Switzerland so
when you first move to Switzerland they
actually they give you your residence
and your address and then they say and
by the way here are some iodine tablets
just in case there's nuclear war and
it's funny because it's like Switzerland
is probably the last place in the world
that actually expects to have nuclear
war but there you go you get your iodine
tablets um they also have bunkers for
example that could house the entire
population in the case of War um and so
even though they do everything in their
power to actually protect against that
situation they have um ways that they
can be protected from the worst possible
outcome so yeah I would hand over here
to Uno
um based on all of this we've decided to
do an eight-week event in May and June
2025 and have a bunch of you amazing
people over and for a really long sleep
over and to nerd on AI privacy ZK
rationality Dows x-ray governance and in
particular really learn from Swiss
democracy um but there's actually more
to this and una is going to tell you
about
that change the slides I don't know what
to say so um instead of not only
conceptually Isa mentioned a lot about
how we're conceptualizing um Switzerland
as a perfect de um but at the same time
as part of social technology um for
social for creating this safe social
space we think that we want to build
this permanent place at this uh
potential um Park that we can have
residents to come in and different
people come in and have fast iterations
and different products that we can test
in a scale that matters which means that
we can actually accommodate 6,000 to
10,000 people onside and have um testing
all different kind of social
Technologies
onsite and one uh one thing that we
firmly believe is that why we need a
Sandbox in Switzerland is also change
within the regime tends to be
incremental and path dependent we need a
little safe space that we want to create
and carve out from existing good Society
to have a path breaking Innovation and
this is what we see have the potential
with a permanent
location and um as for Switzerland we
believe we have the best ingredients to
make it happen we have really great
people all the zuza people I think I see
half of here probably are zalin and
we're great and then um we have the
culture and philosophy as Isa explained
the Dak and uh solar solar lunar Punk
integration and also we want to have
space and infrastructure to make rapid
iteration happen with all of this I we
think that we can make meaningful
radical social technical uh social
technology
happen and our rough plan from 2025 and
2030 is ADD with 2025 the first two
three years we want to have POA Villages
and Pioneer residency and have a a basic
renovation on uh at the physical
location and from 2026 to 2029 we want
to have experimental Villages and scale
up a little bit and with leing labs and
sandbox and have deep Tech uh on on the
park and with 2030 onwards we want to
have a real high tech civilization
accelerator Village on
site um I was meaningful of uh being
careful with the time I think that's our
slot U thank you for your attention hope
you're excited as excited as us about
this and uh we'll come to connect with
us in the corner I guess that's thank
you thank
you thank you Issa and un that was
amazing next up we have M and way
speaking about programmable cryptography
and diac welcome to the
stage hello everyone so in the next 20
minutes we're going to be talking about
the role of programmable cryptography in
DC programmable cryptography has been
talking about in this conference um you
know in relation to ethereum consistent
protocols and trust oranization
and um I I just want to perhaps s the
stage Ag and to say that cryptography is
fundamentally about trust minimization
and there is a new category a new wave
of cryptographic schemes that can help
us better minimize trust in different
settings and uh maybe perhaps the the
first thing that we'll do here is to
introduce our our panelist muu and muu
has worked for over a decade in
cryptography and maybe can you tell us
briefly about your background and um you
know your experiences in in these
cryptographic Primitives yeah uh thanks
V uh my name is Mutu uh I'm a professor
at Josh toown University and founder of
a zero knowledge company Li hero um I
did my PhD back in 2004 uh under Rafael
pass who is a student of Sylvio mikali
uh I've been doing research in zero
knowledge and multiparty computation for
I think two decades uh now and um uh I
think U one of the things for me just
blockchain ecosystem and the ethereum
ecosystem is that these these Primitives
that we have studied that was discovered
in the 80s are really coming uh to life
uh but today I I guess uh we are going
to talk about more advanced Primitives
um which I would also include like from
FH to Fe witness encryption and
indistinguishability of vcation yeah so
perhaps let's dive straight into it so I
think um most of of us here probably
have heard ZK zero knowledge and MPC
multiparty
computation and uh to probably to a
certain extent I right fully homor
encryption can you explain um the
landscape there and and also uh
functional encryption winess encryption
and indistinguishably officiation what
do these things actually
do so when you think of encryption it is
one way to look at it is that uh with a
secret key you get sort of an All or
Nothing functionality if you have the
secret key you can retrieve the entire
message if you don't you don't you get
nothing these Primitives functional
encryption and witness encryption you
know push these encryption schemes to
what we like to call now programmable
cryptography so let's start with W
witness encryption so what does witness
encryption allow you to do is to encrypt
a message with say a puzzle and the idea
is that you'd be able to decrypt this
encryption only if you know the solution
to the puzzle and this is really
beautiful because you don't need to give
a secret key to anybody the secret key
is the solution to the puzzle now what
could this puzzle be in the in the
context of let's say uh Bitcoins Etc you
could imagine that you know I want to
lock some amount of money for anyone who
can solve uh say the reman hypothesis so
now you can imagine that anyone who can
solve it gets the solution and can
decrypt and get a message which is a
transaction paying you some amount so
witness encryption pushes the boundary
of encryption to the point where I can
now not give a secret key but just be
able to decrypt if I know the solution
to a puzzle functional encryption and
indistinguishability of fation I'd say
is like a little bit of mother of all
Primitives like they you can construct
one from another and also do a lot of
things so functional encryption allows
you to generate like a programmable
secret key this is how I think about it
so what happens is that in a functional
encryption I can encrypt a message and
then I can generate a secret key for a
Target functionality and this secret key
will allow me to decrypt any encrypted
message to reveal just the function
applied on the message so if I say some
function f i can generate a secret key
secret key F that if I hold this for any
Cipher text or any message that's been
encrypted in the scheme I can learn F
ofm now when this was discovered or when
this was defined Etc one of the classic
examples is uh spam filtering so I can
have the cloud just have a targeted sort
of secret key to see whether when an
encrypted message or uh comes to my
inbox to do spam uh filtering but as you
as we will talk today you will also see
that this functional encryption also has
other uh powerful uh uh applications now
indistinguishability of fation I would I
would say probably probably is higher
than witness encryption and functional
encryption it actually has this promise
that I can take any program and obisk it
meaning that I can give it to you in a
way that you cannot reverse engineer the
original code now you should take it
with a grain of salt pure off fisc is
impossible so if someone comes and says
hey can I use indistinguishability
alisation to replace tees this is not
true so yeah I think there a lot to
unpack unpack there continue um so
indistinguishability officiation I want
to say is that it's something that
um it tries to find the right definition
of officiation that is both realizable
and um actually does have meaningful
consequences I'll just stop with the
definition of indistinguishability
obfuscation it says that I can obfuscate
programs in a way that I will not be
able to distinguish the obfuscation of
two programs that have identical
functionality and it seems pretty weak
but this this form of aisc already can
give you witness encryption functional
encryption and uh a lot of other things
so just to recap at the high level if we
have
officiation then that implies winess
encryption and functional encryption
yeah um what about the other way can can
you some the landscape so actually a
strong again with just like with
officiation even functional encryption
there are different definitions there
are different levels of security if you
go for like sometimes s the strongest
form of security it becomes impossible
but for a certain kind of functional
encryption actually you can construct in
distinguishability ofation so in that
sense I would put both of them in the
same category and both of them imply
witness encryption and going back from
witness encryption to these things are
harder got it so wi encryption is kind
of the easiest to get and then
functional encryption iio alisation
could be equivalent depending on that
definition so perhaps let's zoom in on
winess encryption uh for now and I think
one use case that's really sparked my
interest uh in actually looking at wi
encryption is um uh actually being able
to extend the existing protocols without
actually running MPC so one example of
this is uh in ethereum what have
signatures we have already a lot of
validators with existing key
infrastructure and and uh and and the
question is can we actually encrypt to
uh a side of these valuators and and
there the condition right the puzzle
that that you descried before will be
has enough notes signed a
message um so that you would then be
able to to decrypt um and so I think
that's one application where people have
proposed where we could use wi
encryption so just looking at this
particular use case can you describe to
us is this is is this uh feasible right
now do we need custom scheme or do we
need generalized window encryption um so
I mean just uh probably before the tldr
is that actually this is one of of the
recent advancements where witness
encryption for a specific language can
enable exactly this functionality which
is that let's say that I have n signers
for something and I want to be able to
decrypt something as long as I have say
t out of n signatures I can encrypt a
message and the puzzle really is that I
need to have te out of n signatures and
there has been a recent construction
even implemented to show that this
functionality is uh is feasible but let
me just say that general purpose winess
encryption would be to ask can I do this
for an arbitrary puzzle and the answer
is today we only know how to construct
that from obfuscation itself so general
purpose witness encryption is still far
from being practical but for this
specific application it is possible to
do it and I want to say that if you also
Trace history witness encryption it goes
back to even like when you think of cca2
encryption it was a limited form of
witness encryption and since then there
have been some progress but I want to
say general purpose witness encryption
is still uh far way out we'll definitely
zoom in on that um in a later question
but so let's go to functional encryption
and tication I think one of the more
recent uh proposals that applies
functional encryption is to actually
adds features to bitcoin to for it to
become more like ethereum right so there
this thing called Bitcoin Covenant which
is not uh feasible on Bitcoin today and
people have been proposing to use
functional encryption to to get cence
for Bitcoin and the use case there is to
say that ecd a signing key must be used
in a certain way uh only if a condition
on the signing message is true so this
requires computation on the message to
be signed a condition to be checked and
uh a signature to be generated as as the
the function to be computed um can you
comment briefly on this particular use
case and whether that is feasible
currently using uh using tication where
uh functional enpt
okay um it's going to be hard to comment
but I will say that um if you look at
the construction I want someone to
implement it to really see the overhead
although just looking at how I have to
implement the circuit I need to embed
arithmetization of One Prime to another
Prime for elliptic curve operations I
think the overhead the margins are going
to be a lot but that should not deter
people from trying to uh uh implement
this but just to maybe give a rough idea
of uh not the construction but um where
it comes from functional encryption is
that so functional encryption again just
like witness encryption if you want for
general purpose polinomial size
computation you the only way we know is
to do it from indistinguishability
ofation but uh a very restricted form of
functionality is an inner product okay I
take two vectors I want to compute the
inner product can I do this under uh can
this be the function and can I do this
under uh functional encryption and there
are construct structions actually there
are I want to say feasible constructions
to do this now this recent work that has
shown that we can implement this
functionality that we said where if um a
certain condition and this condition
really you can think of it as verifying
a zero knowledge proof then I
will sign a particular message and this
can be again translated into whatever
functionality you want in the underlying
uh blockchain layer and just using this
inner product functional encryption you
can construct uh one that can do this
functionality which is verify a certain
kind of proof and then sign say under
the Snore signatures which are needed
for uh the Bitcoin protocol again I want
to say that um the fact that these
Primitives can be useful for these is
not surprising these are like really um
uh very strong Primitives that have you
know really a vast range of applications
but discovering where it is practical
and feasible uh is still really an
ongoing uh
research got it so perhaps let's zoom
out um a little bit more to more deac
the con of DC more broadly I think one
way to look at where we can apply
programmable cryptography is wherever a
te has been used right so there's two
angles of this um if a te is currently
needed can we remove that uh Reliance on
the te and you know so can you actually
comment
on the difference between trust
execution environments trust Hardware
versus programmable cryptography using
officiation so as I mentioned before
right te can give you what is called uh
close to what's called a blackbox of
fisc and that's a technical term but
what it really means that it can give
you access to a just the input output uh
behavior of a functionality now in
general if you want to realize it
without any hardware assumptions it's
impossible so uh indistinguishability of
fation cannot serve as a replacement for
uh for tees but uh I think maybe I want
to make a Spiel here of a larger point
in general in this area and also
probably because of my sort of
background here is that uh when we all
study now witness encryption functional
encryption IO all of these help to
address
certain adver
or certain um uh certain kinds of
attacks on the protocol actually it can
minimize interaction it can help you
interact with smart contracts better Etc
but I think if you look at it MPC on its
own can solve a lot of these so when we
think about these Primitives we also
need to understand is it that this
attack Vector is why these Primitives
are crucial again I mean I I don't want
to comment on that but this is something
that people have to understand and even
when you have to implement things like
witness encryption and functional
encryption there is going to be a dkg
component the dkg assumption is no
different than what you will have to
make for MPC from a security standpoint
you're going to say hey up to n minus
one of the parties are going to be
corrupted or up to like half of them are
going to be corrupted so from at least
from a number of collusions Etc these
like when you compare MPC and witness
encryption and functional encryption for
these things you can't put them on the
same plate and I'll also say that MPC
today is far more efficient than it was
I want to say like when I started
studying uh MPC so when when we are
thinking about these applications and
these great Primitives uh I would post
this question that hey can we device
first an MPC solution can we deploy it
can we see is this enough like is this
or already going to give you certain
meaningful privacy guarantees yes at the
cost of maybe some denial of service
attacks but uh I do think that in terms
of even realizing the potential that we
are seeing of these things to look at uh
MPC so is it correct to say that there's
a spectrum to something that's very
trust minimized where uh you know we we
actually rely on math in the middle is
NPC right NPC still relies on
mathematical assumptions but we actually
ask certain notes to be honest right and
there's ways to hold them to be
accountable if if they behave
dishonestly which is actually quite open
research area the notion of accountable
MPC which I think is is actually you
know within the the the same category of
programable cryptography um we should do
applications first using you know more
trusted uh w Battle tested Primitives
and then move to things like
tication um so maybe in the in the last
couple minutes um let's explore the
actual feasibility of these more
advanced Primitives um I think the first
result that's peer-reviewed and accepted
by The Wider cryptographic community
that says ication is possible came from
2021 right and can you comment on what
has happened since then uh has people
implemented this this primitive and and
what is the performance like uh yeah
actually um my when I was doing my PhD
my PhD classmate uh hu Lyn she is one of
the authors of this 2021 uh paper that
soled IND distinguishability ofation but
when needs actually understand what did
they solve right when you say that can I
realize in distinguishability of fation
it was like you know at least a decade
back they showed the first candidate
construction based on multilinear maps
but then after that there was this huge
cycle of people you know trying to
Define what is the security of
multilinear maps it you know there were
constructions they were broken there
were constructions they were broken the
alisation construction itself wasn't
broken but the Assumption was broken so
so really in the theoretical Community
it was about trying to find the
falsifiable Assumption based on which
you can construct OB fation and this
jails paper in 21 came up with the first
set of falsifiable assumptions and I
just want to say as a cryptographer for
us our bread and butter is about getting
things using falsifiable assumptions and
that was the huge breakthrough in JLS 21
that you could construct aisc based on
falsifiable assumptions but if you look
at this construction it requir four
different things LPN lwe bilinear Maps
like several cryptographic assumptions
went into constructing this and now
since then what people are trying to do
which again is one of the other sort of
really motivating questions in
cryptography is to minimize the
cryptographic assumptions you don't want
to assume four different things and a
more recent line of work is trying to
get another flavor of a single
assumption which is a ltis base they
Define something it gets broken they
Define something but you know this is a
cycle that you know Theory people are
used to uh in terms of these uh
constructions but just to uh you know
wrap up with the Practical feasibility
of this we are far from alisation being
practical I want to say that there was a
paper I forget now maybe six to seven
years back in crypto where they showed
they did construct an offis that could
do five operations and I mean like
really five gates uh of uh of
computation and that took like hours
hours to run using uh multilinear maps
and that being said you know definitely
research should still go into uh you
know making these things both reducing
the assumptions but also trying to find
out in a limited form can the these
things still be practically
constructed so you know on
this um that's a great question I will I
will first say that I will not bet
against cryptography I know all the
researchers in this field they're making
tremendous progress us uh in doing this
but will it accelerate as much as zero
knowledge and MPC uh I think that's a
little bit of a different question it
really comes from is the community
invested in solving that problem let's
take the the Bitcoin signing example you
don't have this particular op code that
you want that will allow you to verify
zero knowledge proofs uh in my opinion
well if the Bitcoin Community are
willing to bring opcat you can now
verify zero knowledge proofs that is to
me an easier path towards that
particular goal than trying to make a
functional encryption problem uh
solve well I think that's all we have
time
for thanks everyone for paying attention
thank
you thank you m and
way and next we are moving on to
decentralized AI a very important field
as AI is becoming such a massive
narrative so I would like to welcome to
the screen emad unfortunately he's not
able to be here in person today but
we'll have emad followed by Vincent
going through both open and
decentralized Ai and then a daac vision
for decentralized AI welcome to the
screen
[Music]
emad you want
ad unmute there we go hello everyone I'm
sorry I couldn't make it today um but it
seems like everyone having a great time
in Thailand uh bit of introduction to
myself I'm aad moac uh previously was
CEO founder of stability AI where we had
about 300 million downloads of our open
source models from stable video stable
audio but most famously stable diffusion
most popular image model in the world at
one point we were running about 10, A1
100s which is one of the top 10
supercomputers and uh it was quite a
ride and interesting but the original
intention of stability was to be
decentralized there actually me to be a
dow of dows um and earlier this year I
had a big think about that and the
future of AI and where we're going so in
this talk today I'm going to touch on a
few elements of that and try to frame it
and uh how we can impact that now with
my new organization shelling um we've
kind of honed down to we're moving to a
post labor economy so let's try and
build um AI money to stack gpus and
increase the intelligence by Building
open source models and supporting others
so demand side of deepin that's a story
for another day
perhaps I think that there are three
types of AI model and this is where it
becomes very interesting uh the one
that's been most famous has been these
private models these chat gpts and
anthropic Claws and others these are
like expert systems trying to achieve
AGI kind of do everything and the
knowledge that they have in the data
sets they have are private um that's
interesting but I don't think it's that
exciting honestly uh in the middle we
have a different type of knowledge which
is public knowledge that is licensed so
that's Entertainment Innovation licensed
data and weights and i' put metal llama
model under this uh you know open
weights but you don't know what's inside
it on the left hand side I think is the
most interesting which is common
knowledge and we recently wrote a piece
how to think about AI when we like
models are like graduates and uh you
know they're going to come out as
doctors lawyers Etc every industry
that's regulated is likely to require
interesting
part there was a very interesting paper
by anthropic um at the start of the year
called sleeper agents where they showed
why it's important to know the data that
goes in as in what are the ingredients
how the sausage is made with a single
indicator and you can't tune that out
and you can't identify it beforehand so
I think rather than having black boxes
the models that we have to having black
boxes the models that we have to run our
lives will be open source open data the
question is who will build those and who
will coordinate those because the
reality is models are reaching a bit of
a plateau because you can't have that
much higher on language understanding
unless you get to uh full AGI so this is
closed versus open weight models but
models ultimately are a function of
their data and the data sets are getting
better and better and again this Gap is
closing the output of models as well is
getting more and more structured and
more and more deterministic so we
designed stable diffusion to be
deterministic you put the same seed in
you get the same output roughly now
you're getting towards 100% on
structured outputs so these little
models which is a few gigabytes can
transform any incoming data in a
reliable deterministic way when combined
with large context windows that makes a
lot of the problems that we've been
facing as a kind of community a lot
easier and you should really look into
where structured outputs are so open AI
gp4 is now pretty much 100% on
structured
outputs so you have increasingly
intelligent models that are getting more
and more structured more deterministic
um and they're getting a lot cheaper so
Frontier AI is at a 100 times drop in
price um and that's amazing and that's a
combination of faster compute but then
also algorithmic
optimization but I think what's more
interesting is AI equi intelligence so
this a chart from Andreas and Horwitz of
the cheapest LM with the minimum mlu
score uh indic ation of language
understanding again a above 83 is that
graduate level above 42 is you know it's
okay it's not that smart um and I think
this is a log on the left hand side so
it's getting increasingly cheap and what
does that really
mean well for a start that equi
intelligence level is getting above 100
in IQ so you have 120 IQ on open AI o1
model um and that's quite something this
is why they're looking for data sets um
for example xai those of you that are
IMO medalists they're hiring to train
their model to generate synthetic and
human-made data and that's quite
something because o1 is probably a model
that's maybe 30 GB big and yet it has an
IQ over 100 to put that in context this
is average global IQ by country so
where's Thailand on there you know
you're in the 89 or so um the pairing of
humans with AIS that have IQs above 100
will be incredibly interesting and I
think this is what we are going to kind
of look at as we think about how do we
position for an open and decentralized
future this chart however isn't because
anyone's stupider than others it's a
question of
infrastructure
so this is a very interesting chart it's
energy versus wealth so on the left hand
side there's energy consumption by
capita and then there's GDP by capita if
you don't have the energy then it's very
difficult to build the institutions and
Frameworks that you need to have that
level of intelligence to have the
schooling to have the electricity to
have the power I mean leenu in Singapore
said one of the most biggest advances in
there was introducing air conditioning
because it's hard to think when you're
hot you know but this connection between
labor productivity and energy
productivity is being broken by these
models because to remind you of kind of
that drop in
intelligence that purple line to run
llama 3.2 3B requires five watts of
electricity
the original gpt3 required 1,000 wats of
electricity so that's a massive drop and
this comes at the same time as this
chart here which is the solar PV cost
per dollar it's now less than a dollar
per watt of solar PV and a gpt3 plus to
GPT 4 level intelligence only takes 5
wats of electricity to run the compute
required to create it is in the order of
magnitude of 10, A1 100s and I don't
think that will exceed
100,000 A1
100s to give you an idea of 100,000 A1
100s or actually h100s shall we say Elon
Musk superc compute cluster uh Colossus
that's the total emissions of bit tensor
over the next year you know it's about a
week of ETF inflows into crypto so I
think that the compute side of things
becomes interesting the energy side of
things equi intelligence and again let's
bring intelligence of 100 IQ to everyone
so we can lift everyone 100 IQ is
interesting and it's with reach to
decentralize this technology as in have
it completely offline a solar power
plant a solar power panel sorry plus a
chip gets anyone a GPT 40 level AI in a
few years and that's really interesting
to think about because when it comes to
you know cryptography and what we do and
blockchains I think those are amazing
for verification coordination and
resilience and when we think about that
left hand side open source open data
models for the stuff that we need for
living you know the stuff I think many
of us actually joined the industry for
then we need to have verification of
inputs and outputs and now again we can
have deterministic ones we need
coordination to create the data sets and
to bring this technology widely you know
the this incentivization and we want to
be resilient we don't want it to be
censored you know we don't want it to go
down when there's a server error asual
Etc and interestingly just a few
gigabytes and a few solar panels we now
have the ability to distribute
intelligence to the edge with minimal
interaction between them so I think that
we're moving from this era of scale and
again I think 100,000 maybe a million
h100s are all you need qu on that in a
few years um I think that the scaling
hypothesis is showing minimal gains
versus the data underlying and the most
interesting thing now is the spread of
this technology because you're moving
from a research artifact that was
interesting to stuff that's genuinely
useful AI models that outperform humans
on diagnosis and empathy and Medicine AI
tutors that are showing massive impacts
50% of certain industries are now using
Ai and looking at this spread and the
feedback loops from that that's how you
build better data and better models so
when we think about open and
decentralized I think you know you got
not NE models not your mind I'd like to
think that that's the equivalent of not
keys not your crypto I think open models
will run the world it will be the
infrastructure upon which our societies
run and I think you know let's make them
awesome and let's think about leveraging
all this technology and Innovation we're
thinking about to do that because I
think open source and decentralized AI
has a massive advantage over these
centralized ones because you need that
spread you need that reach and as it
goes into everyday life and we leverage
again the systems and infro we've built
we're in Prime position to help build
the infrastructure of the future to make
a difference in people's lives by
increasing the intelligence of every
person of our institutions and
ultimately Humanity so thank you for
that and hope to see you all soon take
care thank you
emed next up we have Vincent weisser
who's going to join us and talk about a
diac future for decentralized AI welcome
to the stage
Vincent thank you and um thank you
everyone for coming so very excited um
to talk a bit about a DIC vision for
decentralized AI so I think in very few
Fields like the kind of like
philosophical um principles of like DC
are more important than than fori where
I think like really we're like kind of
like standing at the crossroads like
this is from vitalik's um blog post on
this where really there's this um two
camps more recently obviously some of
you seen it probably on on Twitter or an
X um on both kind of like the %
probabilities of um us dying as well as
like the extreme optimists who are
basically um talking about like no risk
whatsoever and I think like it's
extremely important to take like the
synthesis of those views because I think
extreme optimism and extreme pism kind
of lead to inaction um and I think the
more realistic view is that like there's
a lot of like um positive things and I
think also a lot of risks and I think
actually quite importantly even the
people talking about the risks they they
often um obviously propose things like
for example alignment and safety but
then it ends up in this kind of like
totalitarian almost like one world
government views of like heavy compute
governance like nation states uh
enforcing things behind closed doors and
and kind of fantasizing about like the
desert project behind closed doors to
build super intelligence with our Bros
like that's that's kind of I think like
a really the dangerous almost like
proposal from like the people building
the technology like the closed Frontier
um AI Labs which are obviously
predominantly based in us and maybe
China um so I think there's kind of like
a middle ground and and I'll talk
through the different four aspects of DC
and we'll try to like bring them back to
to AI so I think on the one side there's
like differential progress and the idea
that um progress is great but you need
to make progress on on things um that
make the world a safer place um kind of
the principle of decentralization and of
open architecture and open source um of
democracy and of Defense so I'll go
through um one by one so kind of like on
the differential uh progress point I
think it's quite important that
basically like uh this point at like not
all technological progress is equal and
um there's some progress which basically
U makes the world a safer place and it's
is great to put in place um beforehand
and basically um accelerate
differentially like basically meaning
that um there's some things which if if
we solve them and a lot of the things we
cover today like bios safety would be a
great example um it's one of the things
also the um AI people are most worried
about is bios safety so if uh we would
wouldn't have to worry about any
pandemic if we would have like all the
vaccines and all the detection um then
potentially there would be less risk
from AI as well um so we we kind of
really need to um accelerate some of
those defensive capabilities that we
discussed today um to have like a safe
kind of like um ground for or um like AI
progress more broadly and I think really
importantly also like enhance kind of
like human agency the second one um is
the centralized and open source
architectures I think this one is
actually um extremely important and um I
think the the problem a bit is that like
the camp taking very short timelines and
like AGI very seriously um is usually
the the closed Source Camp of people
like the open my eyes of the world and
then a lot of the open source people
like examplified Maybe by Lama and Yan
leun um are kind of almost like AI
pessimist I would say like they're they
basically they don't really uh take the
possibility seriously that we'll get
like very fast progress over the next
like five to 10 years so they also don't
take the risks as seriously potentially
um but I do think that like there's a
lot to learn from like open source and
decentralized Technologies and it's
actually incredibly important I think
not to um yeah like build AI in a vacuum
and like single Labs um but rather I
think like building them decentralized
and open source makes it way easier to
be safe because everyone in the world
can like audit can can see the code
right and and can um help improve it and
make it safer and also it's like you
don't have to repeat the effort right
it's like right now every AGI lab is
doing safety but they're doing it in a
vacuum like they're doing the safety
basically five times like they're not
not coordinating on um sharing their
research as much as they could um so I
think really the the core of this is
also like that the natural attendance of
AI is really towards concentration right
like you need a lot of compute um as
also IM touched on so I think there's
basically the natural driver is towards
massive centralization and and also
towards kind of like nation states
capturing it for their own interests um
which I think is is potentially some of
the like the biggest risk from it is
basically is like um almost like very
heavy-handed governments um enforcing
kind of like uh AI governance and policy
and kind of like making very hard to for
individuals to participate um so there's
different elements to this um like I
think there's also obviously kind of
like now more and more things happening
at the intersection of of crypto and Ai
and decentralized AI a lot of it is
still very Nas so um yeah I think
there's a lot of things to do I think
one thing that I think is actually
crucial is that I think even um like
crypto and decentralized AI could
contribute to things like verification
of of specific safety properties for
example um to actually like basically
advance um the technology
safely the the other piece is like
democracy and I think one interesting
element there is that like a lot of the
proposed solutions from the AI Labs is
like um obviously AI governance and
policy but like it it usually happens in
a board of five people that can then
kind of like make those decisions or
behind closed doors in some small
government it's not really like a global
Democratic input into AI like it's
really like limited to a small set of
people so I think
it's extremely important that like
basically Ai and AGI development is like
accountable to the broader public and
and takes like Democratic inputs not
just from like specific countries or
specific stakeholders but kind of like
across the population and really then it
preserves kind of like those Democratic
Values um as well as kind of like
distributes the benefits broadly right
it's like I don't know how many people
really trust in in in like kind of like
the um the changing narratives of some
of the the big closed Labs like openi
that obviously prom is to spread
everything uh like spread the the
benefits from the technology I think
like this promise got weak weaker and
weaker over time so I think um at this
point I think there's very few people
who actually trust them to spread the
benefits of the technology um if they
attempted and and and kind of like
shareholder wealth maximization entities
um the other fourth piece is defense so
I think basically it's quite important
to build um this like protective
capabilities um because I think there
there is obviously very concrete RIS
which are also solvable so it goes back
to like the differential progress It's
like we'll get all the upside from AI
like if we actually um like um build it
in in the open like open source if we uh
make it safe to use and and easy to use
for people um so I think it's actually
quite important that um yeah we also
take the aspect of Defense
seriously yes so I think there there's
like different impact areas to to
highlight for me like open source and
decentralized AI but also using actually
um AI to advance science like all the
areas we heard about today be it
neurotech or or bios safety could be
Advanced with AI and and I'll touch on
briefly before wrapping up um like how
they basically led me to the conclusion
to work on those areas so like I um I'm
building a platform called Prim which is
kind of like a peer-to-peer compute and
intelligence protocol really with a goal
to make it like way more accessible for
everyone to accelerate human progress
and um some of the things we did
recently was for example training large
Foundation model of a 10B model size
like distributed across like Europe Asia
and um the US um as well as like
advancing some um differential like
progress so the First Foundation model
we built was like a
metagenomic um Foundation model that
basically discovers pandemics and
Wastewater so it's like was a project
with teamate MIT and um it's it's a good
example of like the French acceleration
because like wasn't very expensive to
build a model but it helps us now to
potentially discover the next pandemic
extremely early um say at an airport um
so I think there's all of those almost
like opportunities also for like open
source Ai and decentralized AI to
contribute differentially to the
progress that like makes um like AI
progress go smooth and I think the other
thing is really is like there has been a
bunch of like interesting work obviously
on making those systems safer and more
aligned but I think there hasn't been
enough of that kind of work in the open
like in with open source so I think
that's also another huge opportunity for
like decentralized AI so that also
concludes my talk so um the conclusion
is like DC provides like a really
valuable framework for AI and if you
think um like exponent like pretty rapid
AI progresses like out of us then it's
worth taking seriously like the the huge
benefits AI could potentially bring but
also the huge risks and how kind of like
the DC philosophy but also crypto could
play a part in like contributing to kind
of like a positive um outcomes for this
so I think it's like yeah like
incredibly important that basically um
AI doesn't become like captured by like
small um groups or individuals or nation
states but rather that it's like um kind
of like openly accessible and um with
Democratic inputs to everyone um so
that's kind of I think like what D can
contribute to AI thank you
everyone thank you Vincent
and that concludes what we were talking
about with decentralized AI and now we
will be moving on to Rum roll physical
resilience and then we'll go through the
closing panel so stick around we've got
two more exciting talks and then a panel
to wrap up the day as a reminder pay
attention we have three prizes to give
away at the end of the day for those who
remember a few things throughout the day
and next I would love to welcome welome
R Miller to the stage from Ukraine to
tell us a little bit more about his work
thank
[Music]
you I want of actually active
participants in um a lot of initiatives
that happening on the ground in Ukraine
so I I today I'll be sharing more about
what is happening on the ground how
Ukraine um stands out with the crypto
initiatives and how that actually leads
to the physical resilience of Ukraine
before I start um I'd like to um take a
moment
to just think of how many of us actually
day-to-day build credibly neutral
systems but that doesn't mean that we
are ourselves have to be credibly
neutral I think when in the moments of
Crisis that's where the Testament of
crypto really happens and each of us can
contribute to
that uh that's a photo of a lady walking
her do just casually in Ukraine um the
reason for such Darkness as you can see
on the picture is that the 50% of
Ukrainian Energy System has been
disabled because of Russian missiles U
what that means that a lot of day-to-day
activities that every Ukrainian you know
used to do they're changing and they
have they have to adapt to the realities
you can see that
uh that that's uh part of the interview
from Yulan who's a head of uh Foundation
leading a lot of initiatives for
renewable energy in Ukraine and she see
she said that from The Invasion you know
a lot of uh sources of energy that
Ukraine used to uh produce like from
wind power you know the the nuclear and
so on has been destroyed and right now
we are faced with the challenges where
we need to rebuild the systems
uh one of the things that every
Ukrainian probably has either in their
homes or if they're business owners or
you know running nonprofits it's
generators generators fill our
day-to-day lives they help us light up
our homes as well as our you know shops
and most importantly Our Lives
specifically for um medicine you know
that that that pretty much becomes a
difference between life and death for
some
people uh has been some of the powerful
initiatives like points of invincibility
that basically started this
decentralized movement of creating this
uh local places where people can you
know charge up their phones their
devices get get warmer and just just
socialize with others in this tough
times and moving forward I would say
that one of the critical part of the
physical resilience related to energy is
creating more uh smart grids and micro
grids that offer more um
secure ways of people to distribute
powers to their homes and um you know
enable um this uh more reliable
autonomous way for them to power up
their lives so you can see this gra
graph where you know there's Renewable
Power Generation Source then you can
store some of that in the battery energy
that you know can light up your home or
the the the the whole you know units of
the buildings and then you have the
other utility power generation outside
so this this is what's happening right
now in Ukraine we see a lot of uh
different initiatives creating uh this
renewable uh you know renewable
decentralized energy systems for high
schools for hospitals the the photo on
the right is actually hospital and then
you see the high
school uh moving forward to food and
water so by March 2023 11 million
ukrainians has been facing the hunger uh
the reason for that was uh severe
damages for the infrastructure of you
know food and water uh part of that was
um obviously agriculture around 9% of
all Farmland has been just pretty much
destroyed uh and Abandoned and because
of that a lot of farmers they were
basically facing with this problems
where they had to shut down their
businesses unfortunately um nevertheless
um we've seen uh a lot of positive signs
of you know the the the opposition uh
you know people started creating this
different alternative decentralized
networks of food distribution a lot of
organizations that came to Ukraine to
support abroad were using local food to
you know support local economy as well
as uh the powerful use case was with
crypto payments some of the locals
started actually accepting crypto
payments as with the Advent of crypto uh
debit cards uh that became more popular
in one specific case is kovka dump um so
the dump was destroyed by Russian
missile and that was fortunate realities
and despite those realities people are
still you know providing
um food and also evacuating people and
animals uh the reason why were they were
trying to provide food with drones is
because part of that um area was
occupied by Russian so people weren't
able to actually rescue people uh
yeah um and the other uh sort of this
kitchen you know like Army of you around
the country that unit to prepare food
for civilian to prepare food for
civilians and Military this lady on the
right is part of the volunteering group
that prepares around two two a half
thousand meals every single day and I
see I would say so far till today there
was around three billion meals
distributed by one of the largest
organizations in Ukraine
um you know the war um enabled us to
create no ways to you know protect
ourselves while integrating this you
know you know shelters in our day-to-day
L like volunteers you can see me some of
my friends that are trying to rebuild
and becoming more and more creative of
how we are doing this and one of the
things I actually came up with is how
they can engage you know people who like
to raave and people who like to rebuild
so they created this initiative called
like repair together Rave together
basically and it was pretty cool and
actually they ended up rebuilding many
houses with volunteers uh completely for
free only you know the the cost for just
like rebuilding materials
and a good friend of mine John Kristoff
he once asked uh mayor of Lou why
they're not printing buildings to be
able to host the people as there more
more and more people moving to wave so
soon later he actually did that himself
with some of the people so they ended up
uh having this project which is the
largest 3D pin School in Ukraine which
pretty cool and they're now leveraging
you know Ai and Robotics to fasten the
process of rebuilding Ukraine and uh
using also
uh local materials for that for the
internet communications I would say we
have diverse um sort of resilient
connection system with a lot of internet
service providers actually coordinating
and um communicating and cooperating
with each other which enables more
decentralized um movement towards
um enriching and strengthening the the
Ukrainian you know connection at the
same time across all of the Ukraine we
have uh 47,000 starlinks that day-to-day
help us connect with each other
especially that becomes critical in the
areas where other alternatives are
pretty much non-existent because of the
destruction you can see that there's
smart traffic management system where
there's rerouting if there's any D
damage areas load balancing across all
available networks and then there's
day-to-day emergency response teams
consist of the telecommunication
Engineers that are always Deploy on the
ground whenever the work is needed to be
fixed
um then we have Dia app which is
fantastic app built by Ukrainian
government that features more than 130
um government services you know you can
you can have your digital passport your
driving license you can get married in a
matters you can pay your taxes you can
pay your bills whatever you want we can
all do that in um literally within one
app and that app used by over 20 million
people uh it's also provides a lot of
services for internally displaced people
and at the same time they actually
support crypto a lot they introduced
crypto education program uh that
featured within the app for 20 million
people I also contribute a little bit to
make that happen at the same time they
play important role actually in
Ukrainian uh Community they support a
lot of initiatives while also trying to
be a bit neutral uh this is part of the
event we hosted in 2022 we hosted the
hackaton and bomb shelter with like 500
people joining around the world and more
than 100 hackers being with us so so
vitalic also came thank you so much
vitalic and a lot of people yeah were
very happy that even in bomb shelters
you know people can still continue
building um and I would say that you
know crypto has been used in a variety
of ways besides the ones that I
mentioned uh and crypto proved to be
extremely helpful in Ukraine and
actually throughout the the whole like
Wartime the adoption of crypto has
increased drastically um and yeah from
the people of Ukraine I would like to
thank you everyone and before we wrap up
share some some key learnings that
happened so crypto enabled border list
you know coordination and support when
actually traditional systems failed and
I faced that myself in the especially
first days of full scale Invasion
Community coordination both like local
and Global played crucial role on how we
actually help each other and survive and
something that we've seen that wartime
realities showed us that adaptability is
and if we want to have the real resence
decentralization is uh at the core of
that so and with that um I would like to
say thank
you thank you so much
Riv and last but not least before our
closing panel I would like to welcome
David and yeses to the stage for our
last Talk of the day thank you so much
[Music]
hello so um I'm Dave a uh co-founder of
Alliance to feed the Earth in disasters
or alfed also a professor at University
of canbury in New
Zealand uh so aled's mission is to build
resilience uh its vision is feeding
everyone no matter what
uh aled is all around the world has a
board members including Robin Hansen
Andrew Sandberg uh Yan Talen and Martin
Helman who won the uh Turing award uh
for
cryptography uh so one of example of the
catastrophes we work on was there was an
eruption in uh 1815 that caused the year
without of summer in
1816 and there was famine in many parts
of and uh
um there's uh the catastrophes we focus
on disrupt food supply uh greater than
5% of total food production in the
world and there are many such
catastrophes uh one of them is uh abrupt
um climate change and another one is
extreme weather on multiple continents
at the same time and a UK government
study estimated that that alone had an
80% chance of happening this Century but
there are other catastrophes there could
be a super pest uh that attacks crops
that's resistant to pesticides or uh a
super weed that outc competes crops uh
you could also have disruption of
pollinators uh disruption of beneficial
bacteria asteroid
impact and uh most extreme is uh nuclear
winter so if we have a large scale
nuclear war we'd have burning of cities
smoke would go up into the stratosphere
and stay there for up to a decade and
the global climate would uh be severely
disrupted around 9 Celsius drop
globally and the uh agricultural output
would fall about
90% And to put this into the perspective
you can see the yield the number of tons
per hectare the Industrial Revolution
so what can we do about this well we
could relocate cool loving crops closer
to the Equator things like wheat and
potatoes uh also mushrooms don't require
sunlight to grow but there are a number
of of other options uh we could scale up
seaweed seaweed can grow uh around 10%
per day even in nuclear winter
conditions uh we could turn fiber or
wood into sugar so that's cellulitic
sugar we could take crop residues and
make Leaf protein concentrate from them
uh we could build green houses and we
could also do fermentation so there are
several companies that are now turning
natural gas into protein and also some
companies turning hydrogen uh into
protein uh but these companies are not
thinking about how to do it fast in a
catastrophe so that's what we focus
on uh we also look at catastroph
scenarios that could disrupt
infrastructure such as electricity and
these include extreme solar storm uh a
detonation of a nuclear weapon at high
altitude causing an electromagnetic
pulse that could destroy
Electronics uh or a Cyber attack which
which could be AI enabled uh or an
extreme pandemic that could cause people
to be unable or unwilling to report to
critical Industries and then this would
Cascade across Industries
so uh as we've talked about today future
pandemics could be far more severe than
covid they could have the
transmissibility of measles and the
fatality of rabies and have no vaccine
and uh we're not prepared for that could
we scale up some of the technologies
that we've heard about today uh like UV
or in room filtration like we have in
this
room and it would be better if we could
scale these ahead of the catastrophe but
we're not ready yet and that's probably
going to take more like tens of billions
of dollars so what we're interested in
doing is figuring out whether we could
scale them up very quickly with our
current capability in a catastrophe uh
in an extreme pandemic and another
option is uh massively increasing
ventilation from outside and also
sequestering
workers and in terms of uh cost
Effectiveness uh we think that for the
the resilient foods that I talked about
earlier an investment of something like
$100 million could get us research and
piloting of the Technologies and
planning and we have some peer-reviewed
papers uh making the case that this is a
uh very cost-effective way of saving uh
expected lives and also improving the
long run
future uh but in this case in particular
uh we don't need to build big industrial
Pilots this could be done potentially
for for millions of dollars so it' be
extremely cost
effective uh so some of the pilots uh
the uh paper factories actually have
most of the equipment already that we
need to turn wood into sugar uh but we'd
like to actually try it out and convert
a paper Factory into a Sugar
Factory um another pilot we'd like to do
is a resilient satellite so if we had an
extreme solar storm or emps uh the
satellites we have now would be
destroyed quickly but if we had a
satellite that was resilient to these
catastrophes we could get emergency
communication and with just one
satellite in a polar orbit uh it would
be able to get information to everyone
on Earth with just regular cell phones
once per day thank you David you might
have all seen already some of the uh Sol
solution set we as a community can uh
come together and build resilience to uh
Global Food
catastrophes there is a lot more work to
be done um some of the things that we
can do uh using the uh the
decentralization ethos and the defensive
ethos uh from the crypto ecosystems uh
could be communication of crucial
information uh you know we would want to
have the capability and the capacity to
uh distribute Ute uh things like
disaster resilient guides or response
plans when these catastrophe occurs so
one thing that we can do is we already
have decentralized uh you know hosting
and storage through your uh ipfs uh but
we would still need mechanisms that
would help us when we do not have access
to Internet so we need to have such
Technologies uh to be able to um
communicate very crucial information
that could save a lot of lives uh during
such a scenario
we could also build uh software
Solutions uh to enable coordination uh
with uh multiple stakeholders who would
uh do decision making this need not be
during a catastrophe but this could uh
also be done um on a you know without a
catastrophe too uh we can utilize all of
the things that the uh web3 ecosystem is
working on uh for example more
pluralistic decision making and uh using
prediction markets as Robin Hansen uh
was talking about today for um more
informed policy decisions but this time
only to sort of predict uh the different
uh
catastrophes um we can also um have
build um you know govern and launch uh
our own Community owned resilient
satellites uh as uh David previously
explained uh we need satellites which
can be resilient to uh solar storms or
uh
hemps so I want to leave um is with all
of you uh about um a potential idea of a
food resilience Dow to so that we as a
community we can together um build and
govern uh resilience at a planetary
scale um does a dow structure suitable
for this I'm not sure yet but would love
to uh love all of your inputs but there
is so much we can do together um and uh
you know take control of our own
resilience and defense as a
community there are some other simpler
things that we can do uh for example
directly sort of supporting uh the work
that uh alfed uh does through ethereum
uh you can just uh send some e to
alfred. e um some of the things that um
Alfred's working on currently is sort of
mapping out the entire uh technology
road maps so as building a technology
tree uh for food resilience uh you know
one of them could be uh research on uh
Precision fermentation uh you can make
fats from microorganisms but we would
need to still map out what sort of
bottlenecks are there in the industries
and as David pointed out when a
catastrophe occurs how can we actually
scale up very rapidly so we you know we
need to uh have that research uh and
plans available
beforehand uh we we can also do some
really cool Pilots uh we can simulate a
nuclear witer condition uh in the uh
Australian interior uh we can um do a
test uh launch uh of our uh resilient uh
satellite as well so if you're
interested to contribute and help uh my
signal is up there at
y88 uh you can um hit me up um yeah so I
want to leave you with this um about uh
potential Community owned uh resilience
um and if you have any questions uh we
can now take it I think you can go to
the QR code on the side and um have some
questions there and uh thank
[Applause]
you thank you so much yes and David if
you've got questions we'll have you guys
outside and there'll be a number of
different um chairs outside that you can
go and sit at so last but not least well
done what a marathon of a day in diac um
today was incredible from kicking off
the day with longevity and neurotech to
Public Public epistemics biod Defense
decentralized AI physical resilience
thank you all for joining the future is
bright technology is beautiful and
Humanity can flourish with it so on that
note I'd like to welcome back onto the
stage Vincent falic Juan Eli and Robin
Hansen thank you and while they get
seated we've got two Awards to give out
for those who were very attentive
firstly whose brain was scanned and was
on stage earlier today okay I've got a
hand over
there yes come on up to the stage and
get your gift all right the second one I
have is whose talk actually spoke about
these awesome air quality devices what
was the name of the person whose talk it
was
unbelievable no
no yes yes come up to the stage and grab
your
device and on that we'll get started
with the our panelists thank
you awesome yeah so excited to kick off
this panel after such an amazing day and
looking forward to um have a fun chat so
I want to kick it off with a high level
question also for the people maybe that
um didn't see the whole day about kind
of like what D is in in almost like
differentiation to some of the other
movements that came before it from um
effective um altruism accelerationism
like transhumanism all of those
different areas maybe V you want to kick
it off giving kind of like your
definition of like almost like which
movements also um inspired you
potentially and like how you yeah came
to some of those ideas with the egg yeah
so when I was uh started writing my post
on techno optimism I think there were a
few different things uh going through my
head at the same time right one of them
was uh seeing the discourse on techno
optimism and of course Mark andreon had
published his famous eak Manifesto about
a few months before that and the uh
debate between that and AI safety people
that was uh like very very strong at
that time and and um also I think just
an effort to like even make clear to
myself as much as I make clear to other
people and of what even like are the
principles that I'm try that that I'm
like seeking to try to achieve and move
toward and like what is the thing that's
uh like updated to the 20 to the 21st
century that uh um yeah because they at
the time crypto I think has been uh for
a long time following these uh ideas
that originally came around in like 2008
and 2013 and I think a lot of the core
thoughts were based on you know 20
January uh you know 2009 Satoshi or
Central Bank on on Brank of second
bailout for banks and like all of that
stuff right and like those ideas were at
the time already 15 years old and they
were very different from things that at
any like other point in our Our Lives
over the last few years like we've
actually been concerned about and so the
goal was to try to like actually create
an updated philosophy that would bring a
lot of those thoughts together as well
as try to uh make a more concrete
picture of uh like what kind of
productive role crypto could play in
this kind of future and so that's where
the post was born and diac itself is
basically this uh attempt uh to find I I
don't want to just say find the middle
ground because like finding the middle
ground is uh like such a cliche right
and like the whole concept of like you
know being the the third thing is like
so overused that there's like literally
it's like there's this concept of the
Third Way and there's this concept of
the third position and if you look at
what they actually mean they're like
almost opposites of each other I think
it's uh in this case attempt to like
integrate the parts of both that make a
that that I think make the most sense
and uh like Bic try to create something
that is uh like very philos
philosophically coherent in its own
right but that still like actually
brings the kind of future that we
want does anyone of you want to add some
perspective on on your thoughts well
maybe I'll add that um I think in
particular the EA eak debate uh created
a whole bunch of confusion in the world
that I think DC is solving um a lot of
the EA philosophy initially um was
extremely accelerationist was very
oriented towards progress and
accelerating um good positive change um
and crucially EA took on a defensive um
a a selective acceleration path of their
specific specific technologies that you
want to accelerate first and this an
idea that a lot of people pioneered
before EA um as well so these ideas are
older um but then eak specifically took
a very strong position on um just going
all the way accelerate everything you
know minimize um uh uh just just just
accelerate the the path of minimiz uh
Str what is the right phrase like
minimizing free entropy um uh some
something like this where it's just like
try to organize um try to let matter and
computation go as fast as possible um
it's totally fine if AI um you know
grows and obliterates humanity and wants
to minimize uh reorganize a world Nam
paper clips and this was a core of the
this is not like a French belief in eak
that was kind of a mistake it was just a
core component um and so a lot of the
people that think about eak don't know
that um and so the synthesis between EA
and and eak is actually quite large like
the two communities agree on way more
than those communities actually think um
and I think of Dak as a way to um
leverage a lot of the good parts of
those communities leave that set of Mis
of disagreements um kind of behind and
say there's a tremendous amount of
positive outcomes that are possible but
it really does matter which things we
get first and it really does matter how
you Orient the outcomes you could Orient
them towards um bad things or good
things and we have agency in that choice
and so to the extent possible let's try
and and uh minimize the bad outcomes so
it's not a a try to just accelerate for
acceleration sake um and is not a hey
halt all progress uh sort of perspective
which both of those things are now
caricatures of those movements I'm not
trying to say that those that's what
they mean um and just Instead try to
find a much more nuanced perspective of
finding the right path of accelerate
progress but don't wipe yourself out and
and kill the species while doing so yeah
I mean one brief thing I also add is
that I think the EA versus eak frame at
least as it existed a year ago also
created the impression that like whether
it's a hero or a villain Ai and AI
developers are like the only main
character that matters and San Francisco
is the only city that matters and uh
like focusing on a really few small
number of narrow things and uh to me a
big part of diac is also created a much
bigger tent of people working on all
kinds of Technologies and all kinds of
environments that we've seen present
today so I think like kudos to the EA
people because like this is all a
reaction sort of to something that they
kind of kicked off right so I think of
EA as like very like seriously applied
like Oxford utilitarianism right like
the work coming out of like Peter Singer
and and DK parfit and and I do think
that it does have a blind spot which is
it's like very top down and it's very
um convinced of the truth of
utilitarianism as like AAL perspective
and um and I I I think like the eak
reaction is like mostly Vibes uh based
it's like it's not uh it's not similarly
rigorous um and I think that uh diac H
is a much more reasoned reaction to EA
based on pluralism and based on the idea
of like okay maybe like
um you know top down utilitarianism you
use to like decide where to put a bridge
or something like that but in in
ordinary human life there's many other
values that we need to consider
including the values of of of freedom
and human rights and and other things
that we wouldn't um we wouldn't like
Brook a a a like a global totalitarian
state to like stop uh you know uh a
hypothetical risk or something like that
so um so I I see it I see the
one of the the values of the daac
response to EA is like no let's let's
have a more pluralistic
response yeah what I wonder is almost
like as an observation for me is like
talking even to a lot of people like
that consider themselves EA or like E I
think funnily enough like a lot of them
have more actually like a DEC position
but it's it's just like the the meme is
very polarizing right so they're like
get stamped as like this extreme safety
is or D sales or as this extreme
accelerationist but then if you talk to
them like to a lot of the scientists or
researchers or startup people like they
actually have this more like reasonable
Middle Ground position so I wonder like
and I think that there's like a strength
to the meme and like to the the
polarization of like EA or eak that um
say progress studies DC and like other
such movements are missing like they're
not as like edgy right like they're more
reasonable like almost maybe too
reasonable um so I wonder like what your
perspective is on this like is that also
like a risk to take like the synthesis
of like two polarizing views
um or like basically it's like how to
was for Di and um those movements to
succeed in that like mematic Warfare
almost so I got my PhD in formal
political Theory and that contains this
essential contradiction that sort of as
a mathematical Game Theory modelist from
stem we're all about precision and
language and being really clear about
what we say and then this whole world of
slogans and you know teams and all this
sort of vague Flags is just really hard
to navigate uh there's a basic fact that
every one of these labels is vague and
then the it's each sort of pulled and
pushed by its members and its opponents
to an extreme to be a stark thing that
everybody else can criticize easily or
understand easily and then as vitalic
said there's always this temptation of
saying well I'm the reasonable middle
I'm not those crazy extremists but then
the middle is kind of hard to say so I
struggle here to like say what's the
precise thing I could endorse with as
with a respectable stem background and
being trying to be precise and I guess
the thing I would most come to is the
idea that of the D and de accelerate
that uh you know the EA people are often
quite willing to be centralized and
authoritarian in their uh
recommendations and the wise
recommendation is say fine we share your
goals we're going to be careful but
you're dealing with you're you're
invoking some pretty dangerous stuff
there and we think maybe we could do
similar things in safer ways uh like a
more decentralized approach is a bit
safer because there's the danger of
invoking these centers and these
authorities and that's really the thing
that I mean that's kind of what puts off
andreon really he sees them invoking
these centrals and he goes no way no way
I I do not want that at all and he's
trying to take the most extreme position
he can to reject that which then looks
kind of silly On The Other
Extreme I'm curious like um we touch
obviously on a lot of them throughout
the day but if there's specific areas
that you think are most crucial almost
like for differential acceleration and
like for DC to make progress on if
anyone of you want to start on
it the big one that I think is perhaps
most of my mind is neur technology uh
and I think to me and I think there
there's a huge difference in opinion
here
on how far you think AI AGI might be or
ASI might be um if you have different
opinions on the time frame there then
you you probably think differently about
other Technologies um I care about a lot
of them uh a lot of the ones discussed
today um the one that I maybe represent
more these days is neurot technology
because that's the field that is both um
in its infancy to some degree uh has is
has way less energy way less but way
less um
people and capital and it's the one that
I think needs to be accelerated the most
from where we currently are in a
defensive orientation um so that would
be that would be my plug it's uh BCI and
eventually whole brain emulation as a
very large uh hedge to make sure hedge
is the wrong word but as a as a
defensive push uh to make sure that when
we do make AGI or ASI type um uh beings
we don't accidentally create a
competitive species that wipes Humanity
out
um and instead we have a some kind of
smooth upgrade or smooth synthesis um
along the
way yeah I mean I think uh one I mean
I'm a a big fan of neurotech as well but
one other thing I would highlight is the
uh cyber defense and info defense side
of things and I think there the
challenge is basically that like threats
that we get on the internet are rapidly
becoming much more sophisticated right
so uh the as basically the big one big
switch that we've seen between like
literally two years ago and today is
that there is basically no longer any
reliable way to tell that someone is
human just by looking at their pattern
of behavior on the internet and that
broke a lot of things right and uh you
know we're seeing uh all kinds of new
types of scams we're seeing all kinds of
uh like new type types of hacks we're
seeing all kinds of uh you know growing
like this the there is a risk that this
basically becomes this Frontier of like
lowgrade War um war of all against all
that had that constantly risks
escalating into a worse kind of war and
to me the only way of resolving things
like this without um you know basically
taking the Hoban solution which
basically says that there is one small
group of experts that all trust each
other that decide everything for
everyone is to actually like figure out
what is the defense um on that side and
there are a lot of like really uh
interesting Solutions right so like on
the uh on the Cyber side like there's
actually an opportunity to make formally
verify a huge number of things that were
not formally verified before there's a
massive gains in uh specific types of
computer security that have been made
there have been massive gains made on
Hardware like more things happen on
trusted chips um there's uh more work on
making making Hardware more secure
there's uh all of these um like new
epistemic technologies that are being
developed like how do we get to a world
with like five more things that look
like Community notes and like just
seeing more experimentation in that
space happen at a rate that is fast
enough to keep up with the pace of
change on the internet feels like it
could be extremely good for us and uh
and for like our ability as a global
civilization to just maintain cohesion
as we enter this uh age of some form of
AGI and then Super Intelligence coming
to
us uh I agree with all that and and
relatedly I would say um authenticated
comms so like uh so we you know I think
one thing that AI is going to be very
good at is fishing and you know voice
cloning and and doing doing you know
calls on the phone and like our
communication systems are not ready for
this right like U like our phone calls
uh are completely like unauthenticated
and our emails you know are easily
spoofed um and you know the the
traditional problem that uh has plagued
this is public key distribution and
blockchains are actually maybe a great
mechanism for Distributing public keys
and and uh you know we could we could
have um you know a system where you can
be reasonably certain that the you know
that you're talking to the right person
um even in a world where there's voice
cloning and uh so I think that would be
like something that is a near-term like
very practical step but then also like
in a world where uh you know we do have
maybe a militia super intelligence like
it wouldn't be able to exploit that that
Vector right and so it it is both a
near-term benefit to to build something
like that and and also long-term uh you
know safety
enhancing like like I wonder almost like
cutting to the the Crux I think almost
like between D and like some of the
other um movements like I would argue
that a lot of them like actually share
the majority in common like they they do
all of rockets and like bio progress and
progress across every Vector I think it
really comes down to trying to extend Ai
and I'm I'm curious if like on your all
perspective but like I really wonder
like what the position of DC should be
or like is on kind of like um on AI
development specifically because I think
it's it's unclear almost like how to
navigate it I think for a lot of uh
camps and I wonder if there's um because
obviously
promises some of like great like
positives and upsides but also some
potential risks and obviously both the
close source and the open source
Paradigm has risks and the centralized
or the decentralized approach so I
wonder kind of like if you agree that
this is like one of the core differences
maybe also between some of those
technological movements or if there's
some others where DC takes like a
different
position a generation ago I get to play
the old man position here uh we had the
great nanotech debate and I think we
learned a lesson from that which was
Eric Drexler tried very nicely to call
attention to the world to an exciting
technology and honestly paint both the
upside and the downside but the net
effect was people overwhelmingly looked
at the downside and wanted to distance
them from themselves from it and assure
them everybody that like that couldn't
happen and they were just going to lock
it down and something a distant away and
can describe it abstractly in ways that
could you know terrify them uh they
don't react very well so there's a basic
problem here uh that maybe our I fear
there's the problem that a lot of us who
know more about technology in the future
we want to identify with that knowledge
and that difference and we want to
really paint the fact that big things
are coming soon and we know about it and
other people don't and hey you guys you
know you need to wake up and he but the
way most people react to that is oh
there's if you know if they actually
believe you CU mostly they don't if they
actually believe you they're going to
react and say oh my God something Big's
happening something should be done
someone should be in
charge and that's exactly the
[Music]
problem it kind of feel like it's
different uh in maybe the last 10 years
I I I think I I agree with a lot of the
prior decades definitely operating that
way and to a big degree some of the AI
risk is being taken taken that way but I
do think in the last 10 years we've seen
the effect of being able to talk about
the future actually recruiting a
dramatically large contingent of people
to help build it and help accelerate the
build out of that technology um and so I
think these days you know I think it
took a while for the internet to really
percolate through a lot of the world um
but nowadays we are having Gatherings
like this in Thailand we are not
presently in a room in Silicon Valley
talking about the future we are now in
um being able to gather people around
the world on on a range of um a range of
components and so um I think we uh we
have gotten the ability to Marshall
resources around the world well there is
a risk of scaring people and causing
unnecessary or bad slowdowns I
guess I I think it does I think a lot of
people's positions will really Center on
what they think will be the timelines on
AI development
and how quickly we'll achieve some
things because some of those some of the
things you might try to achieve will
feel not um relevant to you uh um now I
tend to take a very conservative
position here in terms of um broadly you
should let as many parties as possible
accelerate the range of things that they
think because um there's knowledge is
not evenly distributed um and is not
equally distributed to everybody so
different people will be able to spot
really valuable components and you
should have a broad rights protecting
system that less people accelerate the
things that they think are valuable but
I do think at least for a set of us um
the the to your AI specific question um
I do think make doing something about
that differentially would be valuable
though I do very much agree that you
cannot quite slow it down and it's
actually potentially even more dangerous
to slow it down yeah I me I think I me
I'll like step out of the Kumbaya a
little bit and like answer the original
question which is what is uh a Crux
between eak and DC I would say diak is
the consequence of the acceleration is
that one thing gets 51% of all of the
Power of human civilization and
regardless of whether that thing is a
nation state um or a uh AI philosopher
God trying to implement a pivotal act
which was like one of the EA theories or
the first corporation that happens to
figure out how to UNL walk the next
scaling law um and uh like I mean to get
spec know like more concrete like I
think you know the way that uh open AI
originally started as this effort that
basically said that um you know for we
uh there are all these big corporations
that are doing closed Ai and so we need
something that is open as an alternative
to make sure that these benefits widely
or reach all of humanity and then of
course as we know four years later they
sacrificed openness for the sake of
safety and then four years after that
they sacrificed safety for the sake of
uh growing and getting even bigger and
like honestly that scares me uh so like
that that's like one explicit difference
for
me I'll take like maybe just like a like
a really agnostic approach I think like
people are going to be people are I
don't put a lot of credibility in like
any of these forecasts right like I
think that
um uh even the experts right you said
like people you know like like lay
people are not don't know what's coming
but like like even the experts are bad
at predicting the effects of technology
and if you think about like I think
about very often um uh the Declaration
of the independence of cyberspace this
document from 1996 John Perry Barlo uh
founder of eff also Lyricist for the
Grateful Dead um and and he thought he
knew what was coming which is that
governments of Flesh and steel were
going to be Obsolete and we were going
to create a society of Mind in in
cyberspace and if I look at the internet
today I don't see a society of mind and
you know tell the people of Ukraine that
government's of Flesh and steel are
irrelevant it's not right and um and so
even the experts don't know um I you
know my my bias is the physical world
still matters not just the digital world
and um I do think you know like if if um
if AI follows the pattern of the
Internet it's going to be Inc incredibly
significant maybe more significant but a
lot of that significance might be
cultural or um you know not in the not
in the in sort of the physical like the
physical to go
badly and if you look at the history of
Regulation I'd say the best
regulations uh and regimes are ones
where they you're responding to pretty
specific problems with a pretty known
context and you have something that
responds to that uh and then you know if
things change you change that and the
worst cases in history like things like
nuclear power or even genetic
engineering or where you're responding
to a pretty abstract concern that hasn't
been very much realized and people sort
of make an abstract response to it that
isn't you know adapted to a particular
context or how the problems that are
realized and that I think the lesson
there is that we overestimate our
ability to see and plan these things and
yes you might Envision various AI
Terrors but honestly so far hardly
anything has happened let's emphasize
this hardly anybody has been hurt at all
by Ai and we're not even close to
anybody being hurt anytime soon by AI so
I would say hold your concerns watch for
things but wait till you see some actual
harm in a concrete context and then
we'll listen to your concerns about what
we should do about that but that's not a
good way to avoid falling off
cliffs well if you have some light in
front of you and you are if you get a
few to the cliff you could stop and I
think I think it's precisely what we're
talking about I think a few of us with
think that we see the edge of the cliff
and we're trying to avoid the edge of
the cliff um and this is not going to
smoothly follow some slope um the there
can be a very uh dramatic drop and I
think that's what's fueling a lot of the
the concern so if we if we take your
analogy of just weight until there's a
bunch of damage um I think that's up
that's true up to a point um but but I
think a lot of people argue um that may
may very well be way too late by the
time you see substantial damage um it
might be uh it might be way too hard to
recover I'm not necessarily you know in
full agreement with that that point but
I think with a lot of people trying to
selectively accelerate on things or
decelerate AI would like take that
position in the history of Technology we
just haven't seen Cliffs of that sort
that's the maybe nucle territory like
you know driving across a Terrain you
might come across
clip but that's even really rare nuclear
weapons we we blew up two and we said
and then we tested a bunch and we said
no more they should cannot be used in
war and I think today we are in a much
better position because of
that but and we said a whole bunch of
things could go wrong if we made nuclear
power and we made sure to stop those and
we sort of killed the whole damn
industry yeah I I very much agree with
you on that part yeah for sure right so
I guess the question is would the world
be better or worse if anyone could buy
both a nuclear power plant and a nuke at
Walmart sense of how big they were and
how expensive and how heavy and a whole
bunch of details about nuclear weapons
that we could respond to in regulating
nuclear weapons they weren't an abstract
defon to ethereum and crypto crypto I'm
very curious like I think the audience
is like largely builders in crypto like
if I'm not mistaken like a a big chunk
um of people in the space and I wonder
this specific advice to um the audience
of Devcon to builders in crypto how they
can like differentially accelerate how
they contribute like an AIC way to
improve the world um like yeah curious
for any I mean one very practical answer
is that crypto is just like a very high
value test bed for cyber and info
defense Technologies in very obvious has
been one of my hopes can actually be a
bridge to building those uh technologies
that could then be helpful to people in
many other
environments yeah hopefully prediction
markets can help us um get better
timelines on any risk on any upside and
and help us with those questions yeah
the probability of a cliff we'll
have good was uh was SPF a
cliff awesome I I was going to plug some
some other ideas so you know look be
find the field and technology that you
think um you uh are passionate about and
know a lot about and you think will most
impact the future and in whatever you do
try to aim for good outcomes at the end
of the day it's the people that are
building things that end up writing a
lot of how these Technologies end up
impacting billions of people in the
world so the values that you imbue into
the technology that you build have a
huge impact in the in the future and so
the today we're massive beneficiaries of
the values of the people that built the
internet and built the web and build so
much of what we use day to-day so as you
go and accelerate some technology imbued
with good value vales to end up with you
know safe outcomes and the best benefit
to as many beings um as possible though
I do agree with the utilitarianism is
probably not the right moral Philosophy
for the future uh but you know overall
like try to do good things um and try to
[Music]
[Applause]
like and that wraps up to the Devcon
team and to all of the speakers for
today thank Youk
[Applause]
[Music]